IMAGINARY GAVEL TO HOLD- WELCOME
TO- OUR FIRST FORMAL. BUDGET SUB
COMMITTEE NUMBER THREE HEARING
GUY AS YOU KNOW WILL BE
DISCUSSING- IN THE- A RELATIVE
AMOUNT OF DETAIL- ARE A WILDFIRE
RESPONSE BUT BEFORE I BEGIN I'VE
BEEN ASKED TO READ SOME
DIRECTIONS REGARDING PUBLIC
PARTICIPATION IN TODAY'S HEARING
TO HELP INSURE THE SAFETY OF
EVERYONE HERE WHILE ALLOWING
FULL PUBLIC ACCESS TO THE
DISCUSSION. TODAY WE'RE HAVING A
PHYSICALLY DISTANT IN PERSON
HEARING IN THE STATE CAPITOL
ROOM ONE TWENTY SEVEN. THE
PANELISTS ON THE AGENDA-
APPEARANCE ARE APPEARING
REMOTELY USING ONLINE TECHNOLOGY
. THOSE WISHING TO TESTIFY IN
PERSON MAY DO SO BUT MUST WEAR A
MASK AT ALL TIMES AND FOLLOW ALL
OTHER POSTED GUIDANCE. AFTER
THOSE IN THE COMMITTEE ROOM HAVE
PROVIDED PUBLIC COMMENT WE WILL
ALLOW PHONE TESTIMONY. THE PHONE
NUMBER TO CONNECT IS ON THE
COMMITTEE WEBSITE. AND SHOULD
ALSO BE ON THE SCREEN YOU'RE
WATCHING OVER THE INTERNET. THE
NUMBER IS. AND THIS IS A PUBLIC
TOLL FREE NUMBER. 877-692-8957
AGAIN THAT'S EIGHT SEVEN SEVEN.
SIX NINE TWO EIGHT NINE FIVE
SEVEN. THE PUBLIC ACCESS CODE
THAT YOU NEED TO USES ONE THREE
ONE FIVE ONE. TWO SEVEN ONE
THREE ONE. FIVE ONE TWO SEVEN.
IF YOU ENCOUNTER ANY PROBLEMS
PLEASE CONTACT THE ASSEMBLY
BUDGET COMMITTEE AT NINE ONE SIX
THREE ONE NINE. 209-991-6319 TWO
ZERO NINE NINE AND A STAFF
MEMBER WILL ASSIST YOU. AND
THERE'S- NO LONGER IMAGINARY
GAVEL THANK YOU- ALL
COMMENTATORS WILL HAVE UP TO ONE
MINUTE TO SPEAK TODAY WE HAVE
SIXTEEN ITEMS ON THE NOT.
MEMBERS WOULD LIKE TO ASK
QUESTIONS AND WE'RE GOING TO
BEGIN WITH ISSUE ONE IN A
MOMENT- AS I MENTIONED ON THE
WILDFIRE AND FOREST RESILIENCY
PACKAGE BUT LET ME- MENTIONED
THAT LAST YEAR WE MADE- AS YOU
ALL RECALL A HISTORIC INVESTMENT
OF ONE POINT FIVE. BILLION
DOLLARS FOR WILDFIRE PREVENTION
AND COMMITTED TO AT LEAST ONE
POINT FOUR BILLION OVER THE NEXT
SEVEN YEARS THIS IS A HISTORIC
INVESTMENT- AND- I AM VERY
GRATEFUL THAT WE WERE ABLE TO
MAKE IT LAST YEAR. AFTER CALLING
ATTENTION TO THIS ISSUE THAT THE
NEED FOR MORE OF FUNDING FOR
PREVENTION FOR SEVERAL YEARS
PRIOR. TODAY WE WILL HEAR FROM
THE ADMINISTRATION ON THEIR
PROPOSAL FOR ANOTHER ONE POINT
TWO BILLION DOLLAR INVESTMENT IN
WILDFIRE PREVENTION OVER THE
NEXT TWO YEARS. AND
STRENGTHENING OUR EFFORTS TO
RESPOND TO FIRES- WE WILL NOT BE
TAKING ANY VOTES TODAY- WILL
HOLD OPEN AND THE- OF THE
ISSUES. THAT WE WILL BE
DISCUSSING. HI BUT THIS IS THE
BEGINNING OF OUR CONVERSATION
AROUND THE BUDGET AND I CAN'T
THINK ABOUT OF A BETTER MORE
IMPORTANT PLACE TO START. THAN
AROUND WILDFIRE PREVENTION. SO
WITH THAT WILL BEGIN- ASSEMBLY
GET MY OTHER NOTES HERE- WE
HAVE- ISSUES ONE THROUGH SIXTEEN
ON THE NON DISCUSSION CALENDAR
AND- WE WILL LEAVE THOSE ON THE
NON DISCUSSION CALENDAR AND MOVE
ON THEN TO ITEMS TO BE HEARD
BEGINNING WITH ISSUE ONE
WILDFIRE AND FOREST THE WELFARE
REFORMS RESILIENCY. PACKAGE. BUT
WE NEED TO TAKE ROTH M. RUSTIC.
THAT'S THE FEDERAL. THE DALLAS
THE COR WILL. HERE SENATE.
FRIEDMAN MULLIN PATTERSON RIVAS
YEAH MATT. I THINK WELL. GREAT
WITH THAT- WE WILL BEGIN WITH
THE WILDFIRE AND FOREST
RESILIENCY PACKAGE- WE HAVE-
APPEARING REMOTELY L- HELEN
KIRSTEN THE PRINCIPLE IN FISCAL
POLICY ANALYST WITH THE L. A. L.
WADE CROWFOOT ARE SECRETARY OF
CALIFORNIA NATURAL RESOURCES
AGENCY JESSICA MORSE DEPUTY
SECRETARY OF FOREST RESOURCES
MANAGEMENT. FROM THE CALIFORNIA
NATURAL RESOURCES AGENCY AND
FROM THE DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE
SERGIO. ASSISTANT PROGRAM-
BUDGET MANAGER AND STEVEN BENSON
PRINCIPAL PROGRAMS PROGRAM
BUDGET ANALYST. MS KIRSTEN. ARE
YOU OUT THERE SOMEWHERE. I AM
WELL THANK YOU SO MUCH. THANK
YOU SO MUCH FOR INVITING ME- SO
WE HAVE IN COMMON- ON THAT
PACKAGE THAT WAS PROPOSED BY THE
GOVERNOR AS YOU MENTIONED IT'S
ONE POINT TWO BILLION DOLLARS
OVER TWO YEAR I'M NOT PROVIDERS
CURRENTLY RECENTLY RELEASED A
REPORT WITH. RECOMMENDATIONS AND
YOU SHOULD HOPEFULLY HAVE COPIES
OF THAT AND THEY'RE ALSO
AVAILABLE ON OUR WEBSITE AS WELL
. THE OVERALL WE FIND THAT A
CONTINUED EMPHASIS ON WILDFIRE
MITIGATION AND PREVENTION.
THAT'S REALLY A LOT OF MERIT-
THIS IS THIS IS PRETTY YEAH THEN
THAT OF REALLY LARGE AND TO BE A
WILD THAT THE STATE ETHICS IN
RECENT YEARS SO ALL OF YOUR
WELFARE OF I'VE JUST BEEN TERREL
OB THAT HAVE A IN THIS- I WOULD
LOOK WE ALSO THINK IT'S
REASONABLE TO SUPPORT A RANGE.
OF ACTIVITIES THAT MAKE BOTH ARE
NOT AND HE'S AND CAN YOU- THAT
ARE CROFTERS MORE IS A TO WHY.
AT PROPOSED IN THE PACK OF THE
PACKAGE INCLUDES PROGRAMS
BACKGROUND THIRD DIFFERENT
PROGRAM ARE PROPOSED BE FINANCED
WHY RANGE OF PRODUCTS RIGHT A
DIFFERENT. OF THIS IS KIRSTEN
WE'RE HAVING A LITTLE BIT OF THE
IN THE ROOM HEARING YOU- I NOT
SURE IF THERE ANYTHING YOU DO ON
A END BUT THERE IS. PLEASE DO.
WE'RE TRYING TO ADJUST THE SOUND
ON THE AND ALSO. OKAY I'LL TRY
TO TALK MORE ABOUT THE IS THIS
HELPFUL YES IT IS OKAY OKAY ARE
YOU JUST YELL AT US. BEGINNING
FROM I THOUGHT ARE YOU CAN WHERE
YOU USED. OKAY THANK YOU SOME-
SO WELL OVER WE FIND THAT THE-
WHILE THERE MAY MAY A LOT OF
SENSE DO HAVE NAY RECOMMEND. FOR
THE TO CONSIDER I THOUGHT ABOUT
YOU MIGHT SPECIFIC CORPORATE
PACKAGE I'M SO FIRST WE- THE
LEGISLATURE CONSIDER WHETHER THE
TOTAL OF FINE PROPOSED AS WELL
AS THE SPECIFIC. PROGRAMS IS
CONSIST WITH ITS PRESS. SO I
THAT THEN WE HAVE OUR THEM KEEP
BACK THAT WE RECOMMEND A LOT CAN
- SEVENTY EXTENT TO WHICH FINE
PRINT AT AND VULNERABLE TO ME-
ID ASPECT NO THERE ARE COULD BE
THAT ARE REALLY. HARD INTO VERY
VOTER TO THESE. ARE SICK MAJOR
IS THAT THE LETTER TO FOR ACTION
ON HIS PROPOSED PACKAGE AND THIS
WHEN DOES NOT SHOULD BE
AVAILABLE TO HELP. LEGISLATIVE
DECISION A- THERE ARE A FEW KEY. THANK THEM FOR ME THAT WE
THINK WOULD BE PARTICULARLY. FOR
THE LEGISLATURE TO HAVE TO THE
SELLING IT FUNDING THIS. SO IT
WOULD BE. FOR THE LATEST TO HAVE
MORE DETAIL ON ROGRAM THAT ARE
PROPOSED FOR USE FOR THE PACKAGE
. SO WE KNOW THAT IN AN OF.
THERE REALLY ISN'T A OF ROOM FOR
ABOUT AT THIS ON THE SPECIFIC OF
WHAT THE GOVERNOR PROPOSED. AND
SO FOR EXAMPLE WHILE MANY
PROGRAMS THERE PROPOSED FINDING
WE'RE- AS PART OF THAT WHILE PER
PACK. THAT AND THAT THE CHAIR
MENTIONED. UNDERWENT A PATH BUT
HERE THERE ARE NEW PROGRAM. LIKE
DOES HAVE MILITARY THIS PROGRAM
IS TO ZERO YAKKING THEY ARE NEW.
I'M AND SOME OF THOSE INCREASE
FOR EXAMPLE A STEP FOR THE- TO.
OF WHAT HE BY- AS AS WE- FIND-
AND- THIS DEMONSTRATE FOREST. SO
WHILE THE NEED FOR. WE THINK
GENERALLY IMPORTANT. WE KNOW
THAT THERE'S- ONE COM ON HOW
EXPECTED BE EMPLOYED. UNDER
RATIONALE FOR THE FOR SPENDING
AMOUNT HELD INTERACT EXISTING.
PROGRAMS SEVEN SOME CASES
THEY'RE MAKING THE PROGRAMS I
COULD FIND. TAKES OF THINGS. WE
THINK THOSE ARE REALLY. QUESTION
THAT THE LETTER OLD TO BUY AND-
BEFORE ACTION PROVIDE SOME TIME
FOR. THE TO COME FORWARD WITH A
DETAILS BE VERY. ALSO WE NOTE
THAT AND THERE ARE I KNOW
PROGRAM THAT WERE FINE AS PART
OF PASSED. THERE PROPOSED
BRITISH FUNDING AS PART OF THIS
PACKAGE. I MEAN EVEN THE
IMPORTANT TEN ONLY FOR ME. ON
WHAT PLANNED FOR THAT. BY THINK
. I'M ANYTHING THERE THERE'S
SOME OF QUESTIONS THAT BUT- ALSO
I THINK EVEN FOR. ON PROVIDED
FIND. OVERSIGHT HEARING THE
MINISTRATION IS REALLY MADE A
LOT OF PROGRESS IN GETTING EARLY
ACTION FINDING OUT THE BEST
AJORITY OF. HIS HAVE GOTTEN OUT
BUT AT LEAST AS OF DECEMBER ONLY
ABOUT 7% OF THE TWENTY ONE
TWENTY TWO FUNDING HAD BEEN
COMMITTED TO PROJECTS AND OF
COURSE ONCE. SPENDING IS
COMMITTED IT STILL. TAKES A
LITTLE WHILE FOR THOSE- PROJECTS
ACTUALLY- BE COMPLETED SO. NOT
SURPRISINGLY IN MANY CASES
INFORMATION ON THE OUTCOMES OF
THE PREVIOUSLY APPROVED BY AND-
IT'S PRETTY LIMITED AT THIS
POINT- WE DO EXPECT THAT MISSION
OPERATION SHOULD BE AVAILABLE IN
THE COMING MONTHS WE THINK THAT
THAT. ADDITIONAL INFORMATION
SHOULD HELP INFORM LEGISLATIVE
DECISION MAKING- AND WE WOULD
KNOW IN PARTICULAR THAT THE
LEGISLATURE AB REQUIRED
ADMINISTRATION TO COME FORWARD
WITH AN ANNUAL REPORT. AND THE
FIRST OF THOSE ANNUAL REPORTS IS
EXPECTED IN APRIL AND SO WE HOPE
THAT THAT WILL INCLUDE SOME
REALLY HELPFUL INFORMATION. ON
WHAT HAPPENED WITH PASSED
FUNDING THAT CAN HELP INFORM.
FUTURE DECISIONS BECAUSE YOU
WANT TO SEE OKAY WELL WE ARE
THERE SOME PROGRAMS THAT HAVE
BEEN BETTER AT GETTING FINDING
OUT THE DOOR QUICKLY. ARE THERE
SOME THAT HAVE REALLY
ACCOMPLISHED MORE AND MAYBE
THEY'RE AREAS YOU WANT INVEST
MORE MONEY- RELATIVE TO OTHER
AREAS. WHEN YOU SEE HOW IN FOR
THE LEGISLATURE TO CONSIDER ALL
TO THE TO FUNDING. SO THIS.
CLOSE ISN'T THAT POINT BILLION
BASIC BE EQUALLY AND THE NEXT TO
AND BUDGET YEAR YOU'RE ONE. I'M
REALLY WE THAT THERE'S A TRADE
AND CHECK ASSOCIATED WITH THAT
APPROACH IN SOME CASES- FOR
EXAMPLE THERE SENATE TO THAT
REALLY REQUIRES SUSTAINED
FUNDING NOT JUST ONE TIME
FUNDING TO BE MOST EFFECTIVE.
EXAMPLES ABOUT OR THINGS LIKE
SOME OF THE FORCE HEALTHCARE
PROJECTS- DEFENSIBLE SPACE IS
ANOTHER EXAMPLE AND IT TAKES A
PROJECTS FOR EXAMPLE THAT- YOU
GET NOT JUST BENTENG BRIGHT YOU
KNOW MEDITATION GROWS BACK ON
THOSE PROJECTS HAVE TO BE
MAINTAINED. THEY HAVE TO
CONTINUE TO OCCUR WE HAVE JUST
THE SCALE OF THE WORK THAT NEEDS
TO BE DONE ALSO IT IS VERY
SIGNIFICANT SO IT'S KIND OF AN
ON GOING KIND OF ACTIVITY THAT
THE LEGISLATURE WILL PROBABLY
WANT TO FIND- SO YOU MAY WANT TO
THINK ABOUT WHETHER IN SOME
CASES ONGOING FUNDING IS
APPROPRIATE- WE DON'T THINK YOU
THANK GOD YOU'RE F. IT'S
PROPOSED. TO LAST FOR THE NEXT
TWO YEARS BUT THAT- THE GENERAL
FUND COMPONENT IS ONLY A TWO
YEAR PEACE. I'M AND WE ALSO KNOW
THAT THERE ARE SOME PROGRAMS FOR
WHICH THERE'S NOT A LOT OF
DETAIL AT THIS POINT ON WHAT'S
HAPPENED SO IT MAY BE HARD TO
FUNDING DECISIONS FOR BEYOND
JUST THE BUDGET YEAR. BURKE
TWENTY THREE TWENTY FOUR TWENTY
SAMPLE OF THAT WOULD BE FOR
EXAMPLE HOME GARDENING PROGRAM
WHICH IS JUST GETTING OFF THE
GROUND NOW VERY VALUABLE AND
POTENTIALLY BUT THERE'S NOT A
LOT OF DETAILS ABOUT EXACTLY HOW
IT'S GONNA WORK. AND THERE'S NOT
A LOT OKAY BECAUSE AGAIN IT'S A
NEW PROGRAM THE BUDGET THAT YOU
JUST FUNDED LAST YEAR IT'S JUST
GETTING OFF THE GROUND. SO YOU
CAN SEND TO YOURSELF BUT YOU
ALSO CONSIDER TO SPENDING ONE
YEAR- SEEING HOW. YOU'RE
COMFORTABLE WITHOUT TENS AND
THEN MAKING- ADDITIONAL
DECISIONS LATER. THE FOURTEENTH
ARMY RECOGNITION WE HAVE A THAT
ALLEGED. MEMBER TO PROVIDE
STATURE GUIDANCE TO. THE IN. YOU
SHOULD HAVE SOME. CAN YOU ITS
OVERSIGHT ACTIVITIES. IN THIS.
SO WE REALLY COMMENDED. ON THE
COMMITTEE THAT A LOT OF
OVERSIGHT. ON THE- ISSUE IN
RECENT YEARS I THINK THAT'S
REALLY VALUABLE BUT WE THINK
THAT'S GONNA BE. CONTINUE TO BE
REALLY IMPORTANT HERE BECAUSE WE
SPENT A LOT OF MANY OF THE STATE
EVEN IF THE LEGISLATURE IS
REALLY DEDICATED A LOT OF
RESOURCES IN THIS AREA- IT'S A
REALLY IMPORTANT AREA AND WE
THINK IT'S GOING TO. BE CRITICAL. AND LEGISLATURE. THESE
DECISIONS ABOUT HOW FUNDS SO
REALLY IN. YOU CAN TO MONITOR
THE BUDGET THE ADMINISTRATION
PROGRESS. I'M INCLUDING THESE.
AND GAME LAST LEARNED TO INFORM
FUTURE. I'M SO THOSE ARE OUR
MAIN RECOMMEND. CRAPPIE TAKING
QUESTIONS FROM THE COMMITTEE.
THANK YOU COMMITTEE MEMBERS ANY
QUESTIONS. YES MISTER SMITH
THANK YOU VERY MUCH ON AB ELEVEN
OH THREE IT DOESN'T REQUIRE
ONLINE CLASSES. NO. THAT WOULD
BE BETTER DRESS ALLEN IS THAT
BACK I RECALL- OKAY ONE. GOOD
MORNING THIS IS STEPHEN ABOUT
WITH FIVE I CAN I CAN TAKE THAT
- EIGHT YOU IF YOU DOES NOT RE
THE TO ONLINE IT JUST REQUIRE
THE COURSE TO BE DEVELOPED. WE
ARE PROPOSING ONLINE COURSES
BECAUSE WE BELIEVE IT IS THE
QUICKEST. THE MOST EFFECTIVE WAY
TO GET THE COURSES AVAILABLE-
FOR LIVESTOCK PRODUCERS IN MOST
TIMELY TIMELY MANNER. OF ALL THE
BILL PROPOSALS THAT THE BCPS WHY
IS THIS THE ONLY ONE THAT
CALIFORNIA IS NOT ABLE TO
IMPLEMENT ON TIME. IF IT CAN GO
ONLINE. WELL THERE'S THAT
REQUIREMENT IN THE LEGISLATION
THAT THERE BE SOME OVERSIGHT
FROM STATEWIDE TRAINING- EIGHT
OUT OF THE NAME THE LAST TIME I
HAD SORRY BUT THERE'S SOME
OVERSIGHT FROM STATEWIDE
TRAINING- GROUP THAT HAS TO BE
DONE AND IT TAKES SOME TIME TO
DEVELOP THE COURSE CURRICULUM SO
IN TALKING WITH THE OFFICE OF
STATE FIRE MARSHAL AND LOOKING
AT THE TIMELINE TO DEVELOP THE
CURRICULUM. TO GET THE OVERSIGHT
REVIEW- THAT'S NECESSARY AND
THEN TO GET IT POSTED AN
AVAILABLE ONLINE- THAT THAT'S
JUST THE TIMELINE THAT THEY CAME
UP WITH MY UNDERSTANDING TALKING
TO MEMBER DOLLY THAT THERE IS
OTHER COUNTIES THAT ALREADY HAVE
THE THIS PROGRAM IN PLACE WOULD
BE JUST AS EASY TO GO GET IT
FROM THEM AND YOU WON'T HAVE TO
GO THROUGH ALL THAT THAT. COULD
CHANGE THE WILL OF THE WAGON- I
WOULD NEED TO TALK WITH THE
OFFICE STATE FARM MARSHALS TO
WHETHER OR NOT THOSE EXISTING-PROGRAMS- HAVE TRAINING
CURRICULUM AND HOW THAT MATCHES
WITH THE- REQUIREMENTS WHAT THEY
NEED TO SET UP. FOLLOW UP WITH
ME TOO BECAUSE THERE'S ACTUALLY
NO NEED TO REINVENT THE WHEEL
ANOTHER COUNTY STARTED TO
ANOTHER STATE AGENCIES DOING IT.
THAT WE SHOULD ALREADY BE ABLE-TO IMPLEMENT A PRETTY QUICK. AND
NOT HAVE TO POSTPONED UNTIL JULY
TWENTY FOURTH NEGATIVE. THANK
YOU. FOR YEAH I WE WILL
CERTAINLY. UP ON IT I DON'T KNOW
WHETHER OR NOT THE- RATING
TIMELINE PROHIBITS THE PASSES
FROM BEING ABLE TO BE YOU KNOW A
PROGRAM THE USE OF AS I RECALL
THE- BILL AS IT. PASSED THE LAWS
FOR EXISTING PROGRAMS TO STILL
FUNCTION EVEN BEFORE THE
TRAINING IS AVAILABLE SO. I
THINK THERE ARE SOME THINGS THAT
WAY BUT WE'LL CERTAINLY FOLLOW
UP WITH THAT OBSOLETE FOR
MARSHALL WE CAN GET BACK WITH
DROPS. MISREAD DID YOU HAVE A
QUESTION. I DO AND I DO CAME IN
FOR THE HEARING ABOUT PORTS SO I
MISS MOST OF YOUR PRESENTATION
SO THIS IS THE WRONG PLACE FOR
THIS QUESTION. JUST LET ME KNOW
. BUT MY QUESTION IS ABOUT THE
GOVERNOR'S WILDFIRE EXPENDITURE
PLAN. SO IF THEY CAN IS THIS AT
THE RIGHT TIME TO ASK THAT. YEAH
OKAY SO MY QUESTION IS THAT A
CLEARLY. POST WILDFIRE.
RESTORATION IS GOING TO BE
VITALLY IMPORTANT AND I'M
HEARING A LOT OF CONCERNS FROM A
LOT OF GROUPS ABOUT FIRST OF ALL
MAKING SURE THAT WHATEVER IS
DONE IN TERMS OF RESTORATION
PROVIDES NATIVE PLANTS AND
HABITAT FOR OUR NATIVE ANIMALS
AND JUST I CAN JUST SAY
ANECDOTALLY WATCHING WHAT'S
HAPPENED CERTAINLY IN THE PAST
WITH REFORESTATION AT LEAST IN
MY AREA WAS CHAPARRAL. THERE'S
BEEN A TERRIBLE HISTORY OF
PEOPLE PLANTING NON NATIVE
PLANTS- INAPPROPRIATE PLANTS
HAVE BECOME WE'VE LATER OR NOT
OPEN NOT PLANTING AT ALL AND
ALLOWING FOR INVASIVE PLANTS TO
COME BACK- I'M WONDERING WHAT
KIND OF OVERSIGHT DO YOU EXPECT
WOULD YOU RECOMMEND THAT WE HAVE
FOR THESE REFORESTATION POLICIES
TO NOT ONLY MAKE SURE THAT
THEY'RE APPROPRIATE AND DONE
USING. THE BEST SCIENCE WITH AN
EYE TOWARDS MAINTAINING
CALIFORNIA'S. MADE OF
BIODIVERSITY BUT ALSO MAKING
SURE THAT THEY'RE RESILIENT TO
CLIMATE CHANGE SO THAT IF WE DO
EXPECT. THAT CLIMATE CHANGE IS
GOING TO CHANGE THE MIX OF WHAT
PLANTS CAN SURVIVE. THAT WE
DON'T THAT WE THAT WE DO ALL OF
OUR EFFORTS WITHOUT RESILIENCY
IN MIND SO THAT WE PROTECT OUR
INVESTMENTS AS WELL. I THINK
THAT'S A REALLY REALLY IMPORTANT
POINT AND I WOULD THINK ONE OF
THE MOST IMPORTANT THINGS IS
PROBABLY UP FRONT WORK THAT THE
COMMITTEE IS DOING- SO THERE'S A
HUNDRED MILLION IS PROPOSED AS
PART OF PACKAGE FOR
REFORESTATION. LIKE FIFTY
MILLION EACH YEAR. I'M STILL GET
A LOT OF PROMISE I THINK THAT
THERE IS- PRETTY BROAD. THAT WE
NEED TO BE WORKING ON MAKING
SURE WE DON'T GET TYPE
CONVERSION MAKING SURE THAT
THEY'RE APPROPRIATE. TYPES OF-
PLANTS THAT ARE NATIVE AND THAT
ARE REALLY GOING TO BE
RESILIENT- THAT ARE THAT ARE.
BACK IN THAT LANDSCAPE AFTER
THIS EXPERIENCE VERY SEVERE
WILDFIRES- BUT I THINK IT'S-
JUST MAKING SURE THAT WE'RE
COMFORTABLE WITH WHAT THE
ADMINISTRATION IS PROPOSING
ABOUT THE LEGISLATURE IS
COMFORTABLE WITH IT. AND I THINK
I'M ONE OF THE CHALLENGES AT
THIS POINT WE DON'T HAVE A LOT
OF DETAIL ON THE SPECIFICS OF
THEIR PROPOSAL FOR THAT FIND
THOSE FUNDS FOR EXAMPLE. SO I
THINK I AM PERHAPS ASKING THE
ADMINISTRATION TO PROVIDE A PLAN
FOR HOW THEY EXPECT TO USE THAT
AND THEN HOW THEY'RE GOING TO
INTERACT WITH SCIENTISTS AND
OTHERS. TO HELP INFORM THE
ADMINISTRATION OF THOSE DOLLARS
I'M SAID THE LEGISLATURE CAN
REALLY FEEL CONFIDENT THAT
THEY'RE GOING TO BE DONE THAT
THAT CAN BE DONE IN A WAY THAT-
CONSISTENT WITH. BEST PRACTICES
AND ITS PRIORITIES AS WELL.
REALLY I'M A VERY IMPORTANT
FIRST STEP AND THEN OF COURSE
I'M HERE THERE'S ONGOING
MONITORING AS WELL BUT I'M YOU
KNOW IT'S BETTER IF WE GET A
THAT GET IT RIGHT UP FRONT
RIGHT- MAKE SURE TO DO IT RIGHT
UP FRONT AND I AND I. AM
EXPECTING MINISTRATION PROBABLY
HAS HAD SOME PLANS THERE BUT- I
DON'T THINK WE'VE SEEN A LOT OF
DETAIL YET. I KNOW THE
ADMINISTRATION IS VERY COMMITTED
TO BIODIVERSITY SO I WOULD
EXPECT THEM CERTAINLY TO SUPPORT
THESE GOALS- BUT WE ALSO HAVE TO
MAKE SURE THAT. WHATEVER FLOWS
VERY NATURALLY CAN EXECUTIVE
BRANCH AN UP AND DOWN THAT WE-
ALSO MAKE SURE THE PEOPLE ON THE
GROUND WHO ARE DOING THIS WORK.
REALLY HAVE OVERSIGHT AND REALLY
HAVE TRAINING BECAUSE I HAVE
SEEN JUST REALLY EGREGIOUS
EXAMPLES FROM THE PAST OF WHAT
HAPPENS WHEN IT'S DONE WRONG AND
I'LL JUST SAY ONE OTHER THING
IT'S NOT REALLY A QUESTION BUT-
THERE'S STILL A LOT OF CONCERN
FROM. FOLKS- FROM UC DAVIS AND
OTHERS WHO STUDY WILDFIRE AND.
RISSOIDAE REFORESTATION AND
RESETTING NATIVE PLANTS. THAT
SOME OF THE- BROAD STROKES THAT
WE DO WITH PAUL. THAT MAY WORK
OKAY IN SORT OF NORTHERN. FOR A
THAT AREA ARE STILL UP I STILL
YOU. IN SOME WAYS AND CHAPARRAL
AREAS IN SOUTHERN CAL. WITH
DETRIMENTAL EFFECTS TO. HABITS
AND A LOT OF EXAMPLE THAT
THEY'VE SHOWN ME. WHERE NATIVE
HABITAT IN SOUTHERN CALIFORNIA'S
BEEN DISRUPTED OR- BURNED IN
APPROPRIATELY- AND ALLOWING FOR-
INVASIVE TO JUST TAKE OVER. SO I
JUST WANT TO MAKE SURE THAT YOU
KNOW WE'RE USING. OUR SCIENTISTS
AND THAT YOU KNOW CAL FIRE WHO'S
BEEN A PRIMARY CONCERN IS
RIGHTFULLY ON. FIRE RESILIENCY
ALSO HAS SORT OF BEEN BEDDED
PEOPLE WHOSE. GOAL IS
BIODIVERSITY. AND PROTECTION OF
OUR NATIVE- ARE NATIVE- ECO
SYSTEMS IN THE MIX AT ALL TIMES
SO THAT THE WHATEVER THEY DO.
DOESN'T THAT WE'RE WORKING AT
THE SAME PURPOSE AND I GUESS
THAT'S MORE OF A COMMENT BUT I
THINK WE NEED TO BE. MORE
DELIBERATE AND MORE INTENTIONAL
ABOUT THIS BECAUSE I HEAR THE
LEVEL OF ALARM. UP FROM SOME OF
OUR SCIENTISTS GIVEN THE THREATS
OF. CLIMATE CHANGE TO THE SAME
HABITATS THAT WE JUST HAVE TO BE
SURE THAT. IN OUR VIGOR TO
PROTECT. LIFE AND PROPERTY WITH
FIRE WHICH OF COURSE. IS
IMPORTANT THAT WE DON'T
SACRIFICE OUR COLLEGE AT THE
SAME TIME. SO THESE ARE ALL
IMPORTANT QUESTIONS- AND I'M
GLAD YOU'RE ASKING THEM AND I.
PROBABLY SHOULD HAVE- BEGAN BY
SUGGESTING THAT WE WAIT UNTIL
ALL THE PRESENTATIONS HAVE BEEN
MADE BEFORE IF IT'S ALRIGHT WITH
MEMBERS- I WILL DO THAT-
BIKESHARE FONG YOU MAY WANT TO
MAKE SOME INTRODUCTORY REMARKS.
NO OKAY THEN I THEN I WOULD ASK
THAT WE JUST HOLD OUR QUESTIONS.
IT'S NOT YOUR FAULT. IT'S RIGHT
AT. THE ABSOLUTELY MY- IT THANK
YOU FOR CALLING ME OUT OF SO-
THAT MORE DON'T WE ON- I
SECRETARY CROW FOR TO- AND TO
HEAR PRESENT. THANKS SO MUCH
CHAIRED AND OF THE COMMITTEE AND
CHAIR AS ONE OF SURE YOU CAN
HEAR ME OKAY YEAH WE COULD. WE
CAN HEAR YOU LOUD AND CLEAR.
YEAH I'VE GOT THIS. LEARNING
SOME OF THE MAJOR CHALLENGES
THAT WE CONTINUE TO FACE ON
WILDFIRE BUT ALSO POINTED TO OUR
COLLECTIVE PROGRESS WHICH IS
POSSIBLE BECAUSE OF THE
INVESTMENTS THAT YOU MADE LAST
YEAR IN THE BUDGET BUT ALSO
FRANKLY AS YOU SAY CHAIR HAVE
BEEN CHAMPIONING FOR MANY YEARS.
I ALSO APPRECIATE THE QUESTIONS
ASSEMBLY MEMBER SMITH AND
FRIEDMAN AND I'LL I'LL I'LL
ADDRESS THOSE WITHIN THE CONTEXT
OF WHAT I'M GONNA PRESENT WHICH
IS ESSENTIALLY THE CONTEXT OF
OUR BUDGET PRESENTATION HERE
TODAY I'M GOING TO BE ASLEEP
GONNA TALK A LITTLE BIT ABOUT
THE LAST FIRE SEASON OUR
STRATEGY AMIDST WORSENING
WILDFIRE CONDITIONS- HOW
INVESTMENTS HAVE BEGUN TO MAKE A
DIFFERENCE AND THEN OF COURSE
WHAT WE'RE REQUESTING I HEAR
TODAY THROUGH YOUR BUDGET SUB
COMMITTEE. SO AN OVERVIEW OF THE
LAST WILDFIRE SEASON IS
OBVIOUSLY IT WAS A ROUGH ONE.
FOR OF THE STATE'S LARGEST
WILDFIRES IN OUR HISTORY BURNED
LAST SEASON. EIGHT THOUSAND
EIGHT HUNDRED WILDFIRES BURNING
OVER TWO AND A HALF MILLION
ACRES. MUCH OF THOSE ACRES
EXPERIENCING HIGH SEVERITY
BURNING THAT ESSENTIALLY
DESTROYED. HOMES AND COMMUNITIES
IN THEIR PATH BUT THEN OBVIOUSLY
THE ECOSYSTEM AS WELL. FOR THE
FIRST TIME IN OUR STATE'S
HISTORY TO WILDFIRES ACTUALLY
CRESTED THE SIERRA NEVADA.
HASN'T HAPPENED IN A HUNDRED AND
SEVENTY YEARS OF OUR STATE
HISTORY THAT WAS OF COURSE THE
DIXIE IN THE CALDOR FIRES. IN
THOSE FIRES. THOSE WILDFIRES
WERE JUMPING LITERALLY FIVE
HUNDRED FOOT CLIFFS. THERE WERE
FLAMES ARE ADVANCING THREE MILES
AHEAD OF THE WILDFIRE FRONT. AND
IN CERTAIN AREAS WERE BURNING
OVER TWICE IN THE SAME FIRE. WE
KNOW TRAGICALLY COMMUNITIES OF
GRIZZLY FELT FLAT AND GREENVILLE
WERE DECIMATED. A LOT OF
DESTRUCTION OF OUR UPPER
WATERSHEDS WHICH PROVIDES A THE
BEGINNING OF OUR SORT OF WATER
SYSTEM FOR ABOUT 60% OF THE
STATE'S WATER SUPPLY. TOSE
WATERSHEDS EXPERIENCE THAT HIGH
SEVERITY VERY DESTRUCTIVE FIRE
BASED ON HOW HOT WILDFIRES ARE
BURNING NOW. WE LOST 15220% OF
OUR INCREDIBLE GIANT SEQUOIAS
OVER THE LAST COUPLE OF YEARS. I
SO THOSE ARE OBVIOUSLY ALL THE
CHALLENGES THAT DEMONSTRATE THE
WORSENING CONDITIONS FOR
WILDFIRE. REMARKABLY THEY
ALTHOUGH I KNOW CIVILIAN LIVES
LOST I IN THE LAST WILDFIRE
SEASON FRANKLY DUE TO HER ROIC
ACTIONS OF CAL FIRE AND THEIR
SISTER AGENCIES. WE KNOW THAT WE
NEED TO CONTINUE TO EXPAND AND
STRENGTHEN RESPONSE CAPACITY I
AM PROUD TO CALL CAL FIRE THE
MOST SOPHISTICATED WILDLAND
FIREFIGHTING FORCE IN THE WORLD.
I'M GOING TO COLLECTIVELY
CONTINUE TO BUILD THEIR CAPACITY
MORE FIREFIGHTERS MORE EQUIPMENT
MORE TECHNOLOGY. THAT'S
DISCUSSED IN OTHER PORTION OF
THE BUDGET BUT WE ALSO KNOW WE
CAN'T RESPOND OUR WAY OUT OF
THIS WILDFIRE CRISIS AND YOU ALL
HAVE BEEN GIVING VOICE TO THAT
REALITY FOR MANY YEARS. NOW WE
KNOW WE HAVE TO TAKE PROACTIVE
UP FRONT ACTIONS TO REDUCE THE
THREAT OF CATASTROPHIC WILDFIRE
. WHILE THESE WILDFIRES ARE
GETTING WORSE THE GOOD NEWS IS
THESE INTERVENTIONS ARE GETTING
BETTER. WE SAW THE LAST WILD
FIRE SEASON EFFORTS LIKE
STRATEGIC FUEL BREAKS PRESCRIBED
FIRE HOME HARDENING ACTUALLY
WORK TO PROTECT COMMUNITIES AND
ECOSYSTEM. GREAT EXAMPLE IS
RIGHT AROUND SOUTH LAKE TAHOE
WHERE I WALKED. LINES ARE THE
PROTECTED NEIGHBORHOODS AND
ALLOWED. FIREFIGHTERS TO TAKE A
STAND TO PROTECT THOSE
NEIGHBORHOODS AND THOSE WERE
MADE POSSIBLE BY STRATEGIC FUEL
BREAKS THAT WERE PUT IN OVER THE
LAST SEVERAL YEARS SIMILAR FROM
FUEL BREAKS PROTECTED THE
COMMUNITY OF POLLOCK PINES. DOWN
THE FIFTY. SO THESE PROJECTS
SHOW US THAT WE ACTUALLY KNOW
WHAT WE NEED TO DO TO BUILD OUR
RESILIENCE TO CATASTROPHIC
WILDFIRE. WE OBVIOUSLY HAVE TO
TAKE ACTIONS WITHIN COMMUNITIES
ARE MORE HOME HARDENING MORE
DEFENSIBLE SPACE BETTER PLANNING
WE NEED TO TAKE ACTIONS AROUND
COMMUNITIES MORE OF THESE
STRATEGIC FUEL BREAKS THAT ALLOW
WILDFIRES TO MAKE A STAND
PROTECTING COMMUNITIES. AND GIVE
THOSE RESIDENTS TIME TO EVACUATE
AND OF COURSE LANDSCAPE LEVEL
PROJECTS THAT BOTH REDUCE THAT
SEVERITY OR THE HEAT AND SIZE OF
THESE WILDFIRES AND THEN ALSO
HELP US PROTECT THE HEALTH OF
THE FOREST AND THE LANDSCAPES.
WE KNOW THAT THIS HAS TO BE
BASED ON REGIONAL PRIORITIES. I
AS ASSEMBLY MEMBER FRIEDMAN
POINTED OUT OUT IT IS NOT A ONE
SIZE FITS ALL SOLUTION IN
CALIFORNIA WHAT WORKS IN THE
SIERRA NEVADA. OESN'T WORK IN
SOUTHERN CALIFORNIA AND VICE
VERSA SO ALL OF THESE WERE ALL
THESE PROJECTS WHICH WILL TALK
ABOUT ARE BASED ON THE NEEDS
THAT CHALLENGES THE
OPPORTUNITIES IN EACH REGION.
AND OF COURSE ALL OF THIS WORK
NEEDS TO BE BASED ON THE BEST
AVAILABLE SCIENCE WHICH IS A
VALUE THAT WE ALL SHARE IN
COMMON. NOW LOOK LET'S BE HONEST
WE KNOW CALIFORNIA CAN'T DO THIS
ALONE YOU KNOW TE FACTS WHICH
ARE- 57% OF OUR FOREST LANDS IN
CALIFORNIA ARE OWNED AND MANAGED
BY THE FEDERAL GOVERNMENT. ARE
STATE ONLY OWNS 3% OF THOSE
FOREST LANDS BUT YET OUR STATE
GOT A BUDGET HAS SUBSIDIZED
MANAGEMENT ON THOSE FEDERAL
FOREST LANDS. BACK IN THE SUMMER
OF TWENTY TWENTY GOVERNOR NEW
SOME SIGNED WHAT WAS A HISTORIC
SHARED STEWARDSHIP AGREEMENT
WITH THE U. S. FOREST SERVICE.
THAT FOR THE FIRST TIME CREATED
SOME VERY CLEAR SHARED
COMMITMENTS THAT WE NEED TO BE
HELD ACCOUNTABLE FOR INCLUDING A
MILLION ACRES OF WILDFIRE
RESILIENCE PROJECTS ON OUR
LANDSCAPES EACH YEAR BY TWENTY
TWENTY FIVE. THAT STEWARDSHIP
AGREEMENT SETS OT ESSENTIALLY
LIKE A TWENTY YEAR PATHWAY FOR.
SHARED COORDINATED EFFORTS
BETWEEN FEDERAL AND STATE
AGENCIES. WE BREATHED LIFE INTO
THAT AGREEMENT THROUGH RESHAPING
THE WILDFIRE AND FOREST
RESILIENCE TASK FORCE WHICH IS
CHAIRED BY MYSELF AND THAT HEAD
OF THE U. S. FOR SERVICE IN THE
REGION. BUT ALSO INCLUDES OUR
COMPANIES ARE CITIES OUR STATE
CONSERVANCIES ARE RESOURCE
CONSERVATION DISTRICTS ARE
ACADEMICS REALLY BRINGING
EVERYBODY TOGETHER WITH AN ALL
HANDS ON DECK APPROACH TO THIS
PROBLEM. THAT TASK FORCE
DEVELOPED A VERY CLEAR AND
SPECIFIC ACTION PLAN. WITH
NINETY NINE ACTIONS THAT WE ARE
TAKING TO BUILD OUR WILDFIRE
RESILIENCE. AND THAT WE WANT TO
BE HELD ACCOUNTABLE FOR. SENATE
BILL FOUR FIFTY SIX LAST YEAR
CODIFIED THAT ACTION PLAN AND
REQUIRED. BOTH WE SUBMIT AN
IMPLEMENTATION PLAN BUT THEN ON
ANNUAL REPORT. SO THIS ONE POINT
FIVE BILLION DOLLARS OF
INVESTMENT THAT YOU ALL MADE
LAST YEAR THIS A STORK
INVESTMENT. I IS ALL FOCUSED ON
ON AN ENABLING THOSE ACTIONS
THAT WE'VE SET FORTH IN THE
ACTION PLAN. WELL GOOD NEWS ON
THE FEDERAL FRONT WITH JUST TWO
WEEKS AGO THE DEPARTMENT OF
AGRICULTURE ON THE FEDERAL LEVEL
THE MOTHER AGENCY FOR THE U. S.
FOREST SERVICE. ANNOUNCED TEN
YEAR STRATEGY OR ACTION PLAN FOR
IMPROVED WILDFIRE RESILIENCE IN
FEDERAL FORESTS. GLAD TO REPORT
THAT THIS ESSENTIALLY MIRRORS
WHAT THE WORK OF THE TASK FORCE
AND OUR ACTION PLAN AND
ULTIMATELY IS GOING TO BE
MANIFESTED IN CALIFORNIA THROUGH
THAT SHARED. TASK FORCE WE WERE
GRATIFIED THAT THE VICE
PRESIDENT CAME TO ST BERNARD
DINO IN RECENT DAYS AND
ANNOUNCED AN ADDITIONAL SIX
HUNDRED MILLION DOLLARS OF NEW
FUNDING FOR OUR RECOVERY AND
REFORESTATION. HOW TO ASSEMBLY
MEMBER FREEMAN'S POINT. SO
INVESTING AT SCALE IS ESSENTIAL
AS MISS CHRISTINE ARE POINTED
OUT WE HAVE TO CONTINUE TO MAKE
THESE INVESTMENTS THIS CAN'T BE
A ONE OFF INVESTMENT. THE STAFF
SIZE THE SCALE THE SEVERITY OF
THE PROBLEM REQUIRES SKILLED
INVESTMENT OVER TIME. IS ONE
POINT FIVE BILLION DOLLARS THAT
YOU ALLOCATED LAST YEAR WAS HAS
BEEN A DIFFERENCE MAKER- THERE'S
OF OURSE THE EARLY ACTION
FUNDING THAT YOU FIND IT. TOOK
REMARKABLE EXTRAORDINARY STOP OF
EARLY FUNDING R. FOUR FIVE
HUNDRED THIRTY SIX MILLION
DOLLARS FOR- FOREST OUR
RESILIENCE PROJECT WILDFIRE
RESILIENCE PROJECT. I'M REALLY
GLAD TO REPORT THAT THAT. TURNED
INTO THREE HUNDRED FIFTEEN NEW
WILDFIRE RESILIENCE PROJECTS. SO
YOUR ABILITY DO APPROVAL OUT
FUNDING IN APRIL LET US GET A
JUMP START ON THOSE PROJECTS
MANY OF WHICH MADE A DIFFERENCE
IN THE LAST WILDFIRE SEASON
COUPLE OF EXAMPLES OUR STATE
COASTAL CONSERVANCY USE THAT
FUNDING TO FIND A GRAZING
PROJECTS TO REDUCE WILDFIRE
RISK. AND THAT PROJECT ACTUALLY
STOP THE A LETHAL FIRE IN SANTA
BARBARA COUNTY. IN ITS TRACKS
AND ONE OF THE FRONT OF THE FIRE
I PROTECTING HISTORIC
STRUCTURES. AND I YEAH IN A
COMMUNITIES AROUND. OUR SAN
DIEGO CONSERVANCY I WAS ABLE TO
USE THAT FUNDING FOR A WOOD
CHIPPING PROGRAM TO CREATE THE
SPENT DEFENSIBLE SPACE AROUND
TWO TWO HUNDRED LOW INCOME HOMES
IN SAN DIEGO. AND- SANTA MONICA
MOUNTAINS CONSERVANCY USED
FUNDING FOR AN ARSON WATCH
PROGRAM THAT FOUND ILLEGAL
FIREWORKS OVER THE FOURTH OF
JULY WEEKEND AND THEN PREVENTED
IGNITIONS IN THAT SANTA MONICA
MOUNTAINS ON RED FLAG DAYS. SO
THAT EARLY ACTION FUNDING IS
ALREADY DEMONSTRATING SUCCESS
AND WE LOOK FORWARD THIS
PROVIDING MORE I'VE- INFORMATION
ON THAT. ALSO ACTIONS THAT YOU
TOOK AT THE LEGISLATURE SHIFTED
OUR BUSINESS PRACTICES TO ALLOW
THAT THOSE PROJECTS TO GET DONE
MORE QUICKLY. LEGISLATIVE.
CONTRACTING RELIEF ENABLED TEN
DATE. ON RATHER A ONE YEAR
TURNAROUND THINK ABOUT HOW MUCH
THAT. EXPEDITES THE WORK. GRANT
TIMELINES WITHIN OUR AGENCIES
WERE REDUCED. TO A FEW MONTHS
RATHER THAN THE SIX TO NINE
MONTH PROCESS THAT IT USUALLY
TOOK. AND IMPORTANTLY WITH. A
LOT OF DIRECTION AND NOW BECAUSE
EVEN THE LEGISLATURE WE FUNDED
SHOVEL READY PROJECTS THAT WERE
WAITING TO START. THAT'S THE
EARLY ACTION FUNDING THEN OF
COURSE- YOU ALL A FOLLOW UP IN
SEPTEMBER AND FUNDED NINE
HUNDRED EIGHTY EIGHT MILLION
DOLLARS WHICH IS REALLY DESIGNED
FOR SCALE AND TO BE SPENT
OVERTIME. I'M GLAD TO REPORT
ACTUALLY EVEN AN UPDATE ON THE
LEGISLATIVE ANALYST'S UPDATE TO
YOU THAT OVER TWO HUNDRED TWENTY
FIVE MILLION DOLLARS OF THE NINE
EIGHTY EIGHT. HAS ALREADY BEEN
COMMITTED AND OUR VISION WITH
THAT IS TO SAY IS TO OBVIOUSLY
GET AS MUCH FUNDING OUT THE DOOR
AS POSSIBLE BUT ALSO CREATE
BEGIN TO CREATE A PIPELINE OF
PROJECTS. BASED ON REGIONAL
PRIORITIES. THOSE REGIONAL
PRIORITIES REGIONAL PRIORITY
SETTING- IS MAKING GOOD PROGRESS
THANKS TO A SPECIFIC PROGRAM
THAT YOU FUNDED CALL THE
REGIONAL FOREST AND FIRE
CAPACITY PROGRAM. WE'RE
LAUNCHING THREE PILOT PROGRAMS
I'M HOME HARDENING IN SAN DIEGO
LAKE AND SHASTA COUNTIES WE'VE
NOW GOT A LIDAR REMOTE SENSING
ON TWO THIRDS OF OUR CRITICAL
WATERSHED THANKS TO SCIENCE
FUNDING THAT YOU. THAT YOU
ALLOCATED THAT WE ARE ABLE TO
LEVERAGE A U. S. GEOLOGICAL
SURVEY FEDERAL FUNDING FOR. JUST
EARLIER THIS WEEK THE
INFRASTRUCTURE BANK APPROVED
THROUGH THE CLIMATE CATALYST
FUND I ACTUALLY BUSINESS.
FINANCING FOR. BUSINESSES FOR-
THAT ARE TO TAKE THIS BUDGET.
OUT OF THE FOREST THAT'S BEING.
REMOVED FOR WILDFIRE RESILIENCE
PURPOSES AND PUT IT TO ECONOMIC
USE. AND OUR COLLEAGUES AT THE
OFFICE OF PLANNING AND RESEARCH
HAVE FIVE PILOT PROJECTS TO
ACTUALLY UTILIZE THAT WOODY
FEEDSTOCK IN PARTNERSHIP WITH
BUSINESS. AND THEN LASTLY THAT'S
CALIFORNIA VEGETATION TREATMENT
PROGRAM IS ESSENTIALLY ONE STOP
SHOP FOR PERMITTING FIRST SEEK
WHAT FOR FISH AND WILDLIFE
PERMITS AND FOR WATER BOARD
PERMITS- IS NOW IN ACTION AND
IT'S STARTING TO BE USED I THINK
WE'RE GONNA SEE A LOT MORE USE
OF THE CHALVEY T. P. OVER COMING
YEARS TO. EXPEDITE PROJECTS.
ULTIMATELY THAT FUNDING THAT YOU
ALLOCATED LAST YEAR. NOT ONLY
GOES TO CAL FIRE WHICH IS OF
COURSE OUR STATE'S PRIMARY FOR
STREET DEPARTMENT BUT TO TWENTY
ONE DEPARTMENTS ACROSS FORTY
PROGRAMS. RECOGNIZING THAT THIS
ALL HANDS ON DECK EFFORT. SO
THEN MOVING TO THIS YEAR AND OF
COURSE THE PRESENTATION TODAY
OUR CURRENT BUDGET REQUEST OF
ONE POINT TWO BILLION DOLLARS
WILL ALLOW US TO CONTINUE TO
BUILD ON THE PROGRESS. I MAKE
INVESTMENTS CONTINUED
INVESTMENTS IN EXISTING PROGRAMS
THAT I'VE TALKED ABOUT. LET US
MAKE PROGRESS IN THIS ACTION
PLAN BASED ON REGIONAL
PRIORITIES AND THEN I HAS
POINTED OUT ACTUALLY FUND SOME
NEW PROGRAMS. SO JUST QUICKLY
THE BREAKDOWN OF THE OVERALL
BUDGET IS UP FOR OUR RESILIENT
FORESTS AND LANDSCAPES FOUR
HUNDRED EIGHTY TWO MILLION
DOLLARS WHICH INCLUDES A DIRECT
INVESTMENT FOR OUR TRIBAL
GOVERNMENTS IN OUR TRIBAL
PARTNERS WHICH IS QUITE
IMPORTANT TO US. SUPPORT FOR
SMALL LANDOWNERS TO ACTUALLY
MANAGE THEIR LANDS. IN FUNDING
FOR THIS THIS WORK ON STATE LAND
HOLDINGS LIKE OUR FISH AND
WILDLIFE LANDS AND OUR STATE
PARKS. A HUNDRED MILLION DOLLARS
IN A NEW PROGRAM FOR
REFORESTATION RECOGNIZING THAT
THE CRITICAL NEED. FOR TO
REFOREST ARE THESE THESE LANDS
ARE THE BOTH IN SOUTHERN
CALIFORNIA NORTHERN CALIFORNIA
AFTER THE FIRES. THREE HUNDRED
EIGHTY TWO MILLION DOLLARS FOR
THESE PROTECTIVE FUEL BREAKS
FORTY FOUR MILLION DOLLARS FOR
COMMUNITY HARDENING AGAIN WHICH
WE EXPECT TO LEVERAGE MORE
FEDERAL FUNDING- A HUNDRED AND
TEN MILLION DOLLARS IN TARGETED
REGIONAL INVESTMENTS. THIRTY
EIGHT MILLION FOR SCIENCE BASED
MANAGEMENT AND ULTIMATELY FORTY
FOUR MILLION DOLLARS FOR- FOR
SECTOR ECONOMIC STIMULUS TO GET
MORE OF THESE BUSINESSES
ACTUALLY UTILIZING THE
VEGETATION THAT'S COMING OUT OF
THE FOREST. I'M REALLY EXCITED
ABOUT THE WORK THAT'S HAPPENING
TOTALLY AGREE THAT IT NEEDS TO
HAPPEN AS QUICKLY AS POSSIBLE
ASSEMBLY MEMBER SMITH WILL
FOLLOW UP ON YOUR SPECIFIC
QUESTION ABOUT THAT PROGRAM.
WE'VE BEEN FOCUSED LIKE A LASER
I'VE BEEN PERSONALLY FOCUSED ON
DRIVING THIS PROGRESS FOR IT AND
I AM PROUD OF OUR PROGRESS A LOT
MORE WORK AHEAD AND WE LOOK
FORWARD TO SHARING DETAILS WITH
YOU ON HOW AREPROPOSED ONE
POINT TWO BILLION DOLLARS OF
ADDITIONAL INVESTMENT. WILL
PROPEL MORE PROGRESS MOVING
FORWARD. THANKS SO MUCH CHAIR.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH- DID TO.
YOUR DEPUTY SECRETARY MORE SO
HAVE- ADDITIONAL COMMENTS FORCE
. THE OKAY ANSWER QUESTIONS
THANK YOU. EXCELLENT THANK YOU-
THEN THAT WHEN WE HEAR FROM THE
DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE. THANK YOU
MISTER CHAIR STEPHEN BANDS WITH
THE CURRENT FINANCE I DON'T HAVE
ANYTHING ELSE TO ADD BY WAY OF
PRESENTATION AND THE SECRETARY
DID THAT OBVIOUSLY PHENOMENAL
JOB OF THAT SO I JUST BE
AVAILABLE AS WELL TO ANSWER
QUESTIONS THAT MAYBE. GREAT
THANK YOU THEM NOW WILL I GO
BACK TO OUR QUESTIONS TONIGHT I
THINK MS RIVAS- WAS. WAITING
WITH A COUPLE OF QUESTIONS AND
MR FONG SEEMS TO HAVE LEFT US
FOR A MOMENT- THANK YOU MISTER
CHAIR- THANK YOU TO THE
PRESENTERS FOR THIS UPDATE- I-
LIKE TEARING- HOW EARLY ACTION
FUNDS- WERE BEING USED LAST YEAR
THANK YOU FOR THOSE UPDATES- I
HAVE COMMENTS ON THE- WOODY
BIOMASS TRANSPORTATION SUBSIDY-
YOU KNOW I. HOPE THAT WE GET
MORE CLARITY ON OR IF YOU
ALREADY HAVE IT ON HOW THOSE
FUNDS LIKE WHO WOULD QUALIFY FOR
THOSE FUNDS- AND- HOW WILL WE
KNOW HOW OLD THE BIOMASS IS
BEING PROCESSED. YOU KNOW HOW
WILL WE BE TRACKING THAT- AND
IT'S JUST. I FEEL LIKE THERE'S
NOT ENOUGH CLARITY RIGHT NOW IN
THAT ITEM. THE END OF YOUR
QUESTION SO WHAT IF I AM NOT
TRANSPORTATION SUBSIDY IS REALLY
ADDRESSING A GROWING CRISIS IN
THE FOREST WE HAD TO DEVOTE AN
ENTIRE FIRE ENGINES CHIU SLASH
PILES AND REMEMBER SOME OF THE
SLASH PILES ARE THE SIZES OF
LARGE BUILDINGS SMALL STRIP
MALL- AND AT THE FOR SERVICE AT
ESTIMATED THAT THERE WERE ABOUT
FORTY THOUSAND FOUR HUNDRED
THOUSAND. SLASH PILES IN THE
TAHOE BASIN ALONE- SO DURING
THESE ACTIVE WILDFIRES WE'RE
HAVING TO DEVELOP FIRE ENGINES
CHIU OUTRANKS YOU ARE ENSURE
THAT THOSE SLASH PILES DON'T
COMPLICATE AND IGNITE DURING
CATASTROPHIC FIRES- SO CUTE YOU
CANCER PART OF THE IS THIS
ENTIRE. WATER INFRASTRUCTURE
WERE SETTING UP AROUND MOVING
WHAT HE BY A MASK OUT OF THE
FOREST INTO BETTER PROGRAMS SUCH
AS INVESTMENTS IN IN WHAT
PROCESSING BUSINESSES THROUGH
THE CLIMATE CHALLENGE FUND
THAT'S LAUNCHING SUCH AS
INVESTMENTS WE MADE LAST YEAR IN
LAUNCHING- WE FEEDSTOCK
AGGREGATION PILOTS- THROUGH THE
OFFICE OF PLANNING AND RESEARCH-
BE ABLE TO HELP. CREATE
INFRASTRUCTURE AND A BUSINESS TO
BE ABLE TO START CREATING DEMAND
TO MOVE THAT WHAT OUT OF THE
FOREST SO THIS TRANSPORTATION
SUBSIDY IN THE- WALL- IN THE
SUITE OF EFFORTS TO BE ABLE TO
GET A SLASH PILES TO HIRE
DESTINATION. THE THE DETAILS IN
TERMS OF WHO'S GOING TO
QUALIFYING AND WHAT THE
REPORTING REQUIREMENTS WILL BE
THAT WILL BE WORKED OUT IN THE
GRANT GUIDELINES- AS THAT
PROGRAM GETS DEVELOPED AS THIS
IS A NEW INITIATIVE. BUT WE WANT
TO CONVEY TO THE LEGISLATURE AS
THAT THEY SHOULD BE THOUGHT OF
AS- A TOOL TO HELP US ADDRESS AN
EMERGENCY CRISIS TO HELP MOVE
EXISTING- SLASH PILES AND SLASH
PILES THAT ARE BEING CREATED
FROM POST FIRE SALVAGE AND OTHER
ACTIVITIES- OUT OF. OUT OF. THE
FOREST SO THE THAT WE- ONE MORE
TOOL TO HELP CREATE. AT THE AGE
THAT THIS FIRE HE'S AND FUTURE
BUYERS HE'S ARE LEFT. THANK YOU
MISTER PRIME. BUT THANK YOU
MISTER SHE- I DON'T OF THIS
QUESTION WERE JUST GO FIRST
GROUP- YOU'D MENTION THE SB
FORTY SIX FOR. THAT TO IN APRIL
SO IS- IS THAT REPORT IN THE
DRAFTING STAGES. CAN YOU GIVE US
A TEASE IN TERMS OF WHAT WAS IT
WHAT'S IN IT. YEAH SURE THING
THIS IS ASPECT AWAY CROWFOOT SO
ABSOLUTELY WE'RE LOOKING FORWARD
TO THE ANNUAL REPORT TO THE
LEGISLATURE LOT I MEAN THE
TEASER IS A LOT OF SUBSTANTIVE
PROGRESS HAS BEEN MADE. THE
ACTION PLAN CALLS FOR A NUMBER
OF SORT OF KEY STRATEGIES TO
MEET OUR OUR GOALS INCLUDING
THAT MILLION ACRE TARGET
INCLUDING A STRATEGY TO
INTRODUCE MORE SAFE PRESCRIBED
FIRE MY TO DO A BETTER JOB
SUPPORTING PRIVATE LANDOWNERS TO
MANAGE. THEIR LAND. REALLY AS A
BROAD SET OF STRATEGIES OUR TASK
FORCE MEETS EVERY OTHER MONTH IT
INCLUDES UPWARDS OF TWO HUNDRED
AND FIFTY FOLKS ACROSS THE STATE
WE'VE GOT AN EXECUTIVE
COMMITTEE. OUR LEADER OF THAT
TASK FORCE PATRICK RIGHT IS
BASED IN THE GOVERNOR'S OFFICE
AND DRIVING AT THIS PROGRESS SO
I THE ASSEMBLY MEMBER WE'RE
GOING TO HAVE I THINK A REALLY
SOLID REPORT THAT WILL
DEMONSTRATE SPECIFIC AREAS OF
PROGRESS AND REALLY MAKING THIS
CONNECTION BETWEEN THE BUDGET
THAT YOU ALL ARE LLOCATING AND
THAT THE ACTIONS WE KNOW NEED TO
BE TAKEN. THAT'S GREAT- IN TERMS
OF- HE SAID A MILLION A MILLION
ACRES TARGET MEANS A WE CLOSE
WHERE WE HOW HOW WOULD YOU HOW
WE GAUGING- WHERE WE ARE. YES
THERE IS SO AS I AS I POINTED
OUT THE IN THE STAIR SHARED
STEWARDSHIP AGREEMENT YOU KNOW
ONE COMMITMENT THERE IS THIS
MILLION ACRES A PROJECT BY
TWENTY TWENTY FIVE. AND THE GOOD
NEWS IS. OBVIOUSLY MORE AND MORE
PROJECTS ARE GETTING ON THE
GROUND ONE THING THAT WE'RE
FOCUSED ON RIGHT NOW IS
ACCOUNTING FOR THESE PROJECTS
ACROSS DIFFERENT JURISDICTIONS.
HISTORICALLY THERE HASN'T BEEN
ONE CENTRAL PART OF ACCOUNTING
PLATFORM TO REALLY MEASURE THE
AMOUNT OF PROJECTS AND PROJECT
AREAS THAT WE'RE DOING SO YOU
CAN IMAGINE. THE FOREST SERVICE
HOW THE WAY THAT THEY THEY
RECORDED DACHAU FIGHTER ARE
CONSERVANCIES ARE LOCAL RESOURCE
CONSERVATION DISTRICTS AT CETERA
SO. TO GET TO MORE SPECIFIC
ANSWER IN TERMS OF OVERALL
PROJECT ACRES REALLY BUILDING A
SHARED PLATFORM. TO CTUALLY
MEASURE IT DOES PROJECT IDENTIFY
WHAT PROJECTS ARE HAPPENING AND
MEASURE THE SIZE AND THAT THE
PURPOSE OF THOSE PROJECTS AND-
THAT THAT WILL BE ONE- YEAH THAT
UPDATE ON IN THAT PAPERWORK.
OKAY SO I JUST WANTED THAT I
DON'T WANT TO DWELL ON THIS BUT
THAT THE ONE POINT TWO MILLION-
THAT WAS ALLOCATE ALLOCATED LAST
YEAR. OR THE LAST BUDGET AND
THEN OF COURSE YOU'RE ASKING FOR
SIX OR MILLION SO THERE IS GOING
TO BE A SPECIFIC NUMBER. LISTED
RIGHT IN TERMS OF THE ACREAGE
THAT IT'S ACTUALLY BEEN. DONE.
YEAH I WOULD SAY YES AND I WOULD
SAY THAT YOU KNOWWE OBVIOUSLY
HAVE TO MEASURE OUR PROGRESS
ACROSS A- VARIETY OF METRICS.
INCLUDING FOR EXAMPLE YEAH HOME
HARDENING STRATEGIC FUEL BREAKS
ETCETERA SO. PROJECT AREAS ARE
ONE IMPORTANT METRIC WHERE WE
DEMONSTRATE OUR PROGRESS AND
WILL BE. MEASURING ASSESSMENT
AGAINST OTHER METRICS AS WELL
OKAY SO THERE'S JUST IT WITHIN
THAT REPORT TO ME I KNOW THERE'S
GONNA BE A LOT OF METRICS BUT I
THINK ONE OF THE- YOU MEET. I'M
USING THE METRIC THAT YOU LISTED
WHICH IS. THE MILLION ACRES BY
TWENTY FIVE SO. I WOULD I WOULD
HOPE THAT WE WOULD HAVE TO HAVE
SEX THERE. BUT YOU YOU DID
MENTION THE- THAT YOUR HOPE IS
THAT. IT WOULD BE MORE. USAGE OF
THAT THAT THE CAL THE G. P.
PROGRAM. DO WE HAVE AN
UNDERSTANDING IN TERMS OF HOW
MANY PROJECTS WERE SUBMITTED. TO
THAT STREAMLINED PROCESS AND-
HOW MANY PROJECTS TO EXPECT TO
BE IN. THE PIPELINE- MOVING
FORWARD. THANK YOU ASSEMBLY
MEMBER I IT'S HELPFUL OF JESSICA
JUST GIVES A LITTLE BIT OF A- I
KNOW YOU YOU KNOW A LOT ABOUT
CAL BTP BUT FOR OTHERS WHAT
WE'RE TRYING TO DO AND THEN. YOU
KNOW HOW WE TALK ABOUT IT IT'S
YOU SAID RIGHT NOW. PERFECT. I'M
SORRY COUNTY P. AS A TWENTY
MILLION EAKER ENVIRONMENTAL
IMPACT REVIEW. THAT THAT GETS
YOU QUITE DONE IN ABOUT TWO
MONTHS RATHER THAN TWO YEARS.
AND THEN STATE WATER BOARD
INTEGRATED. THEIR STATEWIDE. ARE
PERMITS ALSO INTO IT. AS WELL AS
DEPARTMENT OF FISH AND WILDLIFE.
THEIR ENVIRONMENTAL MITIGATIONS.
INTO THE CAL BTP AS WELL SO
PROJECT APPLICANTS WHO ARE
STARTING A- LARGER COMPLICATED-
WILDFIRE RESILIENCE PROJECT. NOW
HAVE A SINGLE APPLICATION TO GO
TO. THAT WILL HELP THEM AND
TRACK ALL OF THEIR-
ENVIRONMENTAL MITIGATION NEEDS
AND PERMITTING NEEDS. IN IN ONE
SPOT- AND SO THE CAL BGP IT'S
THE FIRST YOU KNOW THREE FOR ONE
PERMIT IN ESSENCE- THAT WE'VE
SEEN SO IT'S A FULLY
SYNCHRONIZED- PERMIT WHICH IS
VERY EXCITING. AND WAS A HUGE
EFFORT BY THE STATE WATER BOARDS
AND A REAL PARADIGM SHIFT- AND
HOW WE'RE DOING ENVIRONMENTAL
OVERSIGHT. IT'S IMPORTANT TO
REMEMBER THAT THE CAL BTP IS NOT
DESIGNED TO REPLACE. SOME OF THE
EXISTING EXEMPTIONS THAT PROJECT
PROPONENTS ARE USING SO WE HAVE
EXEMPTIONS FOR VERY SIMPLE.
STRAIGHTFORWARD SOMETIMES SINGLE
MEDITATION TYPE SMALLER- EIGHT
CREDIT SHE TYPE OF FUEL BREAKING
FEWER ACTION VEGETATION
MANAGEMENT PROGRAMS. SO PROJECT
PROPONENTS CAN STILL EXECUTE AND
USE. THOSE EXISTING- EXEMPTIONS.
CAL THE GPS HERE TO BE ABLE TO
HANDLE. MUCH MORE COMPLICATED-
AND- AND LARGER PROJECTS SO FOR
EXAMPLE PEOPLE WATER AGENCY.
SUCCESSFULLY DEAD. I IT KEEPS IT
SUCCEEDED ON A CAL BTP PROJECT.
WHERE THEY HAVE A FOUR THOUSAND
ACRES AND MULTIPLE VEGETATION
TYPES. YEAH AND- AND A MUCH MORE
COMPLICATED- PROCESS THAT WOULD
HAVE TAKEN THEM TWO YEARS. BUT
INSTEAD THEY HAD THAT COMPLETED
WITHIN TWO MONTHS. AND SO WE
HAVE NOW TO DATE HAD. TWENTY CAL
BTP PROJECT. SPECIFIC ANALYSIS
SO THAT APPLE ATION- IN AN
APPROVED AND STYLE WHICH MEANS
GREEN LIGHT TO START THEIR- AND
I. THERE'S ANOTHER FISH JUST-
THE RIGHT NOW. AND WE'RE GOING
TO SEE THAT NUMBER INCREASE
BECAUSE THAT'S THE SAN MAY.
YEMEN OF FUNDING HAS GONE ON THE
GROUND AND OUT THE FROM YEAR
WHAT INVESTED INTO SHE- READY
FOR. SO THOSE PROJECTS THAT
ALREADY HAD EMPIRE PERMITTING
JOHN AND SO NOW THAT THE BTP OUR
- WE ALSO HAVE A SPECIAL YOUR
FUNDING IN SEPTEMBER GAVE US A
CONTRACT- TO BE ABLE TO. DO
PROJECT SPECIFIC ANALYSIS FOR
POTENTIALLY THIRTY TO FORTY
PROJECTS ON THE GROUND SO THAT
LOCAL RESOURCE CONSERVATION
DISTRICTS NGOS HEALTHCARE UNITS
DON'T HAVE TO START FROM SCRATCH
THE BILL HAVE BEEN A
PROFESSIONAL ANALYSIS DONE IN
THEIR REGION AND COMPLETED. ON A
REAL PROJECT FOR THEM ALREADY SO
WE'RE REALLY EXCITED TO HAVE
THIS TOOL- AVAILABLE AND- AND
ARE EXCITED TO SEE PEOPLE
ALREADY STARTING TO USE THAT AND
IT'S. SAVING THEM LOTS OF TIME
AND ENERGY. SO- DO YOU HAVE IS
THERE A INTERNAL METRIC MEAN.
ERA OF A GOAL AND TWENTY TWO IN
TERMS OF HOW MANY- PROJECTS YOU
WANT TO OCCUR- APPROVED YOU SAID
THAT TWENTY HAS BEEN APPROVED
FIFTEEN TO TWENTY ON THE
PIPELINE. YOU'D MENTION THIRTY
TO FORTY BUT IS THAT THE GOAL.
TO HAVE THIRTY TO FORTY
PROJECTS. APPROVED BY THE END OF
THE YEAR. I WANT TO JUST BE
REALLY CLEAR THAT WE ARE SORT OF
CREATE WE ARE MAKING THIS TOOL
AVAILABLE AND EASY TO USE FOR
OUR PROJECT PROPONENTS WHO NEED
IT- WE'RE NOT TRYING TO. CLOSE
THAT CAN USE EMERGENCY
EXEMPTIONS THAT ALREADY EXIST-
OF THOSE WILL ALSO BE AVAILABLE
TO THEM SO OUR GOAL IS TO TRY TO
GET AS MANY VEGETATION
MANAGEMENT PROJECTS- ASK GAIL ON
THE GROUND AS QUICKLY AS
POSSIBLE AND FOR THOSE THAT THAT
ETP APPLIES FOR WE WANT THEM TO
USE THAT AND- IT'S GOING TO
EXPEDITE THEIR PROCESS SO THAT
THEY DON'T HAVE TO DO. A AS A
WHOLE SORT OF LONG TERM CHIU
YOUR SEATS FOR PROCESS AND MY
LAST QUESTION I IS WHEN A
DOLLARS A SHARE FOR HOLDING THAT
ARE- OVERSIGHT HEARING- LAST IT
LAST YEAR IN DECEMBER- IN THAT
HEARING- IT WAS MENTIONED THAT
YOU WERE GOING TO PROVIDE- THE
REPORTS FROM AB FOURTEEN NINETY
TWO. THAT'S REQUIRED SINCE
TWENTY SEVENTEEN HE SAID THAT IT
WAS GOING TO COME AT THE
BEGINNING OF THE YEAR DO YOU
HAVE A AN UPDATE AND WHEN THE
LEGISLATURE. WOULD RECEIVE THOSE
REPORTS. I BELIEVE WE RECEIVE
THEM. THANK YOU SO MUCH FOR YOUR
PATIENCE THAT THOSE ARE IN THE
STAGE OF THE CLEARANCE PROCESS
AND SHOULD BE T. VERY SHORTLY.
VERY SHORTLY AS IN A WEEK A VERY
SHORTLY AS IN A YEAR. WELL
YESTERDAY BUT- BUT YOU SHOULD
YOU SHOULD SEE THEM WITHIN THE
COMING WEEKS WITHIN THE COMING
WEEK ARAMBULA THAT THANK YOU.
AND I WILL AS AS AS WELL LET ME
ASK A FOLLOW UP QUESTION SOUNDS
LIKE A- ASSEMBLY MEMBER SMITH
YEARS AS A FOLLOW UP QUESTION ON
THIS. BECAUSE OTHERWISE I HAVE
MR BANNON IN THE IN THE QUEUE.
OKAY SO I WANT TO FOLLOW UP ON-
THE- DELIVERY OF REPORTS AND I
AM GLAD TO HEAR THAT THIS ONE
THAT SHOULD BE. IN OUR HANDS
WITHIN A WEEK THAT'S- THAT IS
GREAT TO HEAR- BUT WE HEARD WITH
RESPECT TO A COUPLE OF OTHER
REPORTS THAT- BUDGET HEARING
RECENTLY. THAT THEY ARE
SIGNIFICANTLY DELAYED AND THESE
ARE REPORTS THAT ARE STATUTORILY
MANDATED- AND I RECOGNIZE THAT
YOU'RE NOT RESPONSIBLE FOR ALL
THESE REPORTS BUT- CAN ONE OF
YOU. CONFIRM THAT WE WILL
RECEIVE THE S. B. FOUR FIFTY SIX
REPORT IN APRIL- WITHIN THE TIME
FRAME. THAT IS STATUTORILY
REQUIRED. YEAH CHAIR- WAIT
CRAWFORD HERE SECTOR IT IT'S OF
CONCERN TO ME PERSONALLY IF
WE'RE MISSING OUR DEADLINES TO
GET YOU THE LEGISLATIVE REPORT
THAT YOU NEED SO WHAT WE'LL DO
AND TONIGHT I WANNA GET OUT OF
THE SPECIFICS ON THE DEVELOPMENT
OF. OF THAT REPORT- BUT I CAN
TELL YOU THIS WHICH IS WILL
FOLLOW UP INTERNALLY AND WILL
PREPARE FOR YOU AN UPDATE ON
EACH OF THOSE REPORTS AND GIVE
YOU A CLEAR SENSE OF WHEN YOU'LL
HAVE THEM AND THEN IF THAT'S
INFORMATION YOU WANT TO SHARE
WITH THE COMMITTEE MEMBERS- YOU
KNOW THAT'S SOMETHING THAT YOU'D
BE ABLE TO DO AND DEFINITELY
WANTED KNOWLEDGE ASSEMBLY MEMBER
FONG SPECIFIC QUESTION AS WELL.
THANK YOU I'M PHILIP PROCEED NOW
WITH THE- MISTER BENNETT'S
QUESTIONS AND THEN- MISTER.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH SHOULD CHAIR
BLOOM- THIS IS THE OVERVIEW
QUESTION FOR SECRETARY- CROWFOOT
UP. WE ARE SPENDING
SUBSTANTIALLY OF. SIGNIFICANT
AMOUNTS OF MONEY AND NEW MONEY-
ON MANY NEW PROGRAMS AND I
REALLY APPRECIATE YOUR COMMENT
ABOUT HOW WE WANT TO TRY TO MAKE
SURE WE ADDRESS REGIONAL
VARIATIONS AND REGIONAL NEEDS
THAT ARE OUT THERE AND WE WANT
TO USE BEST SCIENCE. IT SEEMS
THAT WE HAVE A- AN INCREDIBLE
OPPORTUNITY AND RESPONSIBILITY-
TO CALIFORNIANS TO TRY TO
DEVELOP THAT. BEST SCIENCE WE
HAVE AN OPPORTUNITY- TO BE
LEADERS IN WHAT IS THE BEST
SCIENCE FOR THIS WILDFIRE
MANAGEMENT IN THESE THESE
DIVERSE PLACES THAT- THAT WE
HAVE- BECAUSE THAT IS GOING TO
BE THE BEST WAY FOR US TO ENJOY
ONE OF THE ONE OF THE IMPORTANT
WAYS FOR US TO ENSURE. A WE ARE
SPENDING THESE DOLLARS- AS
EFFICIENTLY AS POSSIBLE AND SO I
HAVE A CONCERN THAT. WHEN YOU
HAVE A LOT OF NEW MONEY GOING
OUT AND WHEN YOU HAVE A DESIRE
TO TRY TO MEET REGIONAL NEEDS
THAT. THE REGIONAL NEED MIGHT BE
IDENTIFIED THAT MAY NOT MATCH UP
WITH THE BEST SCIENCE- AND SO IS
THERE A WAY FOR US ON A DO WE
ARE WE CURRENTLY. TRYING TO MAKE
SURE THAT WITH EACH OF OUR
PROJECTS WE ARE LEARNING MORE
ABOUT WHAT THE BEST SCIENCES
THAT WE ARE APPLYING BEST
SCIENCE. SO THAT WE HAVE THE
APPROPRIATE BALANCE BETWEEN
REGIONAL AREAS IDENTIFYING
THINGS THAT THEY WANT TO HAVE
HAPPEN- AND MAKING SURE THAT
THEY FIT INTO AN OVERALL PLAN
THAT SAYS THAT'S THE BEST
SCIENCE THE BEST APPLICATION- SO
FOR EXAMPLE- AS ASSEMBLY MEMBER
FRIEDMAN TALKING ABOUT WE- WE-
VEGETATE WITH PLANTS THAT WILL
BE BETTER FOR. FOR ALL OF US IN
THE LONG RUN INCLUDING FIGHTING
FIRES COULD COULD USE HELP ME
WITH AN OVERVIEW OF THAT HE I
KNOW YOU HAVE MANY
RESPONSIBILITIES- AND TRYING TO
MOVE ALL OF THIS I JUST WANT TO
TRY TO. SEE WHAT KIND OF SINCE
WE HAVE IN TERMS OF PAYING
ATTENTION TO THAT ONE-
RESPONSIBILITY THAT WE HAVE
THANK YOU. ABSOLUTELY I REALLY
APPRECIATE THE QUESTION ALLOWS
FOR JESSICA TO JUMP IN AS WELL
SO ON THIS TASK FORCE WHICH IS
REALLY DRIVING OUR PROGRESS WE
HAVE A SCIENTIFIC ADVISORY
COMMITTEE. THAT'S COMPRISED OF
SCIENTISTS FROM ACROSS THE STATE
IN THE UC AND CSU SYSTEMS-
FEDERAL LABS AT SENTARA. AND
THEIR THEIR PURPOSE ON THIS TASK
FORCE IS TO REALLY ENSURE THAT.
THE PLANS WERE PUTTING IN PLACE
AND ULTIMATELY THE WORK WE'RE
DOING IS GROUNDED IN THAT BEST
AVAILABLE SCIENCE SO I'D SAY
THAT'S- THAT'S NUMBER ONE AND
WE'RE PROUD OF THE WORK THAT'S
HAPPENING THERE. I SHOULD
MENTION THAT THE WORK OF THE
TASK FORCE INCLUDING THE
COMPOSITION OF THE SCIENTIFIC
ADVISORY COMMITTEE. IS ALL
AVAILABLE ONLINE AND ONE WOULD
JUST HAVE TO GO GOAL-
GOVERNOR'S. WILDFIRE AND FOREST
RESILIENCE TASK FORCE. AND
YOU'LL SEE ACTUALLY A REAL TIME
UPDATE ON THE SPECIFIC ACTIONS
THAT WE'RE TAKING. I THOUGHT
NUMBER ONE NUMBER TWO IS WERE
REALLY EXCITED ELSEWHERE IN THE
BUDGET. THAT WE'RE PROPOSING
INVESTMENTS IN CLIMATE SCIENCE
AND CLIMATE RESEARCH. TO THE
UC'S AND CSU SYSTEM FOR MORE OF
THAT INDEPENDENT RESEARCH THAT'S
GOING TO DRIVE- WHAT WE'RE DOING
ON ON WILDFIRE SCIENCE. AND THEN
I'LL ALSO SAY. YOU KNOW THE
POINT THAT YOU ALL HAVE STRESSED
AS SOUTHERN CALIFORNIA LEADERS
THAT YOU KNOW WHAT WE'RE DOING
IN NORTHERN CALIFORNIA DOESN'T
NECESSARILY WORK IN SOUTHERN
CALIFORNIA WE HAVE TO BE VERY
SENSITIVE. WITH THE CHAPARRAL
ENVIRONMENT WE HAVE TO MAKE SURE
THAT WERE. CONSERVING THE
CHAPARRAL ENVIRONMENT AND THEN
RE FOREST ING THOSE LANDSCAPES
TO THAT BACK TO THE CHAPARRAL
ENVIRONMENT. THAT'S SOMETHING
THAT WE'VE NOW INTERNALIZED AND
ONE OF THE REASONS WHY WE'VE
SORT OF DEPARTED FROM A TOP DOWN
APPROACH ON PLANNING AND REALLY
FOCUSED ON MORE OF A BOTTOM UP
WITH REGIONAL. STRATEGIES AND WE
DO WANT TO MAKE SURE THAT
REGIONAL EFFORTS THAT ARE FUNDED
BY THE STATE HAVE ACCESS TO THE
SCIENCE. SCIENTIFIC ADVISORY
COMMITTEE ON THAT TASK FORCE. SO
THAT'S SOME OF THE CONNECTIVITY
AND IT'S OBVIOUSLY A WORK. IN
PROGRESS JESSICA. ABSOLUTELY IS
HIGHER INVESTMENT IS REALLY
ANGERED IN SCIENCE- WE WERE SO
GRATEFUL FOR YOUR LEADERSHIP. IN
HELPING US SECURE TWENTY FIVE
MILLION DOLLARS FOR REMOTE
SENSING AN ADDITIONAL THIRTY
FIVE THIRTY MILLION DOLLARS- OR
I'VE GROUND SCIENCE AS WELL AND
SO THAT COMBINATION OF INVESTING
IN. RESEARCH EXPERIMENTS- AND I
FY A PLEASURE FORCED INVENTORY
ANALYSIS PLUS WHICH ALLOWS THE
STUDY SEGMENTS OF FORCED
OVERTIME ON THE GROUND IN
ADDITION SHE REMOTE SENSING
WHICH GIVES US I INVESTMENT SUCH
AS LIDAR WHICH WE'RE LEVERAGING.
THOSE WINDS AT USGS JUST
ANNOUNCED THAT THEY ARE GOING TO
AWARD US FUNDING FOR A LIGHTER
ACROSS NEARLY TWO THIRDS OF THE
CRITICAL WATERSHEDS- INCLUDING
THE NORTH COAST AND MUCH OF THIS
YEAR- WHICH IS GOING TO HELP US
GET THAT REAL TIME ASSESSMENT.
ONLINE POST FIRE WATERSHED
RECOVERY FOR EXAMPLE- STORE
REALLY GROUNDING IN THIS AND
SCIENCE AND THEN IF YOU ALSO
LOOK AT MOST OF THE PROGRAMS FOR
EXAMPLE- STATE PARKS IS A GREAT
MODEL. OF DOING REAL TIME
ANALYTICS- AS THEY ARE ROLLING
OUT NEW MODELS FOR RESILIENCY
I'M STILL EVEN OUR PROGRAM
DOLLARS ARE INVESTING IN THAT
SCIENCE. AS WELL AS THESE DIRECT
LINES I'M A FOR. DATA ANALYTICS
AND REMOTE SENSING TO HELP US
IMPROVE OUR MODELS AND OUR
FEEDBACK LOOPS. THAT WE ARE
PLANNING WITH THE BEST SCIENCE
AND- JUST GIVE ME A COUPLE MORE
EXAMPLES OF THAT SO. FOR
EXAMPLE- CALIFORNIA PARTNERED
WITH- IT WITH SEVERAL OF THE
UC'S TO DESIGN- ALL POLL PROGRAM
THAT IS A LONG TERM- PROJECT
WHERE THEY ARE LOOKING AT. HOW
SEEDLINGS FARE- FROM LOWER
ELEVATIONS AND HIGHER ELEVATIONS
AND FROM HIGHER ELEVATIONS TO
LOWER ELEVATIONS OF TAKING-
DIFFERENT TYPES OF LIKE GIANT.
WHITE AND NATIVE PLANTS AND
PULLING THEM INTO YOUR-
DIFFERENT ECO ZONES AND CLIMATE
ZONES WHERE THOSE PLANS ARE
STILL NATIVE. AND TESTING
OUTSIDE CLIMATE. RESILIENCE
REFOREST RIGHT. TRYING TO PLAY
FOR HIGHER- GOING TO SURVIVE
BETTER AT LOWER- AND HARD. IN
THE ERA WHICH SO THERE'S A LOT
OF REACH HOW ON THE ROUND NOW
GETTING BACK THE LOOP. THE OTHER
THING WE'RE DOING IS IN IS
THAT'S NEW IN THIS. WE TEN
MILLION DOLLAR LAST YEAR OF OUR
ONE AND ARE NOW ASKING FOR IT IS
A STATE. AND INTO THE STATE. FOR
A SYSTEM THIS IS WHERE WE BACK.
TO BE A TO DO. LONG TERM ALONG-
EXPERIMENTS AND HAVE- HAD TELL
US ABOUT FOREST HYDROLOGY I
RESTORATION ECOLOGY AND HOW OUR
TREATMENTS ON THE GROUND FOR A
PRESCRIBED FIRE TWO MASTICATION.
ARE IMPACTING LONG TERM FOREST
HEALTH AND CARBON STORAGE STILL
ALLOWS US TO HAVE THOSE
CONSISTENT. NUMBER HAVE BEEN IN
THE STATE OWNERSHIP FOR SOME OF
THEM SEVENTY YEARS THAT ARE
ALLOWING US TO SEE CHANGE OVER
TIME. AND AND GET REALLY SOLID
EUROPEAN SCIENCE- THAT IS
INFORMING OUR MANAGEMENT
PRACTICES IN THE FUTURE. JUST
VERY BRIEFLY IF I COULD FOLLOW
UP I REALLY APPRECIATE THE
ANSWERS AND I APPRECIATE THE
SINCERE COMMITMENT I'M THE
GENUINE COMMITMENT I'M HEARING-
TO TRYING TO MAKE SURE THAT THIS
IS- GOOD SCIENCE- ONE JUST QUICK
QUESTION IS THERE- ACT I
CERTAINLY WE ARE. INVESTING IN
RESEARCH EXTENT OR IS THERE SOME
KIND OF SCIENTIFIC OVERVIEW OF
EACH PROJECT AS IT GOES OUT TO
JUST MAKE SURE IT DOES MEET-
CURRENT SCIENCES THAT'S
SOMETHING THAT WE ACTIVELY DO OR
DO WE SIMPLY TO APPLY GOOD
SCIENCE AS IT SORT OF. THE FALLS
AND EVERYBODY TALKS ABOUT WHAT
IT IS BUT IS THERE ANY KIND OF
SCIENTIFIC OVERVIEW TO MAKE SURE
THAT. WE ARE INVESTING IN BEEN
IN PROJECTS THAT DO MEET- SORT
OF SOME KIND OF SCIENTIFIC
STANDARD AND THAT ALSO WE CAN
ALL START TO. CONFIRM FOR MANY
PEOPLE. AS AS AS WE LOOK AT
THIS. OR NOT WE DON'T DON'T SEE
TO. A UNDERSTANDING OF WHAT HE
THE BEST SCIENCE WHEN IT COMES
TO- FIRE FOR. BOTH WILDFIRE. AND
WILD FOR. MITIGATION MEASURES
LIKE CENTER SO IT JUST IT DOES
NEED TO BE A LONG ANSWER BUT
JUST OVERALL IS THAT IS THAT
THEIR EX OR SOME KIND OF REVIEW
THAT TAKES PLACE. ON ANY KIND OF
OFFICIAL BASIS OR IS IT MORE IT
IS A SCIENCE IS APPLIED ON A
CASE BY CASE BASIS THANK YOU.
ABSOLUTELY ADOPTED. IS REALLY
ONE OF OUR CORE MANTRAS IN TERMS
OF AND IS INTEGRATED INTO ALL OF
OUR PROGRAMS. I'M SO THAT MEANS
THAT WE ARE ENSURING THAT THE
STANDARDS THAT WERE FORCING BOTH
OF THE ENVIRONMENTAL REVIEW THAT
GOES INTO EACH OF THESE
PROJECTS- AS WELL AS THE GRANT
GUIDELINES THAT GO OUT- RECORDS
PROJECTS. IN INCLUDES THE
LATEST- MANAGEMENT MODELING AND
INTEGRATES THE LATEST SCIENCE-
INTO OUR STANDARDS- AND THEN WE
ALSO HAVE JUST AS PART OF OUR-
OUR ENVIRONMENTAL REVIEW
PROGRAMS- WE HAVE MONITORING
THAT GOES BACK. AND ENSURES THAT
PEOPLE THAT ARE THE PROJECT
PROPONENTS. DID THE WORK
CORRECTLY. THANK YOU VERY.
ASSEMBLY SMITH THANK YOU VERY
MUCH CHAIR FOR FOLLOWING UP AND
WANT TO THANK YOU FOR LETTING OF
THE WHOLE PRESENTATION COME
FORWARD THEN WE CAN ASK
QUESTIONS. BUT A JUST COUPLE
IMPROBABLY FOR US SECRETARY
CROWFOOT. HOW MUCH OF THE TWENTY
MILLION DOLLARS WAS SPENT OUT OF
LAST YEAR'S BUDGET FOR THE
TRIBAL ENGAGEMENT. OR JUST I'M
ON A LIMB HERE SO I'LL I'LL I
MAY TURN A JET JESSICA I THINK I
THINK WE'RE STILL WORKING ON
FRANKLY GETTING THAT THAT
PROGRAM UP AND RUNNING BUT- OVER
YOU JUST GOT. ABSOLUTELY THAT
TWENTY MILLION DOLLARS IS A
REALLY- NEW AND NOVEL CONCEPT
WHERE WHAT WE ARE DOING IS
WORKING SPECIFICALLY WITH
TRYING. TO DEVELOP A PROGRAM
THAT REMOVES A LOT OF THE
BUREAUCRATIC BARRIERS AND
HURDLES FOR TRIED ACCESSING
DOLLARS. SO CRIMES HAVE BEEN
VERY INTEGRATED- IN ACCESSING
PROJECT DOLLARS THROUGHOUT THE
ENTIRE- THE ENTIRE PROGRAM FROM
SORT OF PARTNERSHIPS ON STATE
PARKS. AND- FORCED HEALTH GRANT
DOLLARS TO THE OTHER GRANT
PROGRAMS ARE CONTINUING TO FIND.
PROJECT TYPE ONE MEANS- ON
TRIBAL LAND AND TRIBAL
PARTNERSHIPS. THIS TRIBAL GRANT
PROGRAM IS TRYING TO CREATE A
PARADIGM SHIFT IN HOW WE ENGAGE
WITH TRIBES AND SO. OUR NEW
ASSISTANT SECRETARY FOR TRAVEL-
FORMATION I ASKED THE RESOURCES
AGENCY IS DEVELOPING IT IN
CONSULTATIONS. WITH TRIBES BUT
OUR GOAL IS TO ENSURE THAT THIS
IS A TRIBALLY LED. AND TRIBALLY
DESIGN PROGRAM WHICH MEANS IT
DOESN'T GET TO MOVE AT THE SAME
SPEED. OF JUST GETTING THE
PROJECT HOURS ON THE GROUND BUT
I JUST WANT TO REASSURE YOU.
THAT PROJECTS DOLLARS ARE
GETTING TWO TRIBES VERY
CONSISTENTLY- THROUGHOUT EVERY
ASPECT OF THIS PROGRAM WHILE
THIS NEW PROJECT- AND PARADIGM
SHIFT IS BEING DEVELOPED. JUST
TO BE DIRECTLY ASSEMBLY MEMBER I
DON'T THAT I DON'T BELIEVE THAT
WE'VE EXPANDED- FUNDING FROM
THAT TWENTY MILLION DOLLARS
DIRECTLY TO TRIBES YEAH. THAT'S
WHAT I WAS GOING TO THE FOLLOW
UP QUESTION THAT STILL THAT
TWENTY MILLION IS SAFE. FOR THE
TRIBAL COMMUNITIES TO BE GAVE.
AS WE MOVE THROUGH THIS PROCESS.
1% 100% IT MORE OF AND I WANT TO
THANK MY COLLEAGUE ASSEMBLY
MEMBER. FOR FOLLOWING UP FOR THE
MASS BECAUSE I THINK THE QUITE
WITH A BY MASS TRANSPORTATION A
BIO MAY FOR SO. TOOK UP THE SO
WE GET TO THE REFORM. OF AND DO
IT RIGHT SO I WON'T GO TOO MUCH
WITH THAT. AND IN ANOTHER WOULD
JUST GO FOLLOWING UP WITH
ASSEMBLYMEMBER FONG. IS I ASK
THAT QUESTION IN DECEMBER IN THE
MIDDLE OF THE WAITING ALL MONTH
FOR THAT REPORT SO I LOOK
FORWARD TO IT IN THE NEXT WEEK
AND I'LL GIVE YOU TO IN CASE-
SOMEBODY. MIGHT COME UP WITH THE
FLU HERE. THANK YOU VERY MUCH
MISTER CHAIR. ALL RIGHT- THANK
YOU MISTER- ONE THING THAT'S
COME UP PREVIOUSLY AN IDEA AND-
YEARS PAST AND I DON'T THINK
IT'S BEEN ADDRESSED HERE TODAY
IS THE GEOGRAPHIC DISTRIBUTION
OF FUNDS FROM THE OF FIRE
PREVENTION GRANT PROGRAM- DO YOU
HAVE STATISTICS AVAILABLE-
THERE'S STILL A LONG BEEN A
CONCERN THAT- MANY OF THOSE
FUNDS DON'T MAKE THEIR WAY-
INSUFFICIENT AMOUNTS DOWN TO A
SOUTHERN CALIFORNIA. ASSEMBLY
MEMBER I DO YOU HAVE THOSE
NUMBERS- SO IN THE FIRE
PREVENTION GRANTS- WHAT THE
EARLY ACTION FOR THE GRANTS THAT
WERE AWARDED- THAT SOUTHERN
REGION HAD RECEIVED SIXTY FOUR
AWARDS TOTALING SIXTY THREE
MILLION DOLLARS AND THE NORTHERN
REGION. RECEIVE FORTY AWARDS
TOTALING SEVENTY POINT FOUR
MILLION DOLLARS. SO IT'S A
PRETTY EVEN DISTRIBUTION. THANK
YOU. ALL RIGHT I THINK I DON'T
SEE ANY OTHER HANDS GOING UP BY
FOR QUESTIONS ON THE ISSUE ONE-
I KNOW WE'VE COVERED SOME OF THE
GROUND- FOR ISSUE TWO ALREADY
BUT- IF THERE IS ADDITIONAL
INFORMATION. A SECRETARY AND
ALEJO AND OTHERS SAID- TO
PRESENT ON ISSUE NUMBER TWO WHY
pCALLING RIGHT- SHOULD BE
AVAILABLE AT YOUR PRESENT ON THE
FOREST I AM WILDFIRE RESILIENCE
TASK FORCE I REQUEST. THANK YOU. THANK YOU JUST A GARBAGE TRUCK
CHAIRMAN I'M PATRICK RIGHT I AM
THE DIRECTOR OF THE US WHILE
WILDFIRE FORCE RESILIENCE TASK
FORCE THAT SECTOR CROWFOOT-
MENTIONED ALL KEEP MY REMARKS
SHORT BECAUSE I THINK HE DID A
pHE MENTIONED- WE'RE IN THE
MIDDLE OF LAST YEAR WE
RECONFIGURED THE TASK FORCE IT
WAS PREVIOUSLY A STATE ONLY TASK
FORCE BUT IN RECOGNITION OF THE
NEED TO WORK IN PARTNERSHIP WITH
THE FEDERAL GOVERNMENT LOCAL
GOVERNMENT TRIBAL GOVERNMENTS
WE'VE EXPANDED THE TASK FORCE TO
INCLUDE THE REGIONAL FORSTER WHO
NOW. CO CHAIRS IT WAS SECRETARY
CROWFOOT WE ALSO HAVE LEADERSHIP
OF SI SAKET RC RC TO MAKE SURE
WE'VE GOT THE COUNTIES FULLY
ENGAGED AND WE'VE GOT A TRIBAL A
MEMBER FROM THE INTERTRIBAL
INDIGENOUS STEWARDSHIP OUR
NETWORK TO MAKE SURE THAT WE'RE
GETTING GOOD- TRIBAL INVOLVEMENT
IN ALL ASPECTS OF. THE ACTION
PLAN AND ALL OUR EFFORTS
STATEWIDE SO THAT'S OUR
EXECUTIVE COMMITTEE THAT LEADS A
TASK FORCE AS A WHOLE WE ALSO
HAVE ROUGHLY A DOZEN OR MORE
DIFFERENT INTER AGENCY AND
STAKEHOLDER DRIVEN WORK GROUPS
ON EVERYTHING FROM PRESCRIBER TO
REFORESTATION TO WOOD
UTILIZATION TO MAKE SURE. THE
AGENCIES ARE WORKING IN
ALIGNMENT LEVERAGING THEIR FUNDS
WORKING TOGETHER SCALING UP A
REMOVING BARRIERS THAT ARE
PREVENTING US FROM MOVING AHEAD
IN ALL OF THOSE AREAS- ON IT
SECRETARY CRAWFORD SAID WERE
ALSO LASER FOCUSED ON MAKING
SURE THAT WE'RE MAKING PROGRESS
ON THE NINETY NINE ACTIONS THAT
ARE IN THE ACTION PLAN. WE HAVE
A SO CALLED AIR TABLE OUR SYSTEM
THAT SET UP WHERE YOU CAN GO ON
AND YOU CAN SEE EXACTLY WHERE WE
ARE ON EVERY ONE OF THOSE
ACTIONS WHICH AGENCIES WILL LEAD
WHAT'S THEIR SCHEDULE OR THEY ON
TRACK OR THE BEHIND WHAT ARE
THEIR COMPLETION DATES ALL OF
THIS IS CAPTURED IN THE
IMPLEMENTATION PLAN THAT YOU
MENTIONED EARLIER THAT'S
REQUIRED BY S. B. FOUR FIVE SIX.
WE DID COMPLETE THAT BY THE END
OF THE YEAR IT'S ONLINE AGAIN
YOU COULDN'T AS SUCH A GROUP
WOULD SAID YOU CAN JUST GOOGLE
WILDFIRE TASK FORCE. AND YOU
COULD SEE THE WORK PLANS FOR ALL
OF THE WORK. ALL THE SKIN. THE
CHARTER FOR THE TAP FORCE PRETTY
MUCH ALL THE INFORMATION. THAT
YOU WOULD NEED TO TRACK WHAT'S
GOING ON. ON IT WE THINK IT'S AN
UNPRECEDENTED LEVEL OF
ACCOUNTABILITY AND TRANSPARENCY
SO CERTAINLY LOOK FORWARD TO
HEARING YOUR INPUT ON HOW WELL
THAT'S WORKING. WELL WE WILL BE
TAKING IT TO ANOTHER LEVEL WITH
AN UPGRADED WEBSITE UNDER A NEW
COMMUNICATIONS. CONTRACTORS WELL
SO THAT WE CAN GET THE WORD OUT
AS- AS JESSICA SAID WE'VE GOT
DOZENS AND DOZENS OF DIFFERENT
PROGRAMS OUT THERE VERY HARD FOR
PEOPLE TO KEEP TRACK OF THEM. SO
REAL WILL REALLY COMMITTED THE
TASK FORCE TO BE A ONE STOP SHOP
FOR INFORMATION FOR STAKEHOLDERS
THE LEGISLATURE TO OTHERS TO
UNDERSTAND WHERE MONEY IS
FLOWING WHAT PROGRAMS ARE MOVING
FORWARD. WELL IT'S CETERA SO
HOPEFULLY ALL THAT- WILL COME
TOGETHER. I'LL DISCUSS THEN
REALLY THE BUDGET WELL HOW DO WE
PAY FOR ALL THIS RIGHT NOW.
WE'RE VERY LEAN AND MEAN
BASICALLY THE TASK FORCE STAFF
IS MY SELF. IN A SENIOR
SCIENTIST AT CAL FIRE WHOSE
OPERATING THROUGH A BORROWED
POSITION. OF THE BUDGET SUGGESTS
THAT WE RAMP THAT UP A BIT WELL
WE'RE PROPOSING TO POSITIONS OF
SEE AN ALREADY. TO HELP WITH
COMMUNICATIONS AND ALSO TO MAKE
SURE THE WORK WE'RE DOING IS.
DIVERSITY IN CLIMATE ADAPTATION
THAT'S SO IMPORTANT TO ALL OF US
ALSO TWO POSITIONS AT CAL FIRE
ON TO MAKE SURE WE BACK FEEL OF
THE FOLKS THAT WERE BARRING
RIGHT NOW. WE ALSO HAVE A
VARIETY OF CONSULTING CONTRACTS
THAT ARE IN THE PROPOSED BUDGET
FOR THINGS LIKE COMMUNICATIONS
FOR OUR SCIENCE PROGRAM. AND FOR
FACILITATORS. THERE WAS A
QUESTION IN THE BUDGET RIGHT UP
ABOUT IT WHY DON'T YOU ADDING
STATE STAFF TO HANDLE THOSE
RESPONSIBILITIES WE COULD
CERTAINLY GO IN THAT DIRECTION
AND HIGHER HALF A DOZEN STAFF.
WE THINK IT'S MORE EFFICIENT
THOUGH JUST TO SIT DOWN WITH
EACH WORK GROUP AND TALK ABOUT
WHAT THEY NEED FROM A
FACILITATION PERSPECTIVE. OUR
CONTRACTS RANGE FROM ANYWHERE
FROM A SMALL FIFTEEN THOUSAND
DOLLAR CNTRACT TO THE R. C.
D.'S TO FACILITATE. OUR PRIVATE
LANDOWNER WORKGROUP TO I. TWO
HUNDRED THOUSAND DOLLAR CONTRACT
WITH THE WATER SHOULD CENTER FOR
THE WOOD UTILIZATION WORKGROUP.
TO A MULTI YEAR TWO POINT FOUR
MILLION DOLLAR CONTRACT TO
SUPPORT OUR SCIENCE ADVISORY
COUNCIL FOR SEVERAL YEARS SO WE
THINK A MORE. TAILORED APPROACH.
MAKES MORE SENSE IT'S MORE COST
EFFECTIVE MORE EFFICIENT BUT
CERTAINLY HAPPY TO ENGAGE WITH
YOU AND- I HEAR HOW WE CAN
BETTER CLARIFY HOW THAT'S GOING
AND- REACH AGREEMENT ON HOW BEST
TO FUND OUR ON GOING OPERATIONS.
SO THANK YOU AGAIN AGAIN AGAIN
THE FOCUS OF THAT BUDGET REQUEST
IS STRICTLY ON THE OPERATIONS OF
THE TASK FORCE AND HOPEFULLY
WITH THESE FUNDS. WILL BE BETTER
POSITIONED TO DELIVER BOTH ON.
THE ACTION PLAN REQUIREMENTS AND
ALSO ON YOU KNOW THE HIGH NEED
FOR TRANSPARENCY AND VISIBILITY
THROUGHOUT ALL ASPECTS. OF WHAT
WE'RE DOING SO THANK YOU AGAIN.
THANK YOU DOES- L. A. O. OR-
BERMAN FIND HAVE BEEN. TO ADD ON
THIS. I WE DON'T HAVE ANYTHING
TO ADD WE HAVEN'T IDENTIFIED ANY
SPECIFIC CONCERNS WITH THE
PROPOSAL AT THIS TIME. THANK YOU
. NOTHING DAD FROM PORTER
FINANCES THE MOMENT EITHER A
TOPIC ANSWER QUESTIONS. THANK
YOU- ALLOW ME TO- ASKED THEN AND
I THINK IT'LL BE GREAT IF OUR
STAFF TO KIND OF PUT THEIR HEADS
TOGETHER TO TALK ABOUT THE
BALANCE BETWEEN- AND ENTERING
INTO NEW CONTRACTS- OR- PERHAPS
HANDLING SOME OF THE THESE.
CONSULTING. ISSUES- IN IN HOUSE
- BUT AN ADDITIONAL QUESTION I
HAVE IS- WHEN WILL THE STATE
COMPLETE THE FINE SCALE
VEGETATION MAPPING FOR THE
ENTIRE STATE- INCLUDING THE
SIERRA NEVADA CENTRAL CLOSE TO
NORTH COAST. THAT WILL HELP
GUIDE FOR PREVENTION ACTIVITIES
. IT'S A GREAT QUESTION WE ARE
GOING TO BE WORKING WITH
INTERAGENCY TEAM AND
STAKEHOLDERS TO AS JESSICA SAID
TO TRY TO FIGURE OUT WHAT THE
FULL SUITE OF INFORMATION NEEDS
WE HAVE EVERYTHING FROM LIDAR TO
DECISION SUPPORT SYSTEMS THAT
THE VEGETATION MAPPING. ALSO
WILL CERTAINLY BE BACK TO YOU
SOON WITH A MORE COMPREHENSIVE
ANSWER TO THAT QUESTION- BUT
WE'RE DEFINITELY MINDFUL OF THE
NEED TO HAVE THE BEST A
SCIENTIFIC INFORMATION THAT WE
CAN GET TO HELP GUIDE THESE
PROJECTS. THANK YOU ARE
CERTAINLY AGREE- WITH RESPECT TO
THOSE CONTRACTS WE WERE JUST
TALKING ABOUT- WHY ARE SOME OF
THEM ONGOING IT SOUNDS LIKE MOST
OF THEM ARE IN THE- NATURE OF-
SHORT TERM. WELL IT'S A MIX I
MEAN I THINK IN SOME CASES SOME
OF THE WORK GROUPS ARE WORKING
TOWARDS TRYING TO GET
CONSOLIDATE IMPLEMENTATION PLANS
DONE AND THEN THOSE WORK GROUPS
WILL PHASE OUT OTHERS LIKE THE
PRESCRIBED FIRE WORKGROUP- THEY
WANT TO REMAIN IN PLACE SO THAT
THEY CAN CONTINUE TO WORK
TOGETHER. AND COORDINATE THE
EFFORTS THAT STATE FEDERAL LOCAL
AND COMMUNITY PRESCRIBED FIRE
VETS SO THEY EXPECT TO HAVE AN
ONGOING WORK PLAN FOR THE NEXT
SEVERAL YARS- SO OVERALL IT'S A
IT'S A MIX OF. OF SHORTER TERM
IN LONGER TERM EFFORTS. GREAT-
THANK YOU. DO WE HAVE ANY
ADDITIONAL INFORMATION-
REGARDING ISSUE NUMBER THREE. I
SHOULD ASK ARE THERE ANY OTHER
QUESTIONS ON ISSUE TOO OKAY. SO
LET'S MOVE ON TO ISSUE THREE ARE
THERE- IS THERE ADDITIONAL-
TESTIMONY REGARDING THAT ISSUE.
MORE IN THE FUTURE WE COULD
CERTAINLY PRESENT ON EACH OF
THOSE AB I GUESS EQUIPMENT RIGHT
CLARIFYING QUESTION FOR YOU IS
THERE'S CONSOB. GROUPS WITHIN
THAT FOR SURGE CAPACITY
MODERATES AND THEN CARRY THE L.
WOULD YOU LIKE TO TAKE THEM ALL
AT ONCE OR DO YOU PREFER TO TAKE
THE MARKET TIME. I THINK YOU
COULD TAKE THEM ALL AT ONCE.
OKAY IF I COULD TURN TO- CHIEF
JOE TYLER WITH CAL FIRE TO TALK
ABOUT THE SURGE CAPACITY-
ISSUES. I THINK YOU GET THE BEST
POSITION TO GIVE AN OVERVIEW OF
THOSE. ABSOLUTELY THANK YOU
CHAIR BLOOM AND MEMBERS OF THE
COMMITTEE IT'S A PLEASURE TO.
TALK TO YOU HERE TODAY- SO AS-
YOU SEEN IN THOSE ISSUES- WE
HAVE- MURDERS THE SURGE CAPACITY
ENHANCEMENTS- THAT EMERGENCY
SURGE CAPACITY ENHANCEMENT- IS A
REQUEST FOR A SEVENTY NINE
POINT. EIGHT MILLION GENERAL
FUND STARTING IN TWENTY TWO
TWENTY THREE. TO INCREASE SEARCH
FOR CAPACITY FOR A WHILE AND-
MERGES THE RESPONSE BY ADDING
ADDITIONAL RESOURCES THAT CAN BE
USED DURING CRITICAL FIRE
CONDITIONS AND RESOURCE
DRAWDOWN. LET ME START BY ASKING
SECRETARY CREW PUT LARGELY SET
THE STAGE- AND DID EXTREMELY
WELL OF WHAT THE CONDITIONS ARE
IN EACH ONE OF THE- COMMITTEE
MEMBERS KNOW WHERE THE
CONDITIONS WITH IN CALIFORNIA
RIGHT NOW. AND NOT ONLY RELATED
TO- SURGE CAPACITY BUT WE KNOW
THEM THE WOMEN AND MEN ON THE
GROUND- FIGHTING THESE FIRES-
ACROSS. THE STATE FEDERAL LOCAL
AND TRIBAL AGENCIES AS WELL AS
OUR- AS WELL AS OUR OUR PRIVATE
VENDORS HAVE REALLY BEEN DOING-
HECK OF A JOB ACROSS THE YEARS-
TRYING TO COMBAT THESE LARGE AND
DAMAGING AND DEVASTATING
WILDFIRES. SO WE TAKE IT INTO
PIECES I'M NOT GOING TO TALK
ABOUT ANYTHING OTHER THAN SEARCH
CAPACITY RIGHT NOW. BUT TO THE
POINT OF- THAT IT THAT IT TAKES
IN ALL APPROACH EFFORT NOT ONLY
FROM THE WILDFIRE RESILIENCE
THAT WE'VE BEEN TALKING ABOUT
ALREADY. BUT MAKING SURE FOR THE
HEALTH AND WELLNESS OF OUR
EMPLOYEES AS WELL AS ADDING
RESOURCES ON THE GROUND- THAT
CAN MITIGATE INITIAL ATTACK
WILDFIRES TO TRY TO KEEP THEM
SMALL SO. WE CAN GET OUR. WOMEN
AND MEN BACK- TO REST THE NEXT.
TO FIRE WE'RE ALSO. THE PEOPLE
OF CALIFORNIA. SO ABOUT A
HUNDRED AND SEVENTY NINE MILLION
A GENERAL FUND. WE'RE REQUESTING
NINETY NINE MILLION IN GENERAL
FUND TO ADD UP FOR ADDITIONAL S.
SEVENTY I. FIREHAWK HELICOPTERS.
TO PROVIDE AIRCRAFT AVAILABILITY
FOR THE- TWELVE- S. SEVENTY I.
FIREHAWK HELICOPTERS THAT YOU
ALL HAVE APPROVED- PREVIOUSLY.
THE PURPOSE OF THIS IS OUT TO
ENSURE THAT WE HAVE A CONTINUOUS
AVAILABILITY OF- FIREHAWK
HELICOPTERS- SO THAT WHEN ONE
GOES DOWN FOR MAINTENANCE THAT
WE HAVE ADDITIONAL TO ENSURE
THAT WE HAVE TWENTY FOUR SEVEN
THREE SIXTY FIVE COVERAGE. OF
THOSE HELICOPTERS IN ADDITION TO
THAT- THE INTENT OF THE S.
SEVENTY I. HELICOPTER PROGRAM
HERE WOULD BE TO SEARCH THOSE
AIRCRAFT- DURING HEIGHTENED FIRE
CONDITIONS ACROSS THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA. AND WHICH WE COULD
STAFF WITH ADDITIONAL CREWS TO
STOPPING PATTERNS AND ADDITIONAL
PILOTS THAT WE HAVE ON HAND- TO
BE ABLE TO FLY THESE AIRCRAFT
AND- FIGHT TO NATIONAL ATTACK
WILDFIRES. SECOND PART OF THIS
HUNDRED SEVENTY NINE MILLION
GENERAL FUND PACKAGES-
REQUESTING FORTY FIVE MILLION
THE GENERAL FUND FOR- ANNUALLY
FOR THREE YEARS- TO SECURE- TEN
ADDITIONAL. EXCLUSIVE USE HEAVY
HELICOPTERS- TO ASSIST IN
COMBATING HIS INITIAL ATTACK
WILDFIRES THIS IS UP. PARTLY FOR
AN INITIAL ATTACK FIRE FIGHTING
IN REALLY COMBATING THIS FIRES
ABOUT THE SAME TIME ADDING SURGE
CAPACITY WHILE WE'RE WAITING-
THE FEDERAL C. ONE THIRTY AIR
TANKERS TO BE RETROFITTED BY THE
UNITED STATES AIRFORCE. AND BE
DELIVERED TO THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA WITH THE TRANSFER
TITLE TRANSFER OF TITLE- AT THE
TIME OF THE BUDGET CHANGE
PROPOSAL WE- ARE ANTICIPATED
THOSE AIRCRAFT COMING IN IN THE
SPRING OF TWO THOUSAND TWENTY
THREE YOU KNOW AS IT LOOKS RIGHT
NOW- WE ARE APPEARING AT A
PROBABLY BE LATE TWO THOUSAND
TWENTY THREE. AND SOME OF THOSE
AIRCRAFT INTO THE EARLY TWO
THOUSAND TWENTY FOUR BEFORE-
THOSE AIRCRAFT ACTUALLY ARRIVE
SO I BELIEVE THAT THE TEN
ADDITIONAL HEAVY HELICOPTERS. IN
ADDITION TO THE BUDGET BILL
LANGUAGE THAT WAS APPROVED LAST
YEAR- TO ADD EXCLUSIVE USE
AIRCRAFT WILL REALLY PROVIDE. A
GREAT INVESTMENT TO THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA- TO COMBAT THOSE
INITIAL ATTACK FIRES- IN IN
COMPLEMENT THE- KALIFORNIA-
AIRCRAFT FLEET. LASTLY FOR-
EMERGENCIES ABOUT THIRTY FIVE
POINT EIGHT MILLION- TO ADD- TWO
ADDITIONAL SEARCH ENGINES IN
EACH OF OUR TWENTY ONE
OPERATIONAL UNITS ACROSS. THE
STATE AS WELL AS- TO ADDITIONAL
PER CONTRACT COUNTY FOR THE SIX
CONTRACT COUNTIES. IN ADDITION
TO THAT TEN ADDITIONAL SURGE
CAPACITY BULLDOZERS WHICH IS
THE- TRANSPORT TO- BUT THOSE ARE
TRANSPORT THE CLOSER AND THE
BOULDERS ARE SERVICE UNIT. AND
WHICH THAT TAKES CARE OF ALL OF
THAT EQUIPMENT- WE BELIEVE. THAT
THE ADDITION OF TWO ADDITIONAL
SEARCH ENGINES FOR RESERVE
STATUS AND BE ABLE TO SEARCH
DURING CRITICAL CONDITIONS.
ALLOW US- BASED ON THE STAFFING
THAT ARE AVAILABLE IN EACH ONE
OF THOSE OPERATIONAL UNITS ARE
REASONABLE- NO REGRETS ASK OF
ADDING THE SEARCH ENGINES TO- TO
THOSE UNITS FOR. THE PURPOSE OF
ADDING ADDITIONAL PERSONNEL. ON
OF THIS APPARATUS DURING
CRITICAL FIRE WEATHER. THANK YOU
CHIEF TYLER WE'RE GONNA ASK
HELLO YES IF THEY'LL DO A BRIEF
OVERVIEW OF THE FIR INTEGRATED
REAL TIME INTELLIGENCE SYSTEMS
OR VIRUS SO I THINK AND THEY'RE
TOGETHER OVER AND CALLAWAY ESTA.
COURSE THANK YOU.
DO WE HAVE
CARILLO YES AVAILABLE. SWITCHER
LOOKS LIKE THEY'RE TRYING TO
FIGURE OUT SOME AUDIO ISSUES.
CHEER OF ANOTHER UP PRESENTATION
YOU WANT TO MOVE TO OTHER
FIGURING THAT OUT. I'M SURE
CHIEF TYLER DO NOT TOUCH ON
CADDY THE L. IN THE INTERVENING
MOMENTS. YES ABSOLUTELY AGAIN-
CHAIR BLOEMEN AND MEMBERS- JOE
TYLER AGAIN A DEPUTY DIRECTOR OF
FIRE PROTECTION FOR CALIFORNIA-
SO THE THIRD ITEM IN THIS-
SEARCH PROPOSAL IN THIS PROPOSAL
IS- THE REFRESH OF OUR CAT ABL
SYSTEM OUR COMPUTER AIDED
DISPATCH IN A AUTOMATIC VEHICLE
LOCATION PROGRAM A HARDWARE
SERVICE AND REFRESH IT'S AN
INCREASE OF- TWENTY THREE POINT
NINE MILLION DOLLARS REQUESTING
FORTY THREE POSITIONS STARTING
IN TWENTY TWO TWENTY THREE. AD
THEN SEVENTEEN POINT NINE
MILLION THAT COMES- REQUESTED
FROM THE STATE A MERCY TELEPHONE
NUMBER ACCOUNT SET NOW STARTING
IN TWENTY TWO TWENTY THREE AS
WELL TO ACQUIRE INSTALL SUPPORT
THE COMPUTER AIDED DISPATCH
PROGRAM THAT WE HAVE AN
EMERGENCY COMMAND CENTERS AND-
AND THEN THE A. B. L. M. B. T.
MOBILE DATA TERMINAL. EQUIPMENT
THAT WE HAVE IN OUR EMERGENCY
RESPONSE EQUIPMENT AND THIS IS
REALLY- THE CAD PROGRAM IS THE
CORE OF CALPERS- DISPATCHING- WE
HAVE HISTORICALLY HAD THIS
PROGRAM THROUGH A NORTHROP
GRUMMAN NORTHROP GRUMMAN SOLD IT
TO A COMPANY CALLED PERATON AND
THAT IS THE INTENT OF CONTINUING
TO MOVE FORWARD WITH THE
RELATIONSHIP TO REFRESH THE- A
QUICK MET- AND ARMORS TO COMMAND
CENTERS TO BE ABLE TO ENSURE
FUNCTIONALITY AND THE QUICKEST-AVAILABLE RESPONSE TO- TO
EMERGENCIES ACROSS THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA. IN ADDITION- IT
INCLUDES ELEVEN POINT FOUR
MILLION DOLLARS IN GENERAL FUND
FOR FORTY THREE POSITIONS THAT
WOULD BE ALLOCATED BETWEEN OUR
HEADQUARTERS REGIONS IN UNIT
PROGRAMS THAT HELP WITH THE
ONGOING OPERATION MAINTENANCE
INCREASE TECHNOLOGY DEMANDS OF
THE APPLICATION OF THE COMPUTER
AIDED DISPATCH SYSTEM REALLY.
THIS COMES DOWN TO- WHAT. I'M
IT- CHAIR BLAME YOU HEARD OF AND
THEN- THAT EVERY FOR YEARS WE
COME BACK TO REFRESH- THE
COMPUTER AIDED DISPATCH SYSTEM.
THAT INCLUDES A FIVE YEAR
HARDWARE REFRESH AND ALL THE
HARDWARE AND SOFTWARE SUPPORT
AND THE REASON WE DO THIS. IS
BECAUSE ULTIMATELY THE
WARRANTIES HAVE EXPIRED ON ALL
THE EQUIPMENT- AND WE WANT THE
BEST AND MOST UP TO DATE
EQUIPMENT TO BE ABLE TO DISPATCH
OUR RESOURCES TO THE PEOPLE OF
CALIFORNIA. IN ADDITION IT'S
TWELVE POINT FIVE MILLION
DOLLARS- GENERAL FUND FOR
AUTOMATIC VEHICLE LOCATION
HARDWARE AND INSTALLATION WIRING
SERVICES ANOTHER MAINTENANCE
CONTRACTS THERE. IT'S IMPORTANT
TO NOTE THAT ALL THE CAT
HARDWARE THAT WE TALKED ABOUT
ALREADY WILL BE OUT OF WARRANTY
BY JULY ONE TWO THOUSAND TWENTY
THREE SOME OF IT BEFORE- BASED
ON WHEN IT WAS PURCHASED AND
INSTALLED. CURRENTLY THE ABL
EQUIPMENT THAT WE HAVE A TWELVE
HUNDRED UNITSACROSS THE STATE
OF CALIFORNIA BASED ON WHEN IT
WAS PURCHASED AND INSTALLED WILL
BE OUT OF SERVICE AN OUT OF
WARRANTY BY SEPTEMBER ONE OF
TWENTY TWENTY FOUR. WE BELIEVE
THAT THIS ASKING IS CONSISTENT
WITH THE- FIVE YEAR REPLACEMENT
CYCLE TO MEET THE CALIFORNIA
DEPARTMENT OF TECHNOLOGIES BEST
PRACTICES FOR HARDWARE
REPLACEMENT MAINTENANCE SUPPORT.
AND IS CONSISTENT WITH OUR
SISTER AGENCIES H. P. THAT ALSO
DOES A REFRESH OF THEIR AB
YELLING CATS SYSTEM TO EVERY
FIVE YEARS. WITH THAT I'M
STEPHEN I'LL TURN IT BACK TO YOU
APPENDING QUESTIONS. SO LET'S
JUST CHECK BACK WITH CARILLO YES
AND SEE IF WHILE. WE'RE GOOD.
ANY LUCK OVER AT CALLOWAY'S
HEADQUARTERS. OKAY WELL I WILL
GO AHEAD AND PROVIDE
RECORD-EAGLE FIRESTONE AND THAT
THAT YOU'VE TYLER ALSO IT THIS
IS A JOINT PROPOSAL BETWEEN
CALLAWAY US IN CALIFORNIA OR SO
AND WE'LL DO WE'LL DO OUR BEST
TO ANSWER QUESTIONS AND HANDLE
THIS WELL WE- WE FOR- YES TO BE
ABLE TO THANK YOU I KNOW IT'S
NOT THE NORM FOR- CAL OH YES TO
BE THE AGENCY. HAS A HARD TIME
COMMUNICATING. HELLO USUALLY
PASSED. SO AWARE TO- SO THE
VIRUS PER IS IF I MENTION TO
JOIN HER WOULD CAO YEAH CAL- UP
IN ITS MAY DOLLARS I'M GOING
GENERAL FUND AND THIRTY ONE
POSITIONS TWENTY FOUR POINT FOUR
MILLION AND ELEVEN POSITIONS
WOULD BE A CALLOW YES THE
REMAINING FIVE POINT SIX MILLION
IN TWENTY POSITIONS WOULD BE A
CALIFORNIA- REALLY WITH THIS
WITH THIS DOES IS IT. TEN YEARS
AND- ENHANCES A PILOT PROGRAM
THAT WAS STARTED THROUGH A
LEGISLATIVE INVESTMENT IN THE
TWO THOUSAND NINETEEN BUDGET.
THAT PROVIDED SOME FUNDING FOR A
ORANGE COUNTY FIRE DISTRICT TO
START UP A- PROGRAM WITH THIS
PROGRAM DOES IS IT DOES. AERIAL
INTELLIGENCE GATHERING. NEAR
REAL TIME INSTANTANEOUS
INTELLIGENCE. OVER DIFFERENT
DISASTERS KNOWS THE NAME
INDICATES ONE OF THE PRIMARY
USES OF THIS IS BEEN WILDFIRE.
BUT IT ALSO HAS BEEN USED FOR
THE OIL SPILL THAT RECENTLY
HAPPENED- AND IT CAN BE USED FOR
ALL HAZARD- TYPES IN TERMS OF
GATHERING INTELLIGENCE TO HELP
WITH. STRATEGIC AND- BETTER
INFORMED REAL TIME DECISIONS FOR
ON THE GROUND AND IN
CALIFORNIA'S POSITIONSAND-
ORDERLY BE GEARED TOWARDS. THAT
ON THE GROUND REAL TIME DECISION
MAKING USING OF THAT
INTELLIGENCE AND THE CALLOW YES
RESOURCES WILL REALLY HELP WITH
THE- IMPROVE OUR WITH WITHIN
INFORMING. HAVE DECISIONS AT THE
STATE LEVEL FOR- OF OUR OUR
HIGHEST LEVEL STILL OF THE
STATE'S BUDGET MAKERS. WHAT THE
WITH THIS PROPOSAL DOES THE IN
TERMS OF ENHANCING ON WHAT
ORANGE COUNTY HAS ALREADY DONE
IS THE UNDER THE ORANGE COUNTY
PROGRAM. WE HAVE ACCESS TO ONE
AIRCRAFT IN A TWENTY FOUR SEVEN
BASIS IN SOUTHERN CALIFORNIA AND
THEN IN NORTHERN CALIFORNIA. IS
A RECALL THERE'S A IT'S A
BASICALLY A TWELVE HOUR A DAY
AVAILABILITY AND SO THIS.
ENHANCEMENT WOULD BE TO MAKE
SURE THAT WE HAVE TWENTY FOUR
SEVEN AIRCRAFT AVAILABILITY BOTH
IN SOUTHERN CALIFORNIA AND
NORTHERN CALIFORNIA SO THAT WE
CAN GET AN AIR ASSETS TO COLLECT
INTELLIGENCE. ARE RAPIDLY
REGARDLESS OF WHERE WE HAVE
DISASTERS- IN THE STATE. AND
ALSO REALLY ENHANCE OUR
CAPABILITIES IN TERMS OF WHEN WE
HAVE MULTIPLE DISASTERS GOING ON
WHICH HAS BEEN A FREQUENT
OCCURRENCE IN THE STATE HAS
CERTAINLY IN RECENT YEARS. SO I
WILL LEAVE IT WITH THAT AN INCH
CHIEF TYLERTON'S ANYTHING YOU I
WOULD LIKE TO ADD A WELCOME TO
DO THAT. YEAH I APPRECIATE THAT
STEPHEN- I GUESS I WOULD ASK FOR
STEVEN DID- YES MAKE IT ONLINE.
AND IF NOT I WILL- TRY TO SPEAK
ON THEIR BEHALF- I THINK THAT-
WE HAVE SHARED- THE- POINTS TO
BE ABLE TO DO SO. YOUR FRIEND
WELL STEVEN AND BLUE IN MEMBERS
AGAIN I APPRECIATE THIS
OPPORTUNITY- THE FIRES PROPOSAL
IS AN EXCITING ADVENTURE BEING
ABLE TO MOVE- THIS PROPOSAL FROM
A LOCAL GOVERNMENT- ORANGE
COUNTY FIRE AUTHORITY- PROGRAM
INTO THE STATE OF CALIFORNIA- IN
JOINT BETWEEN CALLOW YES AND-
AND CAL FIRE. IT IS AN
OPPORTUNITY- TO INSURE THAT WE
ARE MEETING THE NEEDS OF ALL
HAZARD INCIDENTS ACROSS THE
STATE OF CALIFORNIA AS WELL AS-
OUR WILDFIRE PROBLEM ACROSS THE
STATE AS WELL- THE PROPOSAL IS
AND YOU SAID STEPHEN REALLY
INCLUDES FUNDING FOR TO FULLY
CAPABLE AIRCRAFT TWENTY FOUR
HOURS A DAY. EVERY DAY OF THE
YEAR PILOTS AND AIRCREW
MAINTENANCE- SUPPORT OF A-
FUSION CENTER ACROSS THE STATE
ADDITIONAL MODELERS FUNDS A
SUPPORT- TECHNOLOGICAL UPDATES-
AND ENSURING THAT THERE'S
CONTRACTUAL SUPPORT- THIS
PROGRAM REALLY IS- MANAGED.
THROUGH CALORIE S. AND THEN IN
PARTNERSHIP BETWEEN- CALLAWAY US
IN CALIFORNIA WE WILL HAVE AN
ABILITY THROUGH AN OPERATING
PLAN TO OPERATE THIS AIRCRAFT ON
ALL HAS EMERGENCIES ACROSS THE
STATE CALIFORNIA. A PAUSE THERE. A PENDING ANY QUESTIONS EVEN.
I THINK ALL WE HAVE MISTER
CHAIRED IN TERMS OF PRESENTATION
ON THESE ITEMS SO- WILL CONNECT
SEEM TO L. A- FOR ANY. THINGS-
TREAT YOUR PLEASURE. THANK YOU
ADD CHAIR IF I IF I MAY- IS OKAY
IF I PROCEED THANK YOU MIKE YEAH
THANK YOU SO MUCHFOR- I GET THE
OPPORTUNITY THAT TO PROVIDE SOME
COMMENTS ON THIS ITEM I'M SO WE
RECENTLY RELEASED THE SECOND
REPORT I KNOW WE REFERENCE THAT
ONE ON WELFARE RESILIENCY ALSO
RECENTLY USED ONE. THAT COVERS
THE MAJOR WILDFIRE RESPONSE
RELATED PROPOSALS I'M SO
THAT IT'S ALSO AGAIN ON OUR
WEBSITE I MISS EMORY SOME OF THE
OVER ARCHING I AM PLEASED THAT
WE BRING UP IN THAT- IN THAT
REPORT. AS WELL AS THE
RECOMMENDATIONS ON THAT THREE
PROPOSAL THAT YOU'RE HEARING
TODAY AS PART OF THIS- THIS
HEARING SO OVERALL WE FIND THAT
SUPPORTING ADDITIONAL WHAT THAT
RESPONSE CAPACITY AND HAVE A LOT
OF MERIT AGAIN YOU HEARD ABOUT
SOME OF THAT REALLY- SEVERE
WILDFIRES THE STATE HAS HAD- AND
THOSE HAVE STRANGE CAPACITY-
UNDER RESPONSE SIDE- SO WE DO
THINK IT'S REASONABLE TO DO SOME
OCCUPATIONS IN THIS AREA.
HOWEVER WE DO FIND THAT THE
PROPOSAL'S WOULD RESULT IN A
VERY LARGE INCREASING HELP
BUYERS BASED SUPPORT BUDGET
ABOUT THIRTY THREE PERCENT- AT
AT INCREASE IN ITS BASS
RESPONSE- BUDGET FACE UP OUR
PRODUCTION BUDGET SO THAT'S
REALLY QUITE SUBSTANTIAL AND IN
TOTAL WILL BE OUT OF ALL THESE
PROPOSALS INCLUDING THE CAP
OUTLINES. ON YEAH THAT CLOSE TO
A BILLION DOLLARS NINE HUNDRED
TWENTY MILLION DOLLARS IN BUDGET
YEARAND QUITE A BIT OF ONGOING
FINDING MOST OF ITS ONGOING SO
REALLY IT'S A LOT OF A LOT OF
GENERAL FUND THAT WOULD BE
DEDICATED. DEDICATED TO
INCREASING- SORT OF RESPONSE
RESOURCES. I SO AND EXCEPT FOR
ISN'T HAPPENED PRETTY
SUBSTANTIAL AND- THAT- HAVE BEEN
MADE TO. FIRE AND I'M- BY
DIFFICULT. FEW YEARS AS WELL.
OKAY I'M I'M ANOTHER KEY POINT
IS THAT IT'S AN- TO. AT THIS
TIME EXTENT TO WHICH TO MAKE
PROPOSALS WILL ENHANCE CAPACITY
- BACK THE END OF A WHAT. RANGE
WHICH IS A REALLY CRITICAL
PLEDGES IS GOING TO GRAPPLE WITH
AS CONSIDERS ALL THESE PROPOSALS
- AND FILING THINK THAT THE
STATE WE CAN TAKE. ADVANTAGE
FROM DEVELOPMENT A STRATEGIC
WILDFIRE. PLAN WE TALKED ABOUT A
COUPL OF YEARS. WE MADE THAT
RECOMMENDATION WE STILL THINK
IT'S REALLY IMPORTANT WE WOULD
NOW WE TALK A LITTLE BIT EARLIER
THIS HEARING ABOUT REPORTS THAT.
THAT HAVE MEANT THAT THE
INVESTORS AND HAVEN'T HAD A
CHANCE TO COMPLETE YET YOU OTHER
DEMANDS. I'M SO THIS IS ANOTHER
AREA OF THE LEGISLATURE ASKED
FOR RECORDS PRINCIPLE MIDDLE
REPORT. WHICH IN TWENTY NINETEEN
TWENTY. THAT WAS SUPPOSED TO BE
DO YOU- APRIL OF TWENTY TWENTY.
AND THAT REPORT AND IS STILL
PENDING WE THINK THAT WOULD BE
REALLY HELPFUL REPORTS TO HELP.
INFORM THE LEGISLATURE DECISIONS
BECAUSE THAT REPORT ASKED FOR
INFORMATION ON WHAT ARE THE
RESOURCES THAT CAL FIRE AND- YES
HAVE. WHAT ARE THE GAS WHAT ARE
THE GOALS ONE OF THE COST
EFFECTIVE APPROACHES. WE
CONTINUE TO THINK THAT'S
IMPORTANT. AND SO NOW DESPITE
THAT SETBACK THE- LACK OF THAT
KIND OF PLAN WE THINK THE
LEGISLATURE OBVIOUSLY IS GOING
TO NEED TO MAKE DECISIONS ABOUT
FUNDING. ABOUT DEALING WITH THE
RESPONSE NEEDS THAT THE STATE
HAS- AND SO WE DID PROVIDE WE DO
PROVIDE. AND IF THAT'S- HELLO.
I'M GONNA GO THROUGH THOSE.
THOSE THREE THAT WE'RE ABOUT
TWO. WE WERE TO THE EMERGENCY
SURGE COMPACT PROPOSAL YOU HEARD
ABOUT. THE ONE THAT WE FOUND.
YOU TO HELP. BAD I'M RESERVE AND
- THAT DOES- WE'RE- HOLDING
ACTION ON THIS GROUP. AT THIS
TIME THE REASON FOR THE- IS THAT
THIS PROPOSAL WOULD BE. AND
THREE RESTORE. THAT ARE- THAT
ARE BACK REALLY IT'S PART OF AN
- BUDGET ITEM BUT THERE'S THAT
FOR HUNDRED. DOLLARS IT
SATISFIED THE BUDGET THERE NO B.
THEO P. YEAH. I'M THAT WOULD BE
FOR THE HEALTH AND- OF. I'M A
FIRE- WHO ARE ON THE LOOK AND SO
THE IDEA AS I AM IT AS IS WITH-
WITH THE FIRE JUST. TO DEVELOP
THE- OF WHAT THE PROPOSAL LOOKS
LIKE MIGHT SEE IN. I'M SORRY
YOUR SEATS IS THAT THE STATE FOR
THE HEALTH OF. COMPONENT AND THE
PURPOSE. IS- INVISION TO BE
PROVIDED AS PART OF THAT FOR HIM
BILLION SO I'M THAT THERE'S A
LOT. BETWEEN THAT MANY AND THIS
PROPOSAL SO WE IT'S IMPORTANT TO
THINK ABOUT THEM- TOGETHER AND
TO SEND YOUR GRIEF. BECAUSE OF
THAT WE ALSO KNOW THAT WE CAN
KIND OF PROPOSAL THAT- IT'S A
LITTLE BIT- EXTRA. VALUE RATE
WITHOUT THIS KIND OF STRATEGIC
PLANNING PART OF IT'S JUST
BECAUSE THIS IS EITHER SOME OF
THEM I'M PRETTY TECHNICAL THINGS
ABOUT WELL HOW HOW DO WE MAKE
DECISIONS ABOUT HELICOPTERS
VERSUS HOW MANY ENGINES HAVING
ENGINE SHOULD BE- YES ENGINES.
YOU KNOW THEY THEY MAINTAIN A
FLEET OF ENGINES WE TRIED SYSTEM
VERSUS CAL FIRE ENGINES THOSE
TYPES OF THINGS- SO WE THINK
THAT THE LEGISLATURE HAS SOME
OPTIONS THE CURRENT- ULTIMATELY
ONCE IT YOU KNOW I THINK RECEIVE
THAT THAT THE OTHER PROPOSAL IS
KIND OF DECIDING WHAT TO DO.
COULD APPROVE EVERYTHING AS- AS
REQUESTED OR COULD TAKE A
DIFFERENT APPROACH- FOR EXAMPLE
ONE THING THAT WE MENTIONED AS
AN ALTERNATIVE IS- YOU COULD
PROVIDE SOMEBODY RESOURCES THIS
YEAR DELAY PROVIDING SOME OF
THEM AND TO A FUTURE YEAR AND SO
YOU GET THAT- THAT IT'S EXPECTED
THE ADMINISTRATION. TO HELP
GUIDE DECISION MAKING YOU COULD
POTENTIALLY DO IN A WAY THAT
WOULD NECESSARILY HOLD UP THE
RECEIPT OF THOSE SO ONE THING TO
MENTION IS IT'S GOING TO TAKE A
FEW YEARS TO GET THE HELICOPTERS
ANYWAYS OR YOUR STANDING IS FOR
EXAMPLE FOR EVERY. HELICOPTER
YOU ORDER IT TAKES NEXT THREE
YEARS IF YOU ORDER TO YOU IT
TAKES YEARS OF YOUR REPORT
THANKS FOR YEARS- ABOUT SO FOR
EXAMPLE YOU CAN'T CONSIDER WELL
YOU CAN PROVE TO YOU AND YOU CAN
MEET AND- THE END YOU CAN STILL
WAIT ON THE OTHER TO YOU UNTIL
YOU HAVE THAT. THAT ADDITIONAL
INFORMATION SO THAT'S ONE OPTION
THAT THAT'S AVAILABLE TO THE
LEGISLATURE AS WELL ON EMERGENCY
SEARCH CAPACITY. I'M SO ON- I.
GET THE TICKET IN ORDER WE WENT
AND THE- INTO. ON EIGHT K. ABA.
WE'RE GOING TO THAT THE PROGRAM.
ON THE BENEFITS EXTENDING AB I.
EVERY CAL. CRAP I RESOURCE IT
JUST AS- I THINK IT'S VERY. IN
THE- COMMENTS MADE BY THE- RIGHT
NOW. AB L. THAT. VEHICLE LOW. IS
ON ABOUT. HUNDRED REACHED. ARE
CARTON. TO GEN CARS. THAT THE
HAS AND THOSE ARE. THE FOR LINE
ONE THERE KNOW CARS AND- ENGINES
YEAH. VEHICLES JUST THE CARS.
I'M THE IDEA IS THAT THIS WAY
AND THEN. PROPOSAL EXPAND. L. TO
ALL OF THE OF THE VIA. THAT THAT
. HAS SO. SIX HUNDRED TO TWENTY
FOUR HAD- SO. JEFF BE THE FOR
LINE- YEAH ALL REGIONS THOSE
KINDS OF VEHICLES. ON THE WOULD
BE AB VEHICLE THAT THE
DEPARTMENT. I SO- SO WE CAN IT'S
IMPORTANT TO THEM REALLY MAKE A
CASE FOR WHY EVEN THOUGH THIS.
ARE FRONT VEHICLE NEED THAT LOOK
. ALL THE TIME. I'M WELL AS Y.
YEAR REPLACEMENT CYCLE IS THAT
FOR A FOR ALL THOSE CARS SO
YOU'RE- ARE. GREAT YOU KNOW YOU
KNOW THEY ONLY HAVE A CERTAIN
LIFE BY ANYWAY WHEN THEY GET A
NEW CAR THEY GET. ON AT L. AS
PER OF THAT SO I DON'T CLEAR
EYES WERE AT WHITE EVERYONE
NEEDS REPLACE AND EVERY
EXPENSIVE I THINK IT'S ABOUT-
FOURTEEN. DOLLARS EACH SENATOR
PER SO IF SOME TO THINK ABOUT
WHETHER REALLY NEED BE REPLACED
IT ON A- ONE OF THOSE THIRTY SIX
HUNDRED- VEHICLES FIVE YEARS-
AND THE CONSISTENCY. WITH OTHER
GOVERNMENT ENTITIES- WE THINK
THOSE ARE IMPORTANT THEY JUST
THE AMOUNT OF ANY THAT'S IN.
HERE WE THINKS CAN IN AB- OR
TECHNO. AND VERY VALUABLE I'M
JUST TRYING TO. MAKE SURE THAT
THE LEGISLATURE HAVE ALL THE
INFORMATION IT NEEDS TO THIS TO
DETERMINE WHETHER REALLY THIS
FULL PROPOSAL IS NECESSARY OR
WHETHER. I'M TO MODIFY PROPOSAL
THAT COULD FOR EXAMPLE PROVIDE
EIGHTY GALLON A SUBSET OF THE
FLEET OR LONGER REPLACEMENT
CYCLES MIGHT BE SUFFICIENT. I'M
AND THEN FINALLY ON THE FEAR IS
PROPOSAL AND YOU'RE RECOMMENDING
LEGISLATURE DIRECT I'M
COMPARING- YES REPORT. AYE BUT
HEARINGS ON AN ALTERNATIVE THAT
WOULD FIND THIS PROPOSAL AT THE
CURRENT LEVEL OF SERVICE SO ADDS
AND I WOULD ESTIMATE AND SEND
MENTION AND- OTHERS THIS HAS
BEEN HIGHLIGHTED SINCE TWO
THOUSAND AND NINETEEN IN- ORANGE
COUNTY AND- IT'S BEEN PILOTED
ITS AND OUT. THROUGH LOWER LEVEL
OF SERVICE UNLESS COVERAGE THAT
IS BEING PROPOSED HERE. AND THE
PROPOSAL MENTION THAT FOR
EXAMPLE EXTENDING BACK- ORANGE
COUNTY I HAVE BOB- ORANGE
COUNTY- PILOT. IS ESTIMATED TO
COST ABOUT SEVENTEEN MILLION-
THIS PROPOSAL WOULD COST ABOUT
THIRTY MILLION CIRCUMSTANTIALLY
MORE THAN CONTINUING THAT PILOT.
WE UNDERSTAND THAT WORKS COUNTY
ISN'T INTERESTED IN CONTINUING
TO CUT SO THAT'S NOT AN OPTION.
I'M BUT- ONE OPTION COULD BE
WELL THAT THE STATE. KNOW THAT.
IF THEY WANT I THINK BEYOND IT'S
LEVEL OF SERVICE ARE GOING TO
WANT TO KEEP LEVEL SIR THAT.
THAT'S BARTENDER PILOT. WE WOULD
NOTE THE- DEPARTMENT HAS PRETTY
. I HAVE ACCESS TO. I'M PRETTY
SIMILAR OTHER. TO PROVIDE I'M
SOME AERIAL SUPPORT THAT YOU
KNOW AND RECONNAISSANCE KIND OF-
OF. ADVANCED AND SATELLITE
SATELLITE COVERAGE AS WELL SO
THEY ARE ABLE TO PROVIDE SOME OF
THAT MISSION IS A LITTLE BIT OF
A DELAY- BUT THAT IT'S I'M
PRETTY IMPORTANT AND VALUABLE
COVERAGE AND SO FIFTY. THE STATE
HAVE ACCESS TO THAT AS WELL AND
WE THINK IT'S IMPORTANT TO
UNDERSTAND OKAY WELL WHAT ARE
THE BENEFITS OF. A THROUGH THE
DIFFERENT LEVELS OF SERVICE FOR
FEAR AND- WHAT ARE THE DIFFERENT
LEVELS OF COST AND DO WE NEED TO
GET THIS HIGHER LEVEL SERVICE SO
WE'RE WE'RE RECOMMENDING THAT
THE DEPARTMENT'S REPORT BACK ON
HOW MUCH IT WOULD COST TO
EXPAND. EXISTING LEVEL OF
SERVICE- UNDER CAL- YES IN
CALIFORNIA- FOR THEM TO TAKE ON
THAT LEVEL OF SERVICE THE
LEGISLATURE COULD MAKE THAT
DECISION WHETHER WANT TO GO
WITH- BUT THE TWO PLANES
BASICALLY. OR THE ONE PLANE AND
TWENTY FOUR SEVEN. I SO ARE
THOSE ARE TO RECOMMEND. WE HAD
HAPPY TO ANY QUESTION- FROM THE
- THANK YOU OF I'M SURE WE WILL
HAVE SOME QUESTIONS GOOD- IS
THERE ANY- FOLLOW UP FROM A
DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE. OH SORRY
STRUCTURE YEAH- NO NO FOLLOW UP
IN TERMS OF THE L. A. O.'S
PRESENTATION BUT IT WON'T LET
YOU KNOW THAT THE- HELLO YES HAS
BEEN ABLE TO JOIN THE SHOULD
HAVE AUDIO WITH THEM NOW SO A
VERY MUCH ALIVE WHEN WE DO THAT
I DO KNOW THAT- CHIEF FANTASY
FROM THE ORANGE COUNTY FIRE
AUTHORITY WANTED TO. ADD SOME
COMMENTS ABOUT THE FAIREST
SYSTEM AS WELL. HI GOOD MORNING
THE THIRTEEN OR THIRTY TO
SEVENTY DIRECTOR ITALO YES
SIMPLE YOU CAN HEAR ME NOW. YES
THANK YOU I APPRECIATE YOUR
TECHNICAL STAFF VERY QUICKLY
GETTING AT THE- THAT'LL HAPPEN
PHONE NUMBER SO THAT WE CAN
PARTICIPATE IN THAT METHODOLOGY
AND STEVEN BENSON AND EVERY
DIRECTOR TYLER DID A DID A GREAT
JOB INTERVIEW THING- OF COURSE
ARE COMING TO RELATED TO THE
VIRUS PC. AND THEY DID A GREAT
JOB INTRODUCING IT I WON'T BE
REDUNDANT WITH WHAT THEY COVER
BUT I WOULD HAVE A IVE A COUPLE
THINGS FIRST- WE'RE VERY VERY
FORTUNATE TO HAVE HAD THE
OPPORTUNITY TO PILOT THE SYSTEM
WITH ORANGE COUNTY. FIRE
AUTHORITY AS HAS ALREADY BEEN
DESCRIBED- OVER THE LAST COUPLE
YEARS- IN THAT IN THAT TIME WE
USED IT IN REAL WORLD INCIDENTS
NOT JUST FOR WILDFIRES BUT FOR
ALL HAZARDS. AND SO THEREFORE
THIS PROPOSAL FOR THIRTY
MILLION- AND THIRTY ONE POSITION
IF THEY TAKE THAT SUCCESSFUL
PILOT AND MOVE IT INTO THE
MUTUAL AID SYSTEMS THAT SAME
SYSTEM THAT YOU'RE FAMILIAR WITH
THAT- IS HERE TO ADDRESS ALL OF
THAT WILDFIRE HAZARDS THAT
INCREASING THREAT. AT THAT
YOU'RE THAT THAT WE DISCUSSED
ALREADY IN THE COMMITTEE BUT
ALSO OTHER DISASTERS WHICH OFTEN
HAPPENED CONCURRENT WITH
WILDFIRES AS WE HAVE THE- OVER
THE PAST FEW YEARS SAID THIS
TECHNOLOGY GIVES A THUMBS GIVE A
TOOL IN THE TOOLBOX THAT WASN'T-
YOU KNOW THAT IS THAT IS
DIFFERENT FROM OTHERS IN THAT IT
IS. DEDICATED AND THAT IS ABLE
TO RAPIDLY DEPLOY FOR THOSE
INITIAL ATTACK THEY GIVE A
SITUATIONAL AWARENESS AND
DECISION TOOLS IN ORDER TO
ALLOCATE RESOURCES QUICKLY
PICKED TO CONTEND WITH TODAY'S
WELL PARKER AT IT IS ALSO
AVAILABLE RAPIDLY TO GIVE A
SITUATIONAL AWARENESS FOR OTHER
TYPE AMERICANS BEING LIKE
EARTHQUAKES LIKE KONAMI- LIKE
FOR IT CETERA. SHOW THE NEED FOR
TWENTY FOUR SEVEN COVERAGE IN
TWO PLANES THAT HAVE BEEN
DISCUSSED IN THE PROPOSAL WELL
AND GIVE US THAT CAPABILITY FOR
REAL TIME WE DO HAVE EITHER-
TOOLS AT OUR DISPOSAL. ALL OF
THEM WILL BE LEVERAGED THERE IS
A LEAD TIME WITH SOME. OF THE
MILITARY ASSETS AS WITH APPLE
WITH MENTIONED- IN THE COMMON
BEFORE- THAT WE WILL NOT HAVE.
THE NO SO THAT OF THE- FOR
INITIAL ATTACK IS REALLY KEY TO
THIS AND IMPORTANTLY THIS IS BE
PART OF THE MUTUAL. THE UTILIZES
. THAT NOT ALL- TAP TO RESTORE.
FOR MORE OF A- FOR WILDFIRES
ALSO ALL. CAL IS A TREMENDOUS
PARTNER. HELLO YES- WITH THE
MUTUAL AID SYSTEM AND THEREFORE
THIS ADVOCATES THAT PARTNERSHIP
ON THE VIRUSES IS THAT SOMETHING
THAT WE LOOK FORWARD TO
LEVERAGING FULLY BASED ON THE
SUCCESS OF THE PILOT. I HAVE
COLLEAGUES HERE- OUR CHIEF OF
FIRE RESCUE BRIAN MARSHALL- IN
THE ROOM AND WE'RE HAPPY TO
ANSWER ANY QUESTIONS ON THIS
PROPOSAL THANK YOU AGAIN. WELL
YOU GOT TO PARTICIPATE. GREAT
THANK YOU VERY MUCH- DO WE-
HAVE- CHIEF FENNESSY AVAILABLE.
GOOD MORE CHERUB CAN YOU ME OK.
ABSOLUTELY THANK YOU FOR THIS
OPPORTUNITY AS I SIT HERE AND AS
I READ THE PROPOSED BUDGET I
HAVE TO TELL YOU HOW- HOW GREAT
IT FEELS TO TAKE A PROGRAM THAT
WE ACTUALLY PRESENTED I BELIEVE
YOU CO CHAIRED TECHNOLOGY
COMMITTEE IN TWO THOUSAND
NINETEEN WAS SENATOR DODD AND
THIS WAS ONE OF THE ITEMS THAT
WE BROUGHT FORWARD. AND THE SAME
YEAR- FOR A HALF MILLION DOLLARS
WAS WAS ALLOCATED BY THE STATE
FOR THE PILOT PROGRAM. IT'S
SINCE GROWN- I APPRECIATE. THE
COMMENTS. OF MAY THE DESCRIPTION
PROGRAM DESCRIPTION IS MADE
BEFORE. OF ME COMING UP ONLINE-
A COUPLE CORRECTIONS THE- THERE
ARE TWO AIRCRAFT OPERATING THEIR
STANDARD DAYS TWENTY FOUR HOURS
AND TWELVE HOURS BUT THEY'RE
INTERCHANGEABLE SO- THE ENTIRE
STATE. TODAY IT'S TWENTY FOUR
HOUR COVERAGE. BUT ONE OF THE
OTHER AIRCRAFT. WHAT I REALLY
WANT TO TALK ABOUT IS HOW THIS
IS DIFFERENT AND I THINK-
CALCHAS IN CHIEF TYLER HIT ON
THE HEAD. THIS IS A NATIONAL
ATTACK RESOURCE THIS IS
DIFFERENT THAN ANYTHING THE
STATE OR EVEN THE UNITED STATES
HAS RIGHT NOW- THESE AIRCRAFT
LAUNCH ON THE REPORT THE FIRE.
OF A FLOOD OIL SPILL TRAIN
DERAILMENT THEY'VE DONE ALL
THAT- THERE ONTO. THEIR OVER TOP
OF THESE THESE ACTIONS VERY
QUICKLY AND THE PROVIDING. LIVE
STREAM VIDEO. YOUR TIME TO ON
THEIR WAY VIDEO. MAPPING
LANDOWNERS. UP OF THESE ANSWERS
ALL WITHIN MINUTES OF ARRIVAL IN
TODAY THAT INFORMATION IS GOING
OUT TO HUNDREDS IF NOT THOUSANDS
OF FIREFIGHTERS ON THEIR
SMARTPHONES- LAST YEAR DURING A
LARGE FIRES IN NORTHERN
CALIFORNIA ONE OF THE SCREENS OF
THE STATE OPERATIONS CENTER- WAS
DEDICATED TO THE FIRES PLATFORM.
SURE YOU'RE GETTING YOUR
INFORMATION THAT WE HAVEN'T. WE
HAVEN'T HAD IN THE PAST I GO
BACK TO. RIDGECREST EARTHQUAKE
WE SPOKE ABOUT THIS A FEW YEARS
AGO AT THE COMMITTEE MEETING.
RIDGECREST HAS YOU KNOW A COUPLE
THREE HOURS DRIVE FROM LA NOT
TOO FAR AWAY WE DID NOT HAVE
REAL TIME CALLAWAY YES NOBODY
HAD REAL TIME QUALITY
INFORMATION FOR HOURS AFTER THAT
EARTHQUAKE. TODAY IN THAT SAME
SCENARIO. YOU WILL HAVE AN
AIRCRAFT OVER THAT OVER ANY CITY
ANY ERROR IN STATE MIGHT BE
WITHIN A HALF AN HOUR YOU'RE
GONNA GET LIVE STREAM. VIDEO
YOU'RE GOING TO GET ANY AIRCRAFT
THAT PROVIDES. THE ABILITY TO
LOOK THROUGH CLOUT. THESE
AIRCRAFT HAVE- I HAVE-
TECHNOLOGY AND SYSTEMS ON THEM
SENSING SYSTEMS THAT NO OTHER
HAS COLLECTIVELY- THE ABILITY TO
SEE THROUGH CLOUT. THE BILL IT
IS THE SOME INTO DAM SAYS WE'RE
WE'RE- WITH UNITS OF CALIFORNIA
SAN DIEGO AND TIED INTO THE
SUPER COMPUTER SYSTEM THERE AND-
YOU KNOW THE ARTIFICIAL
INTELLIGENCE IN THOSE SORTS OF
THINGS. UCSD IS CLOSE TO HAVING
WHAT WE WOULD CALL. HOME FOR
LACK OF BETTER WORD WHICH IN THE
FAR SERVICE THE ABILITY TO DO A
WINDSHIELD SURVEY. OVER AN AREA
THAT'S BEEN DAMAGED EITHER BY
FIRE EARTHQUAKE WHATEVER IT IS
SEE THROUGH CLOUD BE ABLE TO
PROVIDE YOU ADDRESSES- LOCATIONS
OF A ONE BUILDINGS ARE STANDING
WHICH ARE NOT WHICH ARE DAMAGED.
WE'RE DOING FLOOD- PREDICTION
MODELING. THEY'RE DOING WILDLAND
FIRE- COME YEARS AGO EARLY IN
THE PROGRAM THIS INFORMATION IN
LOS ANGELES DURING A SANTA ANA
WIND FIRE WAS WAS SENT TO- REAL
TIME THE PHONE OF THE FIRE CHIEF
IN LOS ANGELES. AND A FAST
MOVING FIRE AT NIGHT MOVING INTO
THAT COMMUNITY- AS WE ALL KNOW
AND I'M SURE CHIEF TYLER
MARSHALL WITH TEST TO WE HAVE
THESE FIRES IT TAKES TIME TO
ASSEMBLE ENOUGH RESOURCES. AND
WE'RE DEDICATED TO EVACUATIONS
THE PHARMACY WAS ABLE TO TAKE
THIS INFORMATION THE SPREAD
MOLLY NO MORE THE FIRE WAS GONNA
HIT FIRST. GET THE CITIZENS OUT
OF THOSE AREAS THAT WE'RE GOING
TO BE. IMPACTED RIGHT AWAY IN
CONVERSELY HE SHARED WITH THE
POLICE CHIEF OF LOS ANGELES WHO
WAS ABLE TO GET HIS OFFICERS TO
TARGET THOSE AREAS OF
EVACUATION. TO WERE ABLE TO
FOCUS RESOURCES IN THOSE AREAS
THAT NEEDED THE MOST EARLY ON
AND ALSO TARGET THOSE
COMMUNITIES AND NEEDED TO BE
EVACUATED. SO THIS IS A VERY
UNIQUE RESOURCE- THERE ARE NO
OTHER SYSTEMS LIKE THIS THE
MILITARY AS- A ASSET BUT AS
MENTIONED EARLIER. IT DOES TAKE
TIME TO USE THEM. ALL CLOSE BY.
YOU KNOW THE DIFFERENCE. A MAN
AND I. ERICA OR- OR ARE SIMPLY
THIS. YOU IN A GAME MANTICORE
CRAFT YOU HAVE THE ABILITY TO
THE FOLKS IN THE AIRCRAFT HAVE
THE ABILITY TO. GO LOOK AND MAKE
DECISIONS WHILE AIRBORNE- THAT'S
NOT ALWAYS THE CASE IN AN
UNMANNED AIRCRAFT. THESE
AIRCRAFT ARE STAFFED WITH US- A
DOCTOR TECHNICAL GROUP
SUPERVISORS THESE ARE OUR TAX.
WE'VE GOT THIRTEEN OR FOURTEEN
OUR ON CONTRACTORS FORMER U. S.
FOREST SERVICE FOREST FORMER CAL
FIRE. FORMER DEPARTMENT YOUR ERA
TAXES LARGELY SEEN AS IT IS
REALLY THE DREAM TEAM THESE
FOLKS ARE ARE STILL ENGAGED IN
TRAINING AND WORKING WITH THE
OTHER AGENCIES. THESE FOLKS-
HAVE HAVE. IMMENSE EXPERTISE
EXPERIENCE AND GROUND OPERATIONS
AND AVIATION OPERATIONS ARE ABLE
TO TALK TO THE OTHER AIRCRAFT.
WE HAVE A- A COUPLE AIR TANKER
PILOTS- JUST THIS YEAR THAT.
HAVE THE INFORMATION GOING TO
THE PHONES. FOR US FOR PROVIDING
THEM MORE IN. ABOUT IT INCIDENT
THEY WERE FLYING TO THAN THEY
WOULD HAVE HAD IN TOLD IT
ARRIVED. AND SO THIS IS A UNIQUE
PROGRAM IT'S GROWING- IT'S GOT
TO CLEAR THE AIR A LITTLE BIT
IT'S NOT NECESSARILY THAT ORANGE
COUNTY IS NOT INTERESTED IN
CONTINUING THIS. IT JUST REALLY
DOESN'T MAKE SENSE FOR US TO DO
THAT AS MENTIONED EARLIER THESE
ARE STATE. IT WAS A PILOT
PROGRAM THAT IS GROWN HAS REALLY
BECOME A STATE MUTUAL AID
RESOURCE. HELLO YES IS THE
CUSTODIAN OF THE CARETAKER THE
MUTUAL AID SYSTEM KALIFORNIA IS
A BIG GO A PARTICIPANT IN THAT.
I THINK IT IF YOU WERE TELLING
TODAY THAT- WE WERE GOING TO
RECEIVE SEVENTEEN MILLION TO
PROVIDE THIS ON YOUR OWN BASIS I
PROBABLY HAVE TO TAKE IT'S NOT
ENOUGH- IF YOU WANT TO OUR CRAFT
I THINK IT DOES MAKE SENSE TO
HAPPEN TWENTY FOUR HOURS
AVAILABLE. YOU MAY. EVEN NEED A
THIRD AS RESERVE- IT'S LIKE
YOU'RE YOU MAY HAVE A OFFER. TO
AND OF YOU BETTER SOMETHING-
DECEIT PROGRAM GROW AND HEAR
ABOUT TE POSITIONS THAT
CALIFORNIA LOW YESTERDAY THE
ISSUE. TO TAKE IT TO THE NEXT
LEVEL ACTUALLY MAKE SENSE TO ME.
AND SO REALLY- I I'M HERE TO DO
BAD INPUT TO CLARIFY TO ANSWER
ANY QUESTIONS YOU MAY HAVE BUT
THANK YOU VERY MUCH FOR YOUR
TIME TODAY THANK THANK YOU- G.
FANTASY. MAYBE YOU CAN HELP ME
UNDERSTAND BETTER- HOW A- DRONE
FUNCTIONS DIFFERENTLY FROM-
MANNED AIRCRAFT. I WAS UNDER THE
ASSUMPTION- I LISTENED CAREFULLY
TO YOUR COMMENT ABOUT HOW PEOPLE
IN THE AIR CAN MAKE. SPLIT
SECOND DECISIONS- OR A QUICK
DECISION SO- WOULDN'T. THOSE
PEOPLE BE ON THE GROUND- IN THE
CASE OF A DRONE WITH THOSE
PEOPLE BE ONTHE GROUND AND JUST
RELAYING. COMMANDS. TO THE
UNMANNED AIRCRAFT. IF YOU'RE- IF
YOU HAVE RIGHT YOU YOU KNOW WHAT
I DIDN'T KNOW THIS EITHER YOU
KNOW WAIT STARTED THE PROGRAM-
IN TWO THOUSAND SIXTEEN WE
PARTNERED WITH- GENERAL ATOMICS
VERY LARGE DEPARTMENT OF
DEFENSE. COMPANY WE HAD THIS
IDEA. IN THE MILITARY IS ABLE
ANY WAR THEATER COMBAT YOU'LL
GET THE TYPE OF INFORMATION TO
MAKE SENSE YOU KNOW FOR US TO
HAVE REAL TIME INFORMATION WHAT
THEY SHARED WAS. AND WASN'T WELL
KNOWN IS THAT. THERE ARE LIKELY
MORE MANNED PLATFORMS IN WAR
THEATER THAN UNMANNED. THE VALUE
OF THE MANNED PLATFORMS JUST
THAT YOU'RE ABLE TO ADJUST
QUICKLY BASED ON ONBOARD HUMAN
INPUT. THEY CAN'T BE DONE YOU
KNOW BY SOMEBODY FLYING A- HE
DROWNED A LARGE OR SOMETHING ON
THE GROUND BOTH HAVE. YOU NEED
CAPABILITY. BUT THERE USED TO SO
IT'S NOT SAY WITHOUT- THE
NATIONAL GUARD PRESIDENT OF THE
DROUGHT IS NOT NEEDED NO
ABSOLUTELY YES AS ARE ALL OF
THESE OTHER. OUR RESOURCES ARE.
BUT HAVING SOMEBODY THAT IS
TRAINING EXPERIENCE IN GROUND
OPERATIONS- TO VALIDATE YOUR THE
MODELS THAT ARE BEING PRODUCED
FROM THE AIRPLANE. PROVIDED VIA
SATELLITE- INPUT IN INSTANTLY
MADE AVAILABLE TO THOSE ON THE
GROUND COMMAND CENTERS. POLICY
MAKERS- IS UNPARALLELED BUDGET
YOU HIT THE NAIL ON THE HEAD A
TERRIBLE- THANK YOU- I HAVE A
ARE THERE ANY OTHER FOLLOW UP
QUESTIONS FOR CHIEF FENNESSY.
MISTER BENNETT. I'D I'VE I'VE
LISTENED TO CAREFULLY TO YOUR
ANSWER- CHIEF FANCY I KEEP
FORGETTING THAT THE CAMERAS OVER
HERE- AND- COULD YOU COULD YOU
PLEASE EXPLAIN AGAIN THE
DIFFERENCE BETWEEN HAVING
SOMEBODY ON THE PLANE VERSUS
HAVING SAY SOMEBODY A- COMMAND
CENTER RECEIVING ALL THAT DATA
FROM THE PLANE AND HAVING
COMPLETE CONTROL OVER. ALL OF
THE FUNCTIONS OF THE PLANE. WE
BOTH OBVIOUSLY HAVE MAN AND MAY
I HAVE THEIR UNIQUE VALUES.
VALUE TO MANNED AIRCRAFT IT IS
SIMPLY THE US YOU KNOW FONG
FLYING THE AIRCRAFT AND WERE
OVER AN AREA THAT WE'RE MAPPING
WE'RE DOING WHATEVER THAT THAT
THAT TASK MAY BE. I SEE SMOKE
OUT THE DISTANCE I SEE SOMETHING
ELSE IT'S A LET LET'S GO CHECK
THAT OUT. YOU DON'T HAVE THAT
ABILITY WHEN YOU'RE TALKING
ABOUT FLYING UNMANNED AIRCRAFT
YOU KNOW THE SCREEN THAT THE
INDIVIDUAL AND AS- A MANAGING-
FLYING THAT AIRCRAFT IS LIMITED.
SO THERE ARE ADVANTAGES TO THAT-
YOU KNOW THESE LARGER AIRCRAFT
LARGELY FLY AND CERTAIN YOU KNOW
DIFFERENT PATTERNS. THESE ARE
CRAFTING GUILD OR OF YOU KNOW
MANOR CRICKET LOWER AMERICAN
MANNED AIRCRAFT THESE ARE ALL
PRESSURIZED AIRCRAFT CAN GO
HIGHER- THEY CAN COMMUNICATE
DIRECTLY WITH THE OTHER
AIRCRAFT. IF NEEDED THE-
DECISION MAKERS ON THE GROUND.
WE HAVE THE ABILITY TO DANCE
OFTEN ARE COMMUNICATING VIA
TEXT- THE- TO OUR FOLKS AT THE
STATE OPERATIONS CENTER- PEOPLE
ON THE GROUND IT'S JUST A YOU
HAVE A LOT MORE VERSATILITY. IN
CAPABILITIES WHEN YOU DO FROM-
NECESSARILY. AN UNMANNED
AIRCRAFT THANK YOU. HELLO THANKS
I'M SORRY A QUESTION I THINK
WOULD BE FOR TYLER- THE-
HELICOPTER REPLACEMENT PROGRAM
AND THE- EMERGENCY SURGE
CAPACITY THAT'S- OF BEING SOUGHT
. I AND I HAVE TO SAY I'M A
GRATEFUL TO SEE THIS PROGRAM
MOVING ALONG IT WAS- NOT LONG
AFTER I ARRIVED AND BEGAN
CHAIRING. THE SUBCOMMITTEE THAT
WE IDENTIFIED THE- BADLY NEEDED
THE REPLACEMENT PROGRAM THAT'S
NOW WELL UNDER WAY- BUT I'M NOT
UNDERSTANDING THE DIFFERENCE
BETWEEN- INCREASING OUR FLEET BY
TWO HELICOPTERS- AND THE NOTION
OF DOING THAT BUT LIMITING IT TO
EMERGENCY SURGE CAPACITY I JUST
DON'T GET THE DIFFERENCE I CAN
UNDERSTAND I AM UNDER THE
ASSUMPTION THAT. OF THESE
HELICOPTERS ARE GOING TO HAVE TO
IF WE'RE GOING TO USE THEM AT
ALL THEY HAVE TO HAVE CREWS
AVAILABLE AND IF WE'RE HIRING
CRUISE WHY WOULD THEY NOT BE
AVAILABLE IN THE SAME FASHION AS
EVERY OTHER GROUP FOR ALL THE
OTHER HELICOPTERS I THINK
ULTIMATELY- AND PERHAPS YOU CAN-
HELP ME UNDERSTAND THIS ISSUE
THE- DEMAND FOR SERVICE. IS
GOING TO BE WHAT DETERMINES THE
USE OF THESE HELICOPTERS AND I
COMPLETELY UNDERSTAND THAT- THE
NOTION OF SEARCH CAPACITY- OR OF
OR OF USING THEM IN A SEARCH-
SITUATION BUT- IF WE NEED THE
HELICOPTERS- BUT WHY WOULD WE-
WHY WOULD WE LIMIT THEM TO THAT
ROLE WE DON'T LIMIT WE DO
SEARCH. NOW WHY WOULD WE WANT TO
LIMIT FUTURE HELICOPTERS TO- TO
ONLY THAT MISSION. SIR THANK YOU
CHAIRMAN FOR THE QUESTION- SO AS
YOU'RE GONE FOR THE- HISTORICAL
PERSPECTIVE- THE LEGISLATURE IN
THE ADMINISTRATION APPROVED-
CALIFORNIA FORWARD TO PURCHASE-
TWELVE- BLACK HAWK HELICOPTERS.
TEN ARE IN THE FRONT LINE-
STATUS CRISTINA HELLO HELLO TECH
BASES ACROSS THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA AND TWO OF THOSE
HELICOPTERS ARE- IN THE PURPOSES
OF RESERVES- TO BE ABLE TO.
BRING THE FRONTLINE HELICOPTERS
IN OUT OF MAINTENANCE- WHILE
KEEPING THOSE TWO RESERVES
AVAILABLE- TO- TO SUPPLEMENT
THOSE AIRCRAFT. AS WE MOVE
FORWARD IN THAT PROPOSAL- PART
OF THAT PROPOSAL WAS FLYING FIVE
OF THE TEN BASES TWENTY FOUR
HOURS A DAY- IN THE REASON WE
DID SO WAS BECAUSE- FIVE OF
THOSE HELICOPTERS WOULD HAVE
TANKS AND FIVE OF THOSE
HELICOPTERS WOULD HAVE BUCKETS.
WE CAN'T FIND A FIVE BUCKET
HELICOPTERS AT NIGHT WITH AN
EXTERNAL LOAD- OVER SOME OF
THOSE AREAS. AS WE CONTINUE
THROUGH THE CONTRACT WE ENDED UP
TAKING ALL TEN OF THOSE
HELICOPTERS BUT WE STILL ONLY
FUNDED- FIVE OF THOSE BASES TO
FLY TWENTY FOUR HOURS A DAY. AND
THIS IS WHERE YOU SEE SEARCH
CAPACITY BLENDS INTO THE FOUR
HUNDRED MILLION DOLLARS-
ENHANCEMENT- THAT IS GOING TO BE
WORKED THROUGH WITH- WITH THE
DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE THE
DEPARTMENT- KELLY JAR AND- THE
LABOR ORGANIZATIONS TO FIGURE
OUT HOW THAT FOUR HUNDRED
MILLION DOLLARS. GOING TO BE
USED. SO IN PART OF THAT THE- IS
THAT- IS THAT WE WOULD BE ABLE
TO USE FUNDING TO TURN THE FIVE
- CURRENTLY DATABASE ONLY INTO
FLYING ALL TEN OF THE
HELICOPTERS TWENTY FOUR HOURS A
DAY WHICH REQUIRE INCREASED
STAFFING. WELL WHEN YOU ADD THE
TEN HELICOPTERS INTENDED TO FLY
TWENTY FOUR HOURS A DAY THAT'S
GOING TO INCREASE YOUR- YOUR
FLIGHT HOURS IT'S GOING TO
INCREASE YOUR MAINTENANCE NEEDS-
AND THEREBY IS THE REQUEST IN
THE ADVERSITY SURGE CAPACITY
PROPOSAL FOR FOUR ADDITIONAL
HELICOPTERS. THAT COULD BENEFIT
SUPPLEMENT THOSE INCREASED OURS
IN THE FIRST TEN HELICOPTERS- TO
ENSURE THAT WE HAVE FIREHAWK
HELICOPTERS FLYING TWENTY FOUR
SEVEN THREE SIXTY FIVE ACROSS
THE STATE OF CALIFORNIA- BUT IN
ADDITION TO THAT- THOSE
HELICOPTERS THAT WOULD INITIALLY
BE BASED OUT OF MCCLELLAN HERE
IN SACRAMENTO- COULD BE MOVED
ACROSS THE STATE AND STAFF WITH
ADDITIONAL- PERSONNEL THAT WE
HAVE. THROUGH STAFFING PATTERNS
ENOUGH WAYS TO ENSURE THAT WERE
FLYING THEM WHEN WE HAVE
CRITICAL FIRE WEATHER CONDITIONS
I HOPE THAT ANSWERS YOUR
QUESTION. ON IT IT HELPS BUT I
HAVE TO BE FRANK WITH YOU THIS
IS THE FIRST TIME I'VE EVER
HEARD. THAT SOME OF THE
HELICOPTERS THAT WERE- COMING
ONLINE- WERE NOT EQUIPPED WITH
TWENTY FOUR HOUR- CUT CAPACITY-
EVERY TIME I'VE EVER REFERRED TO
THESE HELICOPTERS AND COMMITTEE-
IT'S ALWAYS BEEN WITH A SENSE
OF. PRIDE IN THE EXPECTATION
THAT WE WERE GOING FROM- FLEET
OF HELICOPTERS THAT WERE ONLY
AVAILABLE PART TIME TO-
HELICOPTERS THAT WERE AVAILABLE-
THROUGHOUT THE DAY SO I HAVE TO
SAY IT COMES AS A BIT OF A
SURPRISE TO ME THAT- THAT. THAT
THAT HAD BEEN THE CASE AND-
BABY- I NEED TO HAVE A FOLLOW UP
MEETING TO UNDERSTAND JUST THAT
YOU KNOW WHERE WE ARE IN THE-
STATUS OF THE PROGRAM- I. FULLY
SUPPORT- INCREASING THIS
CAPACITY- TO THE EXTENT WE CAN
WITH AND- OF THE REASONABLE
LIMITS OF THE BUDGET- BECAUSE
THESE- A CRAFTER ARE ARE SO
IMPORTANT. HI SO I DEFINITELY
WANT TO SEE THAT HAPPEN BUT I
WANT TO SEE THEM USED TO THEIR
MAXIMUM EFFICIENCY AS WELL
SOUNDS LIKE THAT'S WHERE WE'RE
HEADED- BUT MAYBE NOT WHERE WE
WERE AT IT. THAT'S THAT'S THE
SURPRISE- WELL IT WELL I HAVE
YOU CHIEF- LET ME ASK A
QUESTION- THAT IS- HOPEFULLY
FORWARD THINKING- AND SOMETHING
THAT I'VE I'VE ALWAYS KIND OF
WONDERED AND THAT IS- AS AS WE
MOVE FORWARD IN TIME AND AS WE
SEE THE NEED FOR. ADVANCED THE
TECHNOLOGY AND AN AIRCRAFT AND
SO FORTH IT. HI CAN YOU
CORRECTLY- BUT I AM I AM OF THE
BELIEF THAT THEIR- HERE IN
CALIFORNIA- TEXAS WHERE THERE'S
ALSO A LOT OF- AIRCRAFT- THAT
ARE USED- AROUND THE COUNTRY
OTHER PARTS OF THE OF THE WORLD
THERE'S A- ONGOING AND
INCREASING NEED FOR- A
FIREFIGHTING AIRCRAFT TO FULFILL
VERY VERY. SPECIFIC MISSION YES
IT'S MY UDERSTANDING THAT
THERE'S NOT A SINGLE AIRCRAFT
THAT IS DESIGNED FROM THE BOTTOM
UP. TO FIGHT FIRES IN SPITE OF
THIS GREAT NEED- WHEREAS AT
LEAST IN A MILITARY CONTEXT-
THERE ARE- AIRCRAFT THAT ARE
FREQUENTLY BUILT FROM THE GROUND
UP TO ADDRESS SPECIFIC MILITARY
MISSION SO- WOULD YOU AGREE WITH
ME THAT SOMETHING'S GONNA AND I
REALIZE WE'RE TALKING ABOUT THE
DEVELOPMENT OF AIRCRAFT WE'RE
TALKING ABOUT. TEN TWENTY THIRTY
YEAR- TIMELINES FOR DELIVERY OF
ACTUALLY ACTUAL PRODUCT BUT- I
THINK WE CAN PROJECT OUT THAT
FAR IN TERMS OF- OF- THE CLIMATE
CRISIS AND THE NEED FOR FIGHTING
FIRES- AND PERHAPS WE OUGHT TO
BE- LOOKING AT THE DIFFERENT
WAY. RATHER THAN. KINKA
EQUIPMENT THAT'S AVAILABLE OFF
THE SHELF AND ADAPTING THEM BUT
LONG TERM MAYBE- LOOKING AT
STARTING TO DESIGN EQUIPMENT
FROM THE GROUND UP BUT WE SEE SO
MUCH OTHER TECHNOLOGY THAT
ACTUALLY DOES- A ADDRESS TO FIRE
ISSUE IN THAT WAY. ABSOLUTELY
AND THANK YOU FOR THAT QUESTION
AS WELL SO- SO YOU'RE ABSOLUTELY
CORRECT WHEN WE LOOK AT ROTARY
WING- OR HELICOPTERS
SPECIFICALLY- I CAN'T THANK YOU
ALL ENOUGH FOR INVESTING IN THE
S. SEVENTY I. HELICOPTER PROGRAM
IS THE FIRST TIME THAT
CALIFORNIA'S HAD A BRAND NEW
HELICOPTER. BROUGHT INTO THE
FLEET- AND WE SEE THAT A FEW
AREAS ACROSS THE STATE AS WELL
OUTSIDE OF CALIFORNIA- SO MUCH
APPRECIATE THERE WHEN WE'RE
STARTING TO LOOK AT A FIXED
WING. AIR TANKERS- YOU KNOW
HISTORICALLY WHEN YOU LOOK AT
THOSE BETWEEN WHAT IS STATE
OWNED AND WHAT IS PRIVATELY
OWNED. ACROSS THE STATE ACROSS
THE NATION YOU ARE CORRECT THERE
ARE LARGELY IN PART AT REVISED
AIRCRAFT FROM DIFFERENT AREAS OF
TIME. THAT A RETROFITTING AND-
BY PRIVATE VENDORS- TO MEET THE
NEEDS OF OTHER WILDLAND
FIREFIGHTING MISSION ACROSS THE
STATE ACROSS THE NATION- WHETHER
THAT BE- ARE CURRENTLY THE BEST
U. T. GRAHAM AND- AIR TANKERS
THAT WERE REALLY WORLD WAR TWO
SUBMARINE HUNTERS. THE
REPLACEMENT OF THE U. H. ONE H.
HELICOPTERS THAT WERE USED IN
VIETNAM- WORDS SAYING RETROFITS
OF- JETLINERS. AND OUR TANKS ARE
BEING ADDED AND THEY'RE ALL VERY
QUALITY AIRCRAFT THERE RE
UTILIZED AND I REMEMBER AS CHAIR
BLOOM WHENWE TALKED ABOUT THE
C. ONE THIRTY PROGRAM- SOME
NUMBER OF YEARS AGO. THAT THIS
WAS ONE OF THE QUESTIONS YOU
ASKED WAS WHAT DOES IT TAKE TO
BUILD AN AIR TANKER FROM THE
GROUND UP SO WE HAD DONE THAT
RESEARCH INITIALLY. AND A
LOCKHEED MARTIN AT THE TIME WAS-
OFFERING A BRAND NEW- C. ONE
THIRTY J. MODEL- AIRCRAFT- WITH
A BASE PRICE OF ABOUT EIGHTY
EIGHT POINT FIVE. MILLION
DOLLARS TO GET OFF THE GROUND
AND I THINK THAT AS WE CONTINUE
TO MOVE FORWARD WE CONTINUE TO
LOOK AT. WHAT THE NEEDS OF OUR
GREAT STATE- WE NEED TO START
LOOKING AT OPTIONS OF WHETHER
CONTINUING. TO RE UTILIZE
AIRCRAFT WERE TO YOU- PURCHASE
NEW AS YOU SEE BACK. WELL I
THANK YOU FOR THAT RESPONSE I
THINK- I'D LIKE TO AGAIN HAVE
THAT CONVERSATION AGAIN WITH
YOU- IF. GETTING THAT- OF IT
GETTING FORWARD MOVEMENT ON
THAT- A TYPE OF A PROJECT-
REQUIRE SOME- HELP THE FROM THE
SENATE BUDGET SUB COMMITTEE AND
BE HAPPY TO PROVIDE IT AND AGAIN
I DON'T KNOW WHAT THE- THE
SPECIFIC ANSWERS HERE AND WHAT
THAT AIRCRAFT WOULD LOOK LIKE
BUT MAYBE WE NEED TO- PARTNER
WITH THE FEDERAL GOVERNMENT DEBT
BECAUSE THESE THIS WOULD BE A- I
DO KNOW THE DESIGNING AIRCRAFT-
IS A VERY VERY- EXPENSIVE AND
LABOR INTENSIVE. PROPOSITION SO
IF SOMETHING IS TO TALK ABOUT-
THE LAST QUESTION I HAVE A- IS A
ASKING FOR A FOLLOW UP TO- THE
L. A. O.'S COMMENT ABOUT THE-
VEHICLE LOCATOR PROGRAM IN THE
EXPANSION FROM TWELVE HUNDRED TO
THIRTY SIX HUNDRED VEHICLES- I
GUESS THE FUNDAMENTAL QUESTION
IS. WHY DOES EVERY VEHICLE IN
THE FLEET NEED TO HAVE THAT
TECHNOLOGY ADDED- WHEN ONLY A- I
. IT'S NOT A SMALL FRACTION BUT
ONLY A FRACTION OF THE- VEHICLES
WOULD BE EXPECTED TO ACTUALLY.
BE OUT IN THE FIELD THE IN THOSE
SITUATIONS WHERE YOU NEED THAT.
CAPABILITY I THANK YOU FOR THAT
QUESTION AS WELL- CHERRY BLOOM-
SO AS YOU KNOW ACCOUNT BY REALLY
IS A TOTAL FORCE CONCEPT AND
WHEN WE WERE- GRATEFUL TO HAVE-THIS APPROVED IN THE FISCAL YEAR
SIXTEEN SEVENTEEN A BUDGET
CYCLE- B. INITIAL PHASE WAS IN
FACT THE TWELVE HUNDRED UNITS
APART ACROSS TWELVE HUNDRED
VEHICLES WHICH WERE THE FRONT
LINE VEHICLES ACROSS STATE
CALIFORNIA- FOR CALIFORNIA-
SPECIFICALLY THEY HAVE AUTOMATIC
VEHICLE LOCATION AS WELL AS A
MOBILE DATA TERMINAL. LOCATED
WITHIN THE VEHICLE- THAT ALLOWS
US TO SEND INFORMATION TO THE
OCCUPANTS OF THE THOSE VEHICLES
WITH CRITICAL INFORMATION FOR
THEIR- FOR THEIR INCIDENT NOW WE
KNOW THAT- WE HAVE APPROXIMATELY
THIRTY SEVEN HUNDRED VEHICLES IN
THE FLEET. THIS TWENTY FOUR
HUNDRED- WOULD ADD A TOTAL OF
THIRTY SIX THERE ARE CERTAINLY
VEHICLES WITHIN THE FLEET THAT
WOULD NOT HAVE- ABL AND NDTV'S
PLACED ON THEM OF COURSE THOSE
ARE LARGELY CONSTRUCTION
EQUIPMENT TRAILERS AND THINGS OF
THE SORT THAT WE WOULDN'T
REASONABLY EXPECT THOSE TO BE.
PLACED ON THOSE VEHICLES BUT
IT'S EQUALLY IMPORTANT- OF THE
DIFFERENCE OF THAT OF KNOWING
THAT- THAT WE WOULD HAVE THE
UNITS THAT ARE READY TO BE
INSTALLED IN A BRAND NEW VEHICLE
IT'S GOING OUT TO THE FIELD IS
AN OLD VEHICLE COMES IN FOR
SURVEY- TO BE ABLE TO HAVE IT.
REMOVED EQUALLY IMPORTANT IS-
THAT VEHICLES HAVE TO GO IN FOR
MAINTENANCE- VEHICLES ARE PLACED
OUT OF SERVICE AND WHEN WE DO
THAT- WE PLACE RESERVE APPARATUS
OR SURGEON HORRENDOUS AS WE
TALKED ABOUT THE PREVIOUS
PROPOSAL- IN THE SERVICE AND IT
ISN'T AS SIMPLE AS POLLING- THE-
THE A. B. L. N. M. B. T. UNITS.
OUT OF ONE VEHICLE AND PLACING
IT INTO ANOTHER THEIR PARMALEE
HARD MOUNTED- UNITS WITHIN EACH
OF THOSE VEHICLES. NOW WHEN WE
LOOK AT ALL THE VEHICLES ACROSS
THE STATE OF CALIFORNIA AGAIN
GOING BACK TO TOTAL FORCE I'LL
GIVE YOU AN EXAMPLE- DURING THE
CALAR FIRES THE FIRE BURNED OVER
THE TOP. OF ECHO SUMMIT IN THE
LAKE TAHOE REASONABLY ONE WOULD
THINK THAT ME MYSELF AND MY
VEHICLE WOULDN'T NEED- A MOBILE
DATA TERMINAL OR- AVIELLE. YET
IN FACT I WAS SITTING ON THE
ECHO SUMMIT AS THE FIRE BLEW
OVER THE TOP AND WENT DOWN INTO
CHRISTMAS VALLEY AND THE LAKE
TAHOE BASIN- LIKEWISE- ONE MIGHT
QUESTION WHY- VEHICLES SUCH AS
THE OFFICE OF STATE FIRE MARSHAL
MIGHT NEED- BOTTOM OUT OF
VEHICLE LOCATION AND HE'D M. D.
T. ON A SCAN TO. OTHER VEHICLES
THAT WE USE- THOSE FOLKS ON THE
CRITICAL FUNCTION OF DAMAGE
ASSESSMENT WHEN WE PUT THEM OUT
ON THE FIRE LINE TO ASSESS- BURN. DAMAGE AND DESTROYED
STRUCTURES- WHY. A RESOURCE
MANAGEMENT- WILL. GO OUT AN
ANSWER AND PER MULTIPLE
FUNCTIONS IN INCIDENT COMMAND
SYSTEM. ARENAS AS WELL AS-
WATERSHED ASSESSMENT AND- POST-
POST FIRE- VIOLENT SUPPRESSION
REPAIR. AND IT'S IMPORTANT FOR
US AS LEADERS IN THE
ORGANIZATION AS INCIDENT
COMMANDERS ON THE GROUND. TO
ENSURE THAT WE KNOW. THE
LOCATION OF. ALL OF THESE
RESOURCES ON THE INCIDENT FOR
ACCOUNTABILITY BEING ABLE TO PRE
POSITION THEM OR MOVE THEM INTO
OTHER AREAS WHERE FIRE MAY BE
GOING. BY WATCHING THEM ON ON A
MAP. ACTIVE ACTIVELY THERE. AS
WELL AS WHEN YOU'RE LOOKING AT
THE INITIAL ATTACK ACTIVITY
AGAIN BEING IN A RESERVE
APPARATUS- YOU MIGHT FIND. THAT
THAT RESERVE APPARATUS IS MOVING
WITHIN THEIR FIRE DISTRICT MAY
BE CLOSER TO ANOTHER FIRE
DISTRICT AND THEREFORE DYNAMIC
DISPATCHING WILL ALWAYS DISPATCH
THE CLOSEST RESOURCE REGARDLESS
OF WHETHER IT'S A FRONT LINE
RESOURCES BEING STAFF WERE
RESERVE APPARATUS. I HOPE THAT
HELPS. IT DOES THANK YOU- I'M
SURE- ON A STAFF LEVEL THEY'LL
PROBABLY BE MARK- QUESTIONS-
ABOUT THAT IT WOULD BE
INTERESTING ENOUGH THERE'S- DATA
AVAILABLE WITH THE- WITH RESPECT
TO THE USAGE OF VEHICLES AS YOU
AS YOU REFER TO- THAT MIGHT BE
DIFFICULT TO COMBAT THAT WOULD
BE INTERESTING TO SAY- ARE THERE
ANY OTHER QUESTIONS. MISTER
BENNETT. THANK YOU VERY MUCH
JOURNALISM- NUMBER ONE JUST IN
THE QUICKEST I WASN'T PLANNING
ON THIS BUT WHEN YOU MADE THE
COMMENT ABOUT- PLANNING- FIRE
CRAFT FROM THE BOTTOM OF THE
AIRCRAFT FROM THE BOTTOM OF THE
FIGHT FIRES WILDLAND FIRES IN
PARTICULAR- IT'S A GREAT
QUESTION AND I THINK- GIVEN- THE
DIRECTION OF- WHAT'S HAPPENING
WITH THE FIRES IN CALIFORNIA DID
DOES MAKE SOME SENSE FOR US TO
PAY SOME ATTENTION THAT I WOULD
LIKE TO PASS ON AN EXPERIENCE I
HAD WHEN I WAS IN ITALY- ONE A-
FIRE BROKE OUT. I WATCHED TANKER
AFTER TANKER. AND THERE MUST
HAVE BEEN T AT LEAST A DOZEN OF
THEM AND THEY WERE FLYING IN A-
HUGE PATTERN- ONE WOULD COME
DOWN AND LITERALLY FILL IN THE
OCEAN. THE TANKER ITSELF CAME.
HIT THE OCEAN. AND THE
ACCELERATED AS HARD AS I COULD
AND THEY WERE PICKING UP WATER.
NOW I DON'T KNOW WHETHER THAT
WAS AN AIRCRAFT THAT WAS ADAPTED
FOR BUT IF IT WAS ADAPTED IT
WAS. PRETTY MAJOR ADAPTION SO
THERE IS SOMETHING THAT THEY
WERE DOING IN ITALY TEN YEARS
AGO- AND THEY WERE ABLE TO
RAPIDLY ONE LANDED THEN THE NEXT
ONE WOULD COME AND THEY WERE
JUST MAKING A CIRCLE RIGHT OVER
THE FIRES GIVEN THAT OUR
PROXIMITY TO THE COAST. AND HOW
MANY OF OUR FIRES OF THAT WAYS
OF THAT MAYBE SOME AIRCRAFT THAT
WE- THAT THAT MAY HAVE BEEN
DESIGNED FOR THE BOTTOM- BUT I
DON'T KNOW OF OR WAS AT THE
ADOPTED IT LOOKED TO ME LIKE
ALMOST LIKE. C. ONE THIRTY THERE
WERE ADOPTED WITH THEIR- WITH
THAT WITH THE SCOOP IN FRONT
RATHER THAN THAT AND BACK- SO I
JUST OFFER THAT BUT- YOU KNOW.
THE HEARING ABOUT THE- AND I
DON'T KNOW IF PRONOUNCING THIS
BUT THE FOR. SYSTEM THE IN THIS
- RESPONSE SYSTEM THAT'S OUT
THERE- HI HI I AM- AT- HE- DID
NOT AN EXPERT IN THIS WHOLE
FIELD OF. WILDFIRE PREVENTION
EXCITER BUT IT JUST SEEMS TO ME
FROM A COMMON SENSE STANDPOINT.
THAT IF WE COULD ATTACK THESE
THINGS RIGHT WHEN THEY START.
AND REALLY BRING A LOT OF
RESOURCES. OF WE COULD SAVE A
LOT OF. PROPERTY A LOT OF RISK
EXPENSE AND TREMENDOUS ENERGY-
AND CHILL OVERALL I'M VERY
INTERESTED IN- THE INITIAL
RESPONSE- BEING OF BECOMING MORE
ROBUST BEING ABLE TO DEVELOP AT
ACROSS THE STATE- AND SO
GENERALLY- VERY SUPPORTIVE OF
THIS. BUT IT DOES I THINK- LEAD
ME TO THIS QUESTION ABOUT THE
STRATEGIC PLAN THAT STAFF WAS
REFERRING TO AND THAT IS- AS AS
A STATEWIDE STRATEGIC WILDFIRE
PLAN. WHAT PERCENTAGE OF
RESOURCES WHAT. WHAT PART OF THE
PLAN HOW HOW IMPORTANT IS THIS
ADDITIONAL- RESPONSE RAPID
RESPONSE IN IN AN OVERALL
STRATEGIC PLAN AND HOW ROBUST
SHOULD IT BE- HOW MUCH GAIN
WOULD WE GET THERE ON ONE HAND
VERSUS THE OTHER. AND SO MY
QUESTION FOR CAL FIRE IS CAL
FIRE OPPOSED TO CREATING A
STATEWIDE STRATEGIC WILDFIRE
PLANNED- IN THE END IF NOT WHAT
ARE THE HURDLES- FOR ACTUALLY
GETTING THAT DONE. AND IF THEY
ARE WHAT ONE OF THE REASONS WHY
THEY WOULD BE OPPOSED TO IT. NO
WELL THANK YOU SIR I APPRECIATE
THAT AND I'M GONNA DRESSES AND
INTO PIECES FIRST AND FOREMOST-
THE STREET THE STREET SHE
TRISTIQUE FIRE PLAN FOR THE
STATE OF CALIFORNIA. WAS LAST
PUBLISHED IN TWO THOUSAND
EIGHTEEN BY THE BOARD OF
FORESTRY OWNER FRANK TODAY ABOUT
THE STRATEGIC FIRE PLAN REACH
WERE REFERRING TO. WHAT WAS
ASKED OF THE LEGISLATURE TO BE
PROVIDED TO THEM RELATED TO
RESOURCE ALLOCATION AND- AND THE
STRATEGIC THINKING OR STANDARD
TO COVER OF WHAT WE WOULD HEAR.
FROM A LOT OF OUR PARTNERS ON
HOW TO ALLOCATE RESOURCES TO GET
THEM THERE THE QUICKEST. FOR
AIRCRAFT IN THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA WE ALREADY HAVE THAT
IN PLACE FOR AIRCRAFT
SPECIFICALLY IT'S OUR GOAL TO
HAVE AN INITIAL SACK AIRCRAFT
OVER ANY FIRE IN THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA. WITHIN TWENTY
MINUTES AND REASONABLY I THINK
BETWEEN LOCAL STATE AND FEDERAL
PARTNERS WE DO AN EXCELLENT JOB
WITH THAT WE CAN ALWAYS CONTINUE
TO IMPROVE- AND SO FROM A- AIR
TANKER. HELICOPTER PERSPECTIVE I
THINK WE'RE GOOD THERE. SO WHAT
THE- PROGRAM REALLY FOCUSES ON
IS- AND WHAT THE REPORT COULD
FOCUS ON LARGELY IS- THE
ALLOCATION OF ENGINES CREWS- AND. BULLDOZERS- YEAH AND FROM THAT
ACCOUNT ARE CERTAINLY IS NOT
OPPOSED IT- WE UNDERSTAND THAT
THE REPORT WAS DUE BY APRIL
FIRST TWO THOUSAND TWENTY. BUT
AS WE ALL KNOW AND WITH WITH ALL
RESPECT- WE WERE DRAFTING THAT
REPORT- BUT WE WERE NOT ABLE TO
COMPLETE IT TO THE LEVEL IN
WHICH WE FELT IT WAS A READY TO
BE PRESENTED TO THE LEGISLATURE
IN THE ADMINISTRATION. LARGELY
BECAUSE WE DIVERTED OUR
ATTENTION IN FEBRUARY OF TWO
THOUSAND TWENTY- COMMITTING
LARGE AMOUNTS OF RESOURCES A
PART OF THE- LARGER STATE
CALIFORNIA PLAN TO THE COVE IN
PANDEMIC. IN ADDITION TO THAT-
TWO THOUSAND TWENTY AND TWENTY
ONE WHERE LARGE COMET JING AND
DISASTERS FIRE YEARS AND WE KNOW
THE CAL FIRE'S CRITICALLY. SHORT
WITH IT STOPPING RIGHT NOW I AM
COMMITTED WITH MY PARTNERS- TO
REESTABLISH AND- AND BRING FOR
THIS PLAN FOR YOU. I INTO THE
FUTURE. THANK YOU- MY- OTHER
QUESTION IS- WITH REGARDING THE-
IMPLEMENTATION OF THE TECHNOLOGY
AND TO THE- THIRTY SIX HUNDRED
VEHICLES- I TRIED TO DO SOME OF
THE ANALYSIS OF THE COST- AND-
HE- CAN YOU EITHER. YEAH I DO
YOU HAVE AN IDENTIFIED COST PER
VEHICLE- OR CAN YOU GET THAT TO
ME- RELATIVELY QUICKLY IN TERMS
OF WHAT THE COST WOULD FOR BE A-
FIFTY PER VEHICLE WOULD BE- OF-
THIS THIS REQUEST. YES SIR- I
HAVE MY DEPUTY CHIEF OVER THIS
PROGRAM TIMOTHY PERSON ON THE
LINE- IF HE KNOWS THE NUMBER
RIGHT NOW OFFICE SAID LET'S GIVE
IT IF NOT WE WILL CERTAINLY GET
THAT INFORMATION BACK TO YOU.
CHIEF I WILL HAVE TO GET BACK TO
YOU WAS SOLD. ALL RIGHT WE WILL
OF PRESENT BACK YOU IN SHORT
ORDER WITH THAT NUMBER IS. THANK
YOU VERY MUCH. YEAH WE CAN WE
CAN ALL GET THAT INFORMATION I
THINK- OUR STAFF MAY ACTUALLY
HAVE ASKED THAT QUESTION HAVE
SOME INFORMATION ON IT- SO WE
CAN- ASK IN THAT WAY ALSO- BUT
IT IS A- AS I UNDERSTAND IT
IT'S- OF OVER TEN THOUSAND
DOLLARS SO- PER VEHICLE AND THEN
THERE'S AN ONGOING COSTS
THROUGH- TO MAINTAIN- DOES NOT
INCONSEQUENTIAL. WAS GREAT MIKE
MY BACK OF THE ENVELOPE WAS TEN
THOUSAND DOLLARS SO LIKE I'VE I
WANT TO MAKE SURE WAS. WAS
ROUGHLY ON THAT I DON'T KNOW.
HOW YOU FIGURE. OUT OF THE BACK
OF AN ENVELOPE BUT- SOUNDS LIKE
YOU'RE IN THE RIGHT BALLPARK.
WE'RE GOING TO MOVE ON TO A
PUBLIC COMMENT NOW THANK YOU-
TO- ALL OF- OF THIS MORNING'S
PARTICIPANTS- FOR YOUR-
PRESENTATIONS AND- LET ME REMIND
YOU THAT THE PHONE NUMBER FOR
CALLING IS EIGHT SEVEN SEVEN SIX
NINE TWO. 1-757-877-6928 NINE
FIVE SEVEN WITH THE PUBLIC
ACCESS CODE OF ONE THREE ONE
FIVE ONE TWO SEVEN. ONE THREE
ONE FIVE ONE TWO SEVEN AND IF
YOU ENCOUNTER PROBLEMS CALL.
916-319-2099 THE STAFF MEMBER
WILL ASSIST YOU- IS THERE ANYONE
IN THE. WHO ARE GETTING THE
MICROPHONE READY AS WE SPEAK. I
THINK WE HAVE- AT LEVY- I JUST
SAY THAT- WILL BE- IMPOSING A
SPEAKING LIMIT OF- ONE MINUTE.
PLEASE ADD TO. WE'RE ALMOST
READY. GREAT TO HAVE- TO PEOPLE-
HI HERE IN THE HEARING ROOM- WHO
WILL PROVIDE THAT TESTIMONY AND
THEN WILL BE MOVING TO-
TESTIMONY OVER THE PHONE WELCOME
A GOOD MORNING CHAIRMAN MEMBERS
OF THE COMMITTEE PAUL MASON WITH
PACIFIC FOREST TRUST IT'S REALLY
DELIGHTFUL TO SEE THIS MORNING
THANKS FOR GOOD HEARING MY
COMMENTS ARE FOCUSED ON THE
WILDFIRE- INVESTMENT PACKAGE AND
THE TASK FORCE. FOR THE ONE IS
COULD YOU KNOW COMMAND THE
LEGISLATURE ADMINISTRATION FOR
THE REALLY SUBSTANTIAL
INVESTMENTS OVER THE LAST YEAR
IN THAT CONTEXT I'LL JUST SAY WE
NEED TO MAINTAIN AMBITION AND
WHILE ONE POINT TWO BILLION OVER
TWO YEARS SOUNDS LIKE A BIG
NUMBER IT'S ACTUALLY REALLY
SUBSTANTIAL WITHDRAWAL FROM THE
LEVEL OF COMMITMENT WE HAD FOR
THE LAST COUPLE OF YEARS. SO IF
I NEED TO MORE IN THAT BILLION
DOLLAR A YEAR AN ONGOING. BASIS
THE SECOND OLDEST ECHO WHAT A
NUMBER OF PEOPLE ON THE
COMMITTEE I MENTIONED THAT WE
NEED TO MAKE SURE THAT WE ARE
ALIGNING. THESE THE ACTIONS THEY
WERE TAKING FOR WILDFIRE.
VEHICLE IN THE CONTEXT OF TRYING
TO MODIFY MILLION ACRES A YEAR
OF YOU KNOW FOREST OTHER
HABITATS. WITH OUR CLIMATE AND
BIODIVERSITY THESE OTHER STATE
GOALS MAKE SURE THOSE ARE WELL
INTEGRATED. TO THE WE CAN EITHER
DO GREAT THINGS FOR THE STATE OR
BECAUSE A LOT OF HARM ALONG THE
WAY- THIRD THING. IS WE REALLY
NEED TO MAINTAIN. AND INCREASE
OUR PROGRESS ON USING A FIRE PRO
ACTIVELY ON THE LANDSCAPE YOU
KNOW PRESCRIBED FIRE CULTURAL
FIRE. REALLY RECOGNIZING THE
CALIFORNIA IS GOING TO BURN WE
JUST CONTROL THE TIMING. AND
THAT'S GONNA REQUIRE A CULTURAL
SHIFT AND IMPLEMENT A MISSION
FIFTH WITH CAL FIRE AND OTHER
AGENCIES. THE LEGISLATORS DONE
GREAT THE LAST FEW YEARS. I HAVE
THE SOME YELLOW FLAGS ON THE
HORIZON IN TERMS OF
IMPLEMENTATION OF THIS PLAN ON
THE TABLE. YOU COULD READ LAST
LEE- WITH REGARD TO THE TASK
FORCE ALL JUST FLAG THAT- I'VE
BEEN TRACKING THEM VERY CLOSELY
I THINK IT'S GONE QUITE WELL.
AND HAVING AN ENTITY THAT
CROSSES BETWEEN THE FEDERAL THE
STATE THE LOCAL THE TRIBAL. AND
IS OUTSIDE OF CALL FIRE IN CAN
REALLY DRAW ALL THOSE DIFFERENT.
THREADS TOGETHER IS REALLY.
VALUABLE SO. THANK YOU THANK YOU
. GOOD MORNING MR CHAIRMAN
MEMBERS CHRIS MCKINLEY ON BEHALF
OF HUMBOLDT MENDOCINO REDWOOD
COMPANY THREE QUICK ITEMS- WE DO
APPRECIATE THE INVESTMENT THAT
THE LEGISLATURE AND GOVERNOR
HAVE MADE BUT ACTUALLY WOULD
CONCUR WITH MR MASON THAT. OUR
COMPANIES BELIEVE MORE SHOULD BE
DONE AND MORE SHOULD BE FUNDED.
THE SECOND IS AS WE APPRECIATE
THE COMMENTS OF MISS REAVIS AND
MISTER SMITH ABOUT BIOMASS. OUR
COMPANY HAS DONE AN ESTIMATE WE
THINK IN ORDER TO ACHIEVE THE
FIVE HUNDRED THOUSAND ACRES
ANNUALLY. THE LEGISLATURE SHOULD
BE LOOKING AT BETWEEN TWO
HUNDRED AND TWO HUNDRED FIFTY
MILLION DOLLARS. IN
TRANSPORTATION SUBSIDIES FOR
BIOMASS AND THEN THE THIRD ITEM
IS. BASED UPON WHAT WE HEARD
TODAY WILL CONTINUE TO ADVOCATE
FOR HAVING ONE PERSON IN CHARGE.
WHETHER IT'S ENSURING THAT WE
ACHIEVE THE FIVE HUNDRED
THOUSAND ACRES ANNUALLY. OR WHAT
NOT WE HAVE TO HAVE ONE PERSON
IN CHARGE. OF MY CLIENT LIKES
ALWAYS TALK ABOUT THE CHAIRMAN
OF THE BOARD SAYS WE CAN EITHER
HAVE FIRES WHEN MOTHER NATURE
WANTS THEM OR WHEN WE WANT THEM.
WE'VE SEEN THE DAMAGE WHEN
MOTHER NATURE HAS WANTED THEM
THE STATE HAS TO CONTINUE TO DO
MORE THANK YOU. THANK YOU. AND
WILL MOVE TO THE TELEPHONE LINES
NOW. OPERATOR CAN YOU HEAR ME.
YES SERVICE CHAIR THANK YOU
RIGHT TO JOIN THE COMMENT Q.
PLEASE PRESS ONE THEN ZERO ON
YOUR TELEPHONE KEYPAD ONCE AGAIN
THAT'S ONE FOLLOWED BY ZERO AT
THIS TIME. FIRST COUNT WE HAVE
SIX LINES IN Q. ARE YOU READY
FOR THE FIRST COMMENT. YES
ABSOLUTELY. THANK YOU LINE
THIRTEEN PLEASE GO AHEAD ONE
THREE. GOOD MORNING MR CHAIRMAN
MEMBERS MY NAME IS THE HIGHLAND
PELLETS AND WITH THE NATURE
CONSERVANCY THE NATURE
CONSERVANCY COMMEND GOVERNOR
NEWSOM IN THE LEGISLATURE
POPPING AND UNPRECEDENTED BUDGET
PACKAGE LAST YEAR SPECIFICALLY A
HISTORIC ONE POINT FIVE BILLION
IN FIRE PREVENTION AND FOREST
RIDGE LANE. WE ALSO THANK THE
GOVERNOR FOR PROPOSING A NEW ONE
POINT TWO BILLION INVESTMENT
OVER TWO YEARS WHICH
DEMONSTRATES ITS CONTINUED
COMMITMENT TO PROACTIVE MEASURES
TO ADDRESS CALIFORNIA'S MEGA
FIRED. HE'S ALREADY COMMITTED
INVESTMENTS AND THOSE BEING
PROPOSED ACCELERATE CLIMATE
PREPAREDNESS AND SHOW A
COMMITMENT TO BOTH PEOPLE AND
NATURE. HOWEVER TNT BELIEVES ARE
IMPORTANT CONSIDERATIONS FOR THE
LEGISLATURE WHAT ABOUT THE VALUE
WAITING THE GOVERNOR'S WILDFIRE
EXPENDITURE PLAN. I BELIEVE THE
PLAN SHOULD AT A MINIMUM BE
INCREASED TO TWO BILLION OVER
TWO YEARS. WE APPRECIATE THAT
THE TWENTY TWENTY TO TWENTY
THREE BUDGET PROPOSAL CONTINUES
TO SUPPORT CRITICAL INVESTMENTS
TO ADDRESS DROUGHT AND THE
INCREASING WILDFIRE THREAT.
HOWEVER THE WHAT THE PROPOSAL IS
MISSING DETAILS ON THE BUDGET
PACKAGE FROM LAST YEAR
PARTICULARLY ON ACTION TO
PROTECT BIODIVERSITY. WE LOOK
FORWARD TO WORKING WITH THE
LEGISLATURE AND THE GOVERNOR TO
ENSURE THAT A LONG TERM FUNDING
PLAN IS ESTABLISHED FOR WILDFIRE
DROUGHT RESILIENCE. AND
ADDITIONAL INVESTMENTS ARE MADE
IN NATURE BASED SOLUTIONS CRACK
BIODIVERSITY AND HELP CALIFORNIA
ACHIEVE ITS CLIMATE CHANGE
GOALS. THANK YOU SO MUCH THANK
YOU VERY MUCH. OUR NEXT COMMENT
IS FROM LINE THIRTY THREE ZERO.
THE MYSTERY CARE MEMBERS BRANDON
KILLING ON BEHALF OF THE
CALIFORNIA AIR POLLUTION CONTROL
OFFICERS ASSOCIATION. SENDING
THE EXECUTIVE OFFICER SMALL
THIRTY FIVE LOCAL AIR DISTRICTS
ADOPT STRONGLY SUPPORTS THE
PROPOSED BUDGET FUNDING OF TWO
MILLION EACH YEAR FOR TWENTY
TWENTY TWO AND TWENTY THREE AND
THEN TWENTY THREE TWENTY FOUR
FOR CONTINUANCE OF THE LOCAL AIR
DISTRICT PRESCRIBED FIRE
PROGRAM. WHICH IS HELPING TO
MEET THE GOAL OF CREATING ONE
MILLION ACRES OF VEGETATION
ANNUALLY BEGINNING TWENTY TWENTY
FIVE AS IDENTIFIED IN THE U. S.
FOREST SERVICE IN CALIFORNIA
MEMORANDUM OF UNDERSTANDING I
WANT TO POINT OUT THAT AS
WILDFIRE EVENTS BECOME MORE
COMMON AND SEVERE EMERGENCY
RESPONSE IS AN AREA THAT IS
REQUIRING SIGNIFICANTLY MORE
ATTENTION FOR LOCAL AIR
DISTRICTS. HOWEVER DUE TO THE
LACK OF FUNDING FOR THIS
ACTIVITY AND RESTRICTIONS ON HOW
LOCAL FUNDING CAN BE USED THEIR
DISTRICTS ARE LIMITED IN THEIR
ABILITY TO PROVIDE THE NECESSARY
RESOURCES AND ASSISTANCE TO DO
THE JOB. THE NEW BUDGET
APPROPRIATION FOR A DISTRICT
EMERGENCY RESPONSE RELATED
FUNDING. WOULD ALLOW US TO TRAIN
AND PROVIDE. RESOURCES ADVISORS
FOR CALIFORNIA THAT WOULD FOCUS
ON MONITORING AND CORDINATION
OF SMOKE ACTIVITIES DURING
ACTIVE WILDFIRE EVENTS INCLUDING
PUBLIC OUTREACH TO INFORM PEOPLE
OF HAZARDOUS CONDITIONS AND THEN
PROVIDE ADVICE ON APPROPRIATE
RESPONSE AND WE WOULD WELCOME
THE OPPORTUNITY TO WORK WITH YOU
ON THIS IMPORTANT ISSUE. THANK
YOU VERY MUCH FOR YOUR TIME
MISTER. CHAIRMAN MEMBERS THANK
YOU VERY MUCH. IN NEXT TO WE
HAVE LINE. TWENTY FIVE TWO FIVE.
GOOD MORNING CHAIRED MEMBERS
MADELINE ACT ON BEHALF OF THE
NUMBER OF CONSERVATION CLIENTS
INCLUDING SAVE THE REDWOODS
LEAGUE CAN FLOURISH IN OPEN
SPACE TRUST AND CALVINISTIC
PARKS FOUNDATION CALLING SUPPORT
THE GOVERNOR'S WILDFIRE AND
FOREST RESILIENCE PROPOSAL THANK
YOU. THANK YOU VERY MUCH. OUR
NEXT COMMON IS. ONE TWENTY NINE
TO NINE. THANK YOU AND GOOD
MORNING MISTER CHAIR THIS IS
MARK SPENCER MAKER CALLING ON
BEHALF OF THE WATERSHED RESEARCH
AND TRAINING CENTER I WE DO
SUPPORT THE GOVERNOR'S PROPOSAL
FOR OF WILDFIRES GOING INSPECTED
. I GOT THAT SUPPORTED THE
BASELINE AND REALLY ECHO THE
COMMENTS FROM PREVIOUS SPEAKERS
THAT WE REALLY NEED TO BE
INVESTING MORE. AYE WE'VE CORD
SUPPORT AND KNOW THAT WE NEED
MORE INVESTMENT IN FUEL
REDUCTION PROJECTS ARE
PRESCRIBED FIRE PROJECTS. BUT
ALSO CALL THAT WE NEED TO BE
REALLY RAMPING UP OUR
INVESTMENTS. AND NON VEGETATION
MANAGEMENT PROGRAMS AND AGENCIES
SO THE HOME HARDENING IT
ACTUATION READY MESS MOKRI
BILLIONS YOU KOW THE WILD FIRES
ARE GONNA KEEP COMING WE HAVE TO
BE INVESTING IN. THE COMMUNITY
READY MASS SIDE AS WELL. AND
LAST YEAR JUST LIKE REGISTER OUR
SUPPORT FOR THE R. AFFECTS FUND
. OF THIS PROGRAM REALLY GOING
ACCORDING NEED FOR PROJECT
PLANNING. AND CRIME. A AND
CAPACITY AND WE APPRECIATE THAT
THERE IS NO CURE FUNDING
PROPOSAL THANK YOU VERY MUCH
LOOK FORWARD TO THE CONVERSATION
THIS YEAR. THANK YOU. NEXT WE
HAVE LINE TWENTY TWO. MORNING
IT'S A CHAIR MEMBER OF THE
COMMITTEE OUR MONTHLY JOURNAL BE
APT TO CALIFORNIA BY MAP ENERGY
ALLIANCE. ISSUE ONE CAL FIRE TVA
LIKE IT'S EXPECTED SUPPORT FOR
CONTINUED FUNDING FOR THE
POOREST HELP GRANT PROGRAM IN
THE WOOD PRODUCTS AND BIO ENERGY
PROGRAM ABOUT THESE PROGRAMS
HELP MANAGE FIVE EXISTING
WORKFORCE DEVELOPMENT AND
TRAINING ALKALOIDS. WHICH IS IN
DESPERATE. NEED AND IF THEY'RE
IN THIS AREA. TBA ALL BECAUSE OF
THAT MILLION DOLLARS YUKON FOR
THE- OF BIOMETRIC. DID FUNDS
WILL TRY THE HARDER TO GET
MATERIAL AND HELP MOVE MORE DEAD
TREE PILED AROUND THE STATE TO A
BENEFICIAL BEES PROJECTS. HOW WE
ARE GEARED UP WITH THIS ITEM
WHEN IT'S APPROPRIATE THANK YOU
. THANK YOU. OUR NEXT COMMENTED
LINE. TWENTY THREE TO THREE-
GOOD MORNING CHERRY BLOOM AND
NUMBERS OR YEAH JUST GOOD
MORNING STEVEN MYERS ON BEHALF
OF THE CALIFORNIA ASSOCIATION OF
LOCAL CONSERVATION CORPS. THE
FOURTEENTH ST LOS CERTIFIED
LOCAL CORES ARE HAPPY TO SEE THE
CONTINUED IMPLEMENTATION OF A
WILDFIRE WORKS RESILIENCE
PACKAGE I AM VERY GRATEFUL TO BE
ADMINISTRATION AND THE
LEGISLATURE. LEADERSHIP ON THIS
AND THE WIDER ISSUE OF
ADDRESSING CLIMATE CHANGE WITH A
VARIETY OF STRATEGIC INVESTMENTS
WE'RE PARTICULARLY GRATEFUL FOR
THE TWENTY MILLION DOLLARS TO
THE CALIFORNIA CONSERVATION
CORPS FOR FUEL BREAKS AND FUEL
REDUCTION WORK THE LOCAL COURTS
WILL BE CRITICAL PARTNERS TO THE
CCC AND CREATING HIGHER
RESILIENCY ACROSS THE STATE.
FROM THE NORTH BAY TO SAN DIEGO
AND FROM THE COAST. TO THE
SIERRA. THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
THANK YOU. WE'RE GOING OUT TO
LINE. THIRTY THREE THREE THREE.
MISTER CHAIRMAN TERRY MCHALE
REPRESENTING CAL FIRE LOCAL TWO
EIGHT EIGHT ONE- THE DEVASTATING
FIRES IN THE PAST SEVERAL YEARS
OBVIOUSLY ARE A MATTER OF RECORD
HERE IS NOTHING TO SUGGEST THAT
THE NEW NORMAL WILL NOT
CONTINUE- THIS YEAR- WE
APPRECIATE VERY MUCH THE
GOVERNOR'S PROPOSAL IN THE
BUDGET AND THE ATTENTION MISTER
CHAIRMAN CHAIRMAN BLOOM. ON THE
COMMITTEE I CAME TO
INFRASTRUCTURE STAFFING INTO
PREPARATION FOR WE KNOW WILL BE
A VERY DIFFICULT HERE AGAIN
THANK YOU VERY MUCH AND WELCOME
BACK. THANK YOU. AND WE'LL GO TO
LINE THIRTY ONE THREE ONE.
MISTER TURN MEMBERS CHRIS ROSE
ON BEHALF OF HEALTH FOR.
CANACCORD DEPRECIATE THE
GOVERNOR'S WILDFIRE PREVENTION
COURT COULD GOING THE PROPOSAL
AND ESPECIALLY THE MULTI YEAR
APPROACH THAT HAS- CALIFORNIA
BELIEVES THAT A POSITIONAL
INVESTMENT THOUGH ARE NECESSARY
SPECIFICALLY CALIFORNIA THE
REQUESTED DIGITAL FUND SEEK
BEFOREHAND TO CREATE. AS THE
PROPOSAL FALLS SHORT OF WHAT'S
REALLY NECESSARY TO ADEQUATELY
RESPOND TO THE FIRE BEEN SURE
THAT KILL BENCHMARK TO BE
COMPLETED DURING THE OFF SEASON-
ADDITIONALLY THE ACCUMULATION OF
WOODY MATERIAL GENERATED THROUGH
FOREST MANAGEMENT PRODUCT
PROJECT IN POST FIRE RECOVERY IS
A GROWING PROBLEM AND THEREFORE-
BUT IT REALLY HAS TO BE
ADDRESSED AS PART OF THE STATE
FIRE PREVENTION EFFORTS
THEREFORE. CAL FOR ITS REQUEST
THE LEGISLATURE INCREASE. THE
FUNDING. AFTER PROPOSED FOR BY
ABOUT TRANSPORTATION GRANT
PROGRAM AT THE YOU AND WE LOOK
FOR TO WORKING WITH YOU. THANK
YOU VERY MUCH. AND THANK YOU
MISTER AT THIS TIME THERE ARE NO
FURTHER LINES IN Q. WELL GREAT-
THANK YOU OPERATOR FOR YOUR
ASSISTANCE AND JOB THAT BRINGS
OUR HEARING TO A CONCLUSION WE
WILL STAND ADJOURNED THANK YOU
ALL.